Don't throw up on themselves, no don't throw up, don't throw up, I'm here, oh baby, oh my sweet baby, don't throw up, don't throw up my baby, sweetie, are you there, are you there darling, I think so, oh no, okay
Oh really, oh, I swear this game has it's way, but not in a zoo, do we?
Um, sorry, that is so cheesy and I love it, I love that too, hello reflins you're not throwing up on yourself, you don't, let me wipe the sick off of you, no I have ultra low latency and it just so long to get up, I don't know why
Oh reflins, let me wipe the sick off you, you didn't need to throw up okay darling, oh dear, oh dear you got yourself in a right to his didn't you
Oh good morning, good evening good afternoon, now I do have the background audio playing a little bit if it's not too distracting
Mummy's sent voting to herself, no, what, I would never do something, oh that's so embarrassing, no
Your senses are gonna, good morning, are we ready for first test endurance stream? I'm a little bit nervous, I had a few heart flutters this morning when I woke up and I wanna say that when I woke up I mean literally 15 minutes ago
Hi mummy, hello reflins, I'm game and out of game, good morning, am I ready? Right, I'm just gonna say I had some heart flutters which were, I had to sit down, a few blood pressure issues but I think I'll be okay
I'll tell you if I don't feel well, but got my tea, got my beef, you know how yesterday when we played and who wants to be a millionaire, oh god it's been like so long since I played Runescape, I'm like ooh I'm about to be in like a complete baby on the game again
Right we'll ramble for a little bit and I'll get used to pulling out wings again, oh my god, okay, okay there we go, let's go
Right, for updates, I don't know, line up little reflins, for those of you who are on Patreon you have early access to an absolutely cursed audio called pregnant with you ASMR
Those of you who have listened, do I need to edit the stomach sounds quieter cause my stomach was popping off, it was like tchoo tchoo tchoo, it literally sounded like rrrrrrrrrr every time I was recording a freaking thing
It was 10 out of 10, it doesn't need any editing, that baby me, the father of me, stomach sounds will be the best part
Okay listen to it and it's perfect, okay it doesn't require any editing, I made that in like a tired haze, I was like oh yes I will make the oh
I'm going, okay if it's good then for those of you who are not on Patreon please don't worry that video is gonna be coming out in 20 hours
So at midnight in Australia, but only my part of Australia, but you have to guess which part of Australia, ooh I could be talking about Tasmania, ooh New South Wales, ooh Northern Territory, ooh no
At midnight is when I will release it, I'm gonna do it 2 hours before AC's usual uptime because I try and not do that
Mercy's yandere roleplay on YouTube is back up, she did want it taken down cause she wasn't happy with the subtitles and there was a font issue
And then it looked like for some reason the apostrophe came out like an eye, so whenever there was an apostrophe it looked bizarre, it looked like we were trying to form a new sentence and I'm like oh that never happens to me but
Thanks for the war, I didn't listen to it yet so I'll trust all the reasons, honestly got a tear down my face, it's very good
Oh wait was it like, is the word cathartic, oh I don't know what the word is, was it like really like oh mummies in Tasmania, could you imagine if I was Tasmanian bro
Call me the devil cause I'm Tasmania
It would be 12 hours of me trying to come up with a conversation to get these wines done
Now I don't know if there's a runescaper, a rune reefling if you will, a rune reefling for runescapers
No a rune reefling, yeah a rune reefling, okay
That can do the napkin math of 29,000 wines, not sure how long that's gonna take
But we can get it down real close to 99, whether or not we'll manage, fuck me yourself George if you want
I hypnotic Tasmanian cutfish, she said, same weight as an Alaskan billworm
What even is that, I'm sorry I actually don't know what that is, is that a type of worm in the ground, like it's literal
And they just call it a billworm cause it's a bit bigger than the average worm
A reef scape, aww that's cute, I like that name
2.4k wines an hour, right, shit
What does that mean, what is 2 times 12
There's gonna be a sixth stream for this cause I pissed about in the first and second ones so much, whoopsies
Okay this might not be the last one, but the next stringer and stream will be the last one, okay, real
You've got to lock in though, the chances of me locking in are rather low, I have to be honest, I won't be
I like taking it easy, it's about the journey and the yapping I got to do along the way, okay
It's a myth worm that's usually the same as almost as big as Australian fooders, okay
Mummy's gonna wine and dine, are you joking, I have like wine for literally the whole planet right now
Like actually I say I have wine for the whole planet, I also only have enough wine to satisfy Ireland for a day, so
Yeah when some you lose some, yeah when some you lose some, yeah this is nice
So is this the RuneScape gameplay, here's so much about it, I am so sorry if this is your first experience with RuneScape
This is a terrible entry to what RuneScape is, just consider this asatsu, how about that, just consider it asatsu
This is it, this is the gameplay, I am currently in a location called Edgeville Bank, okay
I am doing what's called winemaking and you have limited inventory slots
And this is it, there's more stuff to do we swear, like so there is more to do but we're alcohol maxing
I would estimate a Europace like 15k by the 12 hour mark
Yeah if this is your first thing, RuneScape is a numbers up kind of game via different methods
And there's like player versus player if you're like interested in being like I'm the best and there's like combat and stuff if you like that
But me, so I'll show you this, these are like the skills that you can get as you can see my membership ran out
Cause I didn't realise you didn't need membership to do winem
You can level up your skills to 99 and I have picked cooking because I'm a wham and I didn't want to pick anything else
But if I picked the Fletch in, I could have done it like in record time
Cause the reflins literally I'm so rich in game cause the reflins kept coming up to me and giving me all their money and I'm like
I don't know how to say thank you for this but now I'm rich in game
I mean 15, I don't know why I type 1500 hours, you're just feeling quirky like that
I didn't even question it, I just accepted it, I'm like yeah no I'm here for a good time like I'm ready to strap in
I just didn't question it
She is roleplaying her lore in RuneScape so she hypnotised people to help conquer the world
Sorry I have a really bad heart palpitation this morning, I don't know what's going on with me
Now once I reach 99, we might come back at a later date and do questing
Cause we were mucking about doing questing
Finn Dom and RuneScape, no then I start paying RuneS or whatever
Insert terminology would be paying RuneS
Oh it sounds like eww
But it's kinda like one of those games where just if you ever want something casual where you're not like
Well if you don't take it casually
Finn coming through
No, absolutely not
When it's like
Literally like
You're appealing to pay piggy
Shut the fuck up, I literally made pregnant with you ASMR
Go and actually get a fucking life, go and actually get a clue
You have absolutely no concept of what fun community you could possibly have
Because you're such a nasty little ratbag
Anyway, that's just my two cents
Good morning
Like literally you have no concept of how much love and cherishment that you can show towards both parties
For both streamers, from strongy to reefling and reefling to strongy, you know what I mean
And you will never have that experience
And not only do I gloat and you never having that experience
I equally feel sad that you will never have that experience of that unconditional love that is offered to you
Because the only way you can imagine it is an exchange of goods
And we're, it's not
We don't even have to
Good morning
Shadow Boxing
Level 99 Shadow Boxing
I fucking love being so good at Shadow Boxing
Take this
You know?
So I was punching my little hands
But yes, we are your friends
You
Who angered me?
Ah, it's just myself
I'm really good at doing it
Don't you worry
Fight the demons money
Fight the demons
But watch yourself
But show them who they're working with
Fight the demons
Watch yourself
Wow
I don't even know who that is
Is it someone controversial?
Please, I'm scared
Who's got balloons?
You have to poke someone's eye out with them balloons
Thank you the Tonysu
To the Super Chat
I'm so sorry, I don't know who
I don't know what it means
But I'm so, I'm so glad you guys like the pregnancy
So I can't wait to see all the comments being like
What?
And then, because everyone will click on it and be like
And then it's literally just me going
Fredy Zaka
Don't leave me
And
The thing is like
Oh my god
Oh my god, she's such a cash grab
I'm a puppet
I'm a sheep
I'm a cash cow
You bitches
Mesh
Based on henji
Oh no
Can I get a rundown?
Can I get a lore?
Can I get a Wikipedia article?
What's the deal?
What am I missing?
What is the context of this name?
And then
Oh wait, is it a
D's nuts in your mouth
But because of my accent that doesn't work
Joe, henji of Mars or something
Are you squidding me right now?
Eh
No!
Oh god
Thank you Vulcan Dynasty
That's actually hilarious
I am so sorry
I did not expect that
Thank you for the super chat
And letting me pop your
Boy cherry
For your super chat
That is hilarious
What, you need a little twang into the
Into the voice?
Eh, who's that going?
Eh, actually get to that spicy sausage
Did you guys like my
That was so funny
Because he went deaf?
How dare you?
What do you mean when I say
DADDY?
It doesn't make you
Your pintice shrivel
Oh no, you mean
Boss shrivel
I did a
I got a new short today
I actually did really well
Hold on
Wait, hold on
I'm linking the short
Yeah, it literally did 2 out of 10
For my most recent uploaded content
I literally did so well
Sorry, I'm making you all watch it
I don't care
I'll say what was it
You get right
Are you squidding me?
Say his name and he appears
I believe in Joe Hendry
HotClap
Is he a good boy?
Are you guys trolling me?
Right, fine
I'm looking it up
I swear to god
If it's a fucking
Like that fucking baby
Fucking pacifier
Beach over
Fucking mean that you guys
Always get me with
Is that when she imports us
Onto the farm
We have to pass a
Scott dialect test
To become citizens
Look it up
Actually part of the citizenship process
Aw
Real answer
Alright, I've looked up Joe Hendry
He's a wrestler
He wears blue shorts
Wait, what about him though?
Why?
Joseph Samuel Hendry
Is a Scottish professional wrestler
There is
Okay, he's Scottish
Go Scotland
Juicen
Was it
Edward's army
Running over the hills again
Got him really bad at one national anthem
And yeah, when it comes to zoos
I'm all over it like a rash
Short behaviour
Thank you zoos, good boy
And thank you Tainy Spainy
Okay, right
The tour meme
Bruh, I used to get caught
With the tour meme
All the fucking tape
I'm sorry
Oh my god
I didn't understand it
I was like, what's going on?
They'd be like
Oh my god
Someone's just done this
Absolutely catastrophic thing
And I'd be like
Oh my god, what is that?
And then click on Twitter
And it was like
Oh
Come on bruh
Don't fucking tour baby me
But she's adorable
But da da baby
But da baby
Okay
I can't believe
Actually
You know what
I should talk about VTuber fucking lore
That's the Rick Astley of VTuber lore
You know
Okay
I didn't know the Scotland national anthem either
No, no you do
You do
It's like
Fucking
Old Flare of Scotland
When will we see
I can't sing
You're like
It goes up even higher
I don't know why it's so high
But
And then
King Edward's army
To think again
It's literally straight up against England
We're like
Yeah
England
I'm sorry
You have tried to eradicate the Scots
For many a year
We've had enough
Let us have this national anthem
Okay
Never gonna give you up mummy
Never gonna
Did you see what Emmie did on Twitter?
She's putting her oiled up feetsies
For 20K
Wait
Hold on
What do you mean?
What did my little sister do?
Is it on her main or is it on her own?
She put it on the right like
Mercy keeps accidentally putting stuff on the wrong thing
Is it on her own?
Oh hi
Emmie
Actually I just ordered Emmie's artwork
Because she's getting
She's getting two song covers
And then they're getting anime
And she drew one
What the fuck
Is my little
30 minutes ago
Wait, scabity
Oh no someone clicked Emmie
Sorry, the Emmie didn't say scabity
There's some cut there
Going to buy alcohol
Someone bought me
Em covers
Of a certain variety
Hold on let me do this one handed
I'm holding my cup of tea before it gets cold
Do you think you sly?
I know what you're doing
Wait it must be on her main then
What did she do?
She did a pop up stream
And she's doing more hand cam streams
Never, she would say she would be the author
On her own a couple of days ago
The drawing?
The drawing
She forgot her pentagram
No
I don't know how to say how she got
Her tattoo slash marking
But it was at your death
That's how she obtained
Oh my god
Someone drew the reeflings
It's the fucking
The fucking thing
Oh my god hold on
Hold on
Hold on where is it
Show yourself
Oh my god
Hold on
I literally just saw this
Wait hold on fuck
I need the pointer thing
Oh my god
I've already forgotten
The wee
Raccoon's name
Wait why have I forgotten his wee name
I've already forgot
Oh look at you wee darling
Thank you the cutest
Oh no
Got to gee your bath again
Sai because you're all dirty
Oh my god it's so cute
I can't handle it
I love it
This is like undeniably
If you're a pinata
Don't crack
Don't crack his open
We have ink not candy inside
We've a pinata
Right I'm going to drink my tea
Before it gets unbelievably cold
Well it's already room temperature
I tried my best
I'm so bad at doing that in time
Right and we will get ready to watch
The VODs okay
Just let me rant a little bit
Let me ramble a little bit
First we have no management
To send me my
See I get abused
I get abused
I don't
I get everything last
Unlike the
All the girls
Get all their stuff done first
So I get mine done last
I'm getting it
Right are you ready
For what next week's schedule is
Are you ready
Steady boom
Okay
Aha there you go
I
I'm going to play a childhood game
Called Blinks now I got stuck on level 2
In Blinks as a child
Because I was such a child
And I couldn't figure out what I was supposed to do
So I'll be a curious one
We are going to then do the classic
Ace Mar Stream and then I'm forcing you
To watch Beauty and the Beast with me Disney style
Who goes out
And then we are doing back to back
Lego Lord of the Rings
We're going to 100% it
I mean I'm such MLG pro that I know
How to 100% the game
And then we're going to play Pagel
I remember playing
The Trial of Pagel
On Xbox 360
And
I remember making a particular
Noise that was like boom boom boom boom
Like that and then like the more you got
The higher the pitch went
So I was like you know what actually
Let's get a shot like let's actually give Pagel
Pagel a shot right
And then I have a member's
Handcam Ace Mar Stream
It's a test
I know that sounds bizarre
Why would you need to test Ace Mar
I bought
A mannequin prop
That I might either make a video
Or a stream about but I wanted to test
That you guys first like I feel comfortable
Testing it as a like thingy
That is such I remember
That so much like oh you'll get like
So much you'll get gamer score
If you like do this or look up my youtube channel
That's such a good mod
That person is saying an Xbox
Reference before you think they're being weird
That is an Xbox
Reference
We are then doing a mysterious
Dead by Daylight collab
Outside Vialeur
Those outside Vialeur
Now please do check
The time on Saturday
It is not my usual
Start time
The Dead by Daylight collab
Sets me one hour
Later
Than I usually start
And I believe that will be
Finished and wrapped up in two hours
Okay two hours
And then
We'll play Fortnite
I think Fortnite
Unless you guys want to play a different
And then
We're gonna test
1v1 chest in a member stream
And if that's successful
Then the following week
I'll do
1v1 chest in general
If it's just a nightmare
I don't know if it should be one of those things
Where like I'm not allowed to go offline until I win
Because yeah
Is LEGO 31st
Starting late for any reason
Yes
Oh that's thank you
LEGO Lord of the Rings is starting
Two hours later because
That's when the group meeting for Vialeur
It's the best time slot for everyone to meet up
Hold on
Let me sip my tea
I'm gonna finish my tea, give me one second
Yes the best time
For everyone to meet up for the
Meeting
Vialeur meeting is actually right when I stream
Because it's not too late for AC
But because everyone is American
And Canadian outside of that
It means the best time
Is right on my time slot
But we are playing LEGO Lord of the Rings
So hopefully it's worth the wait
It's a fantastic game
Absolutely fantastic game
I watched the VOD for that stream
Oh do apologize unfortunately
But
Yeah so
Two streams are not at the regular
Time
Wed and stay
Two hours later
And then Mysterious Dead by Daylight
I was originally gonna come on for an hour
But I was like oh that does
They make any sense like it just does
But
I hope you enjoy the people
I'm playing that Mysterious collab with
I have to fucking play Dead by Daylight
Again
Because I've not played it
Apparently there's like a billion new killers
A billion new
IP things that they've bought
The rights to use
Apparently there's a billion new perks
There's new systems in place
And I'm like
Like I have to play a tutorial
Because they've changed everything in Dead by Daylight
They did like an overhaul from the old game
And I'm like shit I'm old game
Dead by Daylight I'm not new game
Dead by Daylight
Check me
More like strong again
Check me pressed
Oh you don't wanna
You don't wanna
Well I thought we could
Maybe you know
But I guess not
Jeez
Dead by Daylight learning stream win
Well I'm actually gonna play it
Offline
Just
To try I mean
And impromptu
Dead by Daylight stream
Although I'm trying to get all my ASMR
Collabs out the way
So I've kinda discovered that after stream
I have like enough energy to do one thing
So offline win
He tried nice one
It's like going back home to a small town
And now it's just a grand central station
Literally I'm like I can't believe I have to say
I'm like old school Dead by Daylight
Like I don't recognise any of the systems
That are in place I'm like fuck
I have to brush up on my gameplay
Can they be embarrassing via Lora
I need to prove that I'm a gamer oh lord
Give me decisive strike I don't have the perk unlocked
Please I need self heal and Claudette please
That's what the meta used to be
You know
Maybe we could do an impromptu
Dead by Daylight
Is there a way for me to get
You guys in my lobby in Dead by Daylight
Without having to add you on stream
Surely Dead by Daylight understands
That it's a well streamed game
Surely
Okay I've almost finished my cold cleaner
Playing old mate on new mail
There's a code system
That we can do custom lobbies
Oh maybe
Okay okay
Maybe we make fortnite
Dead by Daylight
Snipes
Don't ever use self-care
It's like really whack now
I remember it used to be like
When it was tier 3
It was like 40 seconds to heal yourself
And you didn't have to rely on teammates
And that was like
I don't even know how the ranking system looks
When back in my day
It used to be like
20 to 1
And if you were rank 1
It was like ooh really good
The lore you were
Ooh not as good
I suppose one solution is to add reeflings to our friends
And then remove them all at the same time
Even though
The account is fully private
I'd really worry
About brain worms being like
Oh mummy added that reefling
But didn't add me as a reefling
She hates me
And again
I do want to be like
Would you rather a streamer
Add anything like that at all
But I do want to be considerate
I don't just want to drop
They're like
You know
They're brain worms
Yes I'm aware of your brain worms
You guys are in trouble honestly
But yeah
It's about time
It's about power
Those reeflings don't speak for us
I just don't want to hurt anyone
I feel like if you're hanging out with me
We'll just be chilling
You know
I just want it to be good
I don't want anyone being like
She hates me specific
No this is exactly what I'm talking about
And after that
On Sunday Halo Combat Evolved
I will
Tell you my dad's letter
Now remember my dad's a guy
So it's not exactly
A sauna or something
I'll bring a tear to your eye
But that's because I'm a wuss
But I'll tell my dad's little letter to you
But if you want the TLDR
It's basically thank you for looking after my daughter
When I couldn't
Because you know distance and stuff
When I was going through really bad stuff last year
Because obviously
I explained to my dad the situation
And all of that and he was like
You just
I kid you not he said the sentence
You just stick to your own
And it was like
My own is like my refunds
And it was really nice
He was like you just stick to your own
And I was like fuck yeah stick to my own
We got his approval we're in
Basically
He's happy
Very happy
Because my dad's internet
So heavy and all of that
Oh my god sorry
My dad is a wee gossip by the way
He
My dad absolutely loved the
Linus Tech's
Drama that went down
So he likes watching PC's be built
And I was like you might really like this game
PC build simulator but he's not downloaded it yet
And I'm trying to get him to do it
Because I think he would actually thoroughly enjoy the game
But like so he watches Linus Tech
Tip to like vicariously
Build PC's through him
Because he likes the unique designs
Or like the challenges he actually
Really likes the challenge of building a good
PC because my dad built my PC
For me and he built his like
He's done it like three times for his
Now
And he did it once for me
And then he also ripped out my
Yeah that was another time
But it was a mistake
Your dad sounds so cool
I love my dad
Like bogus champus
I think my dad's definitely
Like laid back and like
You know I already kind of divulged
This information but my mom and dad
Are punks and
Are in their younger days
You know these days they're kind of more
Just working hard
And the sister type thing
But
They were punks and
If you were a punk back then
It means you fucking leave
Let people live and fucking
Let them be type shit and
You know you're not
You realize who the problem is
And it's not the community
The community's been diverted
To look at these problems that aren't real problems
You know like the biggest example
I can give you in the UK right now
Is a terminology
Called benefit scroungers
A benefit scrounger is someone who claims
Benefits that might not necessarily
Need it
However
Counterpoint
Billion
Billion dollar companies
Not paying taxes
And someone getting less than
Minimum wage via the government
I wonder
I wonder who the problem is
In this situation
Curious curious
And basically
The people's
Why is the landscape always
Turns into tinfoil hats
It's not even tinfoil hats
That's the worst part
It's not
Right I need to stop
But anyway
To be punk means
Socially that you are aware
That community
Good society
Good government
I don't know
And also being
Very wary of news media
If you haven't
Noticed
News media
Sways public
Opinion public
Approval
Of certain things public thingies
And all that
Watches tinfoil hats
We want them being good
Not so sure about that one
Wait
Who's being good
No I'm not
Billion dollar companies feel so bad
Yeah
I learned of a recent one
Vodafone in Australia
Got a 50 million dollar government grant
They
Reported I think 13 billion
Profit
Do you want to know how much taxes they paid in Australia
No
I'm going to give you a hint
It's less than one dollar
Oh
But they get to make all that profit on the people
But yeah
That
And before anyone's like
Strongy strongy
You did that short where you complained about holding
30% back for the tax money
Again again I would like to redirect
Your fucking eyeballs
And your wrinkly brain
Billion dollar
Billion in zero taxes
But the little commoner
The little peasant
That isn't even a droplet
In the sea
Complaining about taxes is a problem
Anyway
I want to do that
0.99
You're giving it far too much
Far too much
Did you watch friendly George's
Is it one about the quality of houses in Australia
And is someone who has rented in Australia
Yeah
Absolutely
It is disgusting not to mention
If I had a dollar for every real estate agent
That was like oh this rentals
Fine this rentals fine
I'd be so rich
First things first
Now when we all get condemned to hell
Okay first things first
Real estate agents you're going first
Okay
First you can go into the worst part
Of it because
Bruv
Why are they so slimy
Honestly
Don't upset yourself mummy
I'm getting rabid
I need to watch my gen mates
German politics starting to get torn up for the same thing
Well
You know how good the Belgian governments are
Do you know how good the Belgian governments are
Do you know if the Belgian government
Gets
Guilty
Found guilty of corruption
Everyone
Has
To fork in
Everyone has to fucking resign
Like
Noriboshi
I'm so sorry but you're becoming a mod
Get fucked
Thank you very much fang
Wait what am I trying to say
Everyone has to resign if a scandal has occurred in Belgium
And I'm like
Belgium is probably the only country that does something along those lines
Oh thank you
Literally get right
It's only going to be like
Bleh
Literally you guys vomit when I'm not here
And I vomit when I start getting too deep
Into the rabbit hole
Real answer
Um
I've been wrenched
Are you in game
What are you doing here
You're in game
Why are you in game
I don't know you're in game
Oh that's so good
Hi
You're a little nerd
Um
The way I see it is
Well it has like 5 million dollar generational wealth
Speaking generational wealth
I have 20 million to my name
I also have crusty socks
Everyone's getting scared
Yeah let me try here sorry
I wanted to be here to cheer you on
Bro we're getting there we're almost there
We're not we're not going to do this stream but we're almost there
Unless I did an endurance stream
Where I popped up another waiting room as well
And just balled to the wall
There's no escape and ruinscape
You only take breaks in between it
Right
Now that I've had my absolutely mental tinfoil hat
Ran
Will I quickly check Marshmallow before we
Start watching my gen mates
In the background
Oh my god I have
Marshmallows
Yeah
It's almost like the same beach
It was like old school runescape
It is a classic game
I'm not sure if it's the most engaging to watch
Like I mean
I'm sure for the community
Or sort of like yeah play smart
Do ASMR instead of fucking
Do a little bit of skill and whine
Eh
I also really have no levels
And no skills so I can't trade things to people
Oh yeah you need like in order to
Not be identified as a bot
You need to do missions and stuff
But to be honest the bots just do them anyway
So
Oh
Reeflin said two hours ago
Crying happy tears right now
Listening to the pregnant with you early access
You did a fantastic job
I'm so glad it was like
An emotional outlet for you
I thought it was cute
Hopefully
I did
Do like a little soft breathing
At the end as well just if someone wanted to fall asleep
In the womb if
Edgeville the Denial Reeflin is not looking
Too hot right now
That's actually really funny
I'm glad we're all like on the same page
We're all like yeah fuck it let's fuck this one particular
Reefling up
I'm literally so cute
Boom
Eh
Also it might have been the same month
But Emmy also ovulated
Why are we talking about my little sister ovulating
What's going on here
What also it might have been the same day
But Emmy ovulated on the 5th
Maybe it's the same time you did
Actually I will confess
Emmy did
Ovulate near the same time as me
I think she started and then I did it
And I'm like fuck the Bluetooth device
She's connected
I was like oh damn
Shawnee can you tell us when you're ovulating in August
When it happens
I'm trying to work it out and establish a pattern
Oh I have bad news for you
You can't get a pattern out of me
I am
I am rotating
I don't
It's not like it picks like the 14th
Every month or whatever I'm rotating
I'm just so
I'm just so cool like that
I'm not like the other streamers
My ovulation
Cycles
Absolutely
Shotting behaviour
Actual shotting sorry but it is
Em
Hi Shawnee, hi Weefling
I got into your hit noses stream
Finally I'm writing during the aftercare
I'm writing during
So this is fresh I missed your control
More than I thought I had
I truly love you love me too and I mean that so much
I've been listening to hypnosis over a decade
And I once have I
Drilled I mean you're drill
I drilled, cried, or gone so far under
I didn't have any intrusive thoughts the first two just happened now
I felt the tiniest bit of wetness
On the side of my mouth and it almost snapped me out
And I wiped it off without thinking I barely remember
What caused it but I remember you were saying something
Really nice and kind and now
I just feel relief and a cry so there's two
Of my hypnosis how are you
No wait wait wait wait
How have you consumed the media for ten years
And then me just going
Oh I really want to have a go at this because
I really enjoy hypnosis personally
And I popped two cherries
No way
I don't know I was
Fucking hell that's such a compliment
Thank you
That's such a compliment
I really hope you take the third one
I feel a little warm all over I love you so much
I love you too little wreath
I'm so glad you can enjoy that
Oh my goodness
Bro I was like so nervous to do it
Another reason
Aww
That's what's mean
That wreathlings the two crying stream
2.0
You can't be nice to me
For those of you
Who weren't lurking in the shadows in the membership stream
It was just the
Classic ASMR stream
Going to that so after ten minutes
But basically a wreathling left me
A really nice message
And it was like very sincere
And heartfelt and it made me cry
Because
I'm like used to like
All the tentacle and inco-references
Which I love and adore and like
I love teasing each other
Back and forth with it
And I just didn't expect it
And then
Oh someone's recommended me a list
Of games to play on
Bansley thank you so much
Oh my god thank you
Because I literally
I do not really play games
So thank you that's actually really helpful
Like unironically that's actually really helpful
Waa
Hi strongy I enjoyed the presentation
Streamy did it was nice to catch a vod
Oh I had to catch a vod
That's okay don't worry about it
I know I don't really stream at the bestest
The bestest of times
And the worstest of times
I don't necessarily stream at
I wanted to bring up a correction though
It's more than likely
You misspoke or
It meant something different
When the swimmers finally reach the beach ball
That's actually a really good one
It's not the first one who reaches it
That starts the next phase
It's like a battle royale
This is absolutely true
And you're absolutely correct
I didn't want to get into the nitty gritty of it
But
What briefly you say and he's absolutely true
A load of
Swimmers can go around the beach ball
It's Hoover's first to crack
The beach ball
But whenever you
You know you're trying to say it can get through
It is technically
Yes you're absolutely right
No you're absolutely just fine
Maybe it's just me diving further into the
Topic than you intended
But damn does my actual order
Doesn't get me fixated on clarifying points
No don't worry about it honestly
Please don't worry
There's also a very high chance
That I say something wrong as well
I'm presenting it as like
Education and truth and all that
I'm very dumb so please don't worry
Don't worry at all thank you Reefling
Cheers no thank you Reefling
I wake up I think about you
Even after having awful nightmares
Oh Reefling you had a nightmare
Love you strongy love you too little Reefling
Hope you're okay after your nightmare
Always remember that your
Your nightmares
That you have in the morning
It'll dissipate and then you'll start to forget them at night
Like over time it'll dissipate
And obviously if it's fresh
You'll notice it more but as
That beach ball literally are you an egg
Are you an egg
Give that
Reefling a honorific title
Every time you think you're worthless
Remember you fought a battle royale against
A million of other years in one
For y'all
And you also perish your entire
Bloodline
As well in one
A little swoop
I'm lucky that at the moment I'm done with the work
That strongy streams an hour later so I can just make food
And eat while I watch mommy
I think
That would be like
A horrific timing
Unironically
Get off work
Obviously cause you're a guy
You need to do your post work jobby
So you sit on the toilet for 30 minutes
You know
Release a future
Wash your hands
Go fix yourself a quick dinner
Open up stream life's good
Simple as literally
Yeah lucky
I'm so lucky lucky
She knows
It's all over tiktok
It's literally sorry
I brainwrote so much
That I sometimes get tiktok for girls
Like instead of my usual memes
Posts and all that
I normally get like brainwrote
Like stuff
But sometimes it's like
It's really cringy but it's like
Ladies
Does your fella
Come home from work
And take 30 minutes
In the bathroom
To himself
And then all the comments are like
Oh my god yes
What is with that
Why does he take so long
And I'm just like
I don't know maybe cause he wants to
Take a big fucking jobby in the comfort
Of his own home
Who wants to
I don't know
I don't know why it's so hard to be empathetic these days
I don't know why no one can put them
Imagine being out at work
Your bowels
Are pulling on you for 8 hours
Screaming for a jobby
You refuse to bomb the
Work toilet
As a courtesy
You refuse to do that
And then you want to get home
And you want to decompress from your day
And take a wee jobby
And go on your phone
And just tune out
Tune out for 30 minutes
Why is that so much to ask
Am I going mental? Am I going schizophrenic?
I literally feel like that zombie cat gift
Where there's a black cat and it's going
Like
Bro
Why is it so hard?
Boss makes a dollar, I make a dime
That's why I take a jobby
On company
I know I messed up I didn't want to swear
Big fat jobby
Being a good wage worker is like being a good
As they say
I mean yeah
No you're completely sane
Couldn't be me I'm not holding that
That's a char
Reefling
Bombs the work toilet
Doesn't say anything
Stinks out the entire floor
And then goes back to desk as if nothing happens
Everyone's like gagging and coughing
Like
They're like someone's like crawling along the floor
To get to the water cooler
To try and like splash water on them
And all that
You know the printer's just jammed
Even though it doesn't breathe oxygen
It jammed anyway
And in response to the orders that had been released
In the office
That's funny
Biological warfare
Yeah casually committing biological warfare
Via the toilet at work
Oh I thought we were talking about the different
Kind of mail time
No no no a jobby's to
Be a big fat shite
What did I walk in on?
Oh don't worry about it
Why guys need 30 minutes
After work to just decompress
And take a big jobby
Shocking behaviour
That crawling won't work
Heavier gases go lower
Oh
I thought smoke inhalation went up
Hmm
Cause I know what came out of that ass was fire
That's absolutely disgusting
Don't ever speak again
Reefling
I just wanted to ask
Why do you care about us so much
Oh no wait what does that mean
I'm not asking it to be mean or anything
Like
That it's something I'm really curious about
It would be so easy
To just do the bare minimum to keep us around
But you go above and beyond for people
And do
Things you're
Under no obligation
To do but do anyway
Hold on I need to read this whole thing before
I bite into it
Obligation to do anything anyway
But you put so much effort into
Making everyone happy and building people up
Even at your own expense sometimes
You don't treat men like there's some
Evil vile disease on this planet
You go out of your way to make them feel like
They are in a safe space to relax
And enjoy what they like without
Condemnation
I hope my question doesn't come across negatively
No okay now that you've specified that
The start caught me off guard
I genuinely think you're a beautiful person
So please don't change
Who you are
At your core and keep up the hard work
Love you mummy, love you too Ruthlyn
Right let me reread the questions
Cause I don't even know where to start
Why do you care so much about us
How do I even start
Ruthlyn how do I even start
Bro I'm gonna gap for like two hours straight
Why do I care so much
Where do you even start
Let's give that reef on a hug
How do you even start
I don't even know how to tackle that
I mean it depends how far back you wanna go
If you wanna go to last year
I could have been
Eating up and spat out
I was welcomed with
An open hand
And I was literally
Explained how to be a
VTuber okay
So rather than being like
This disgusting hole
Once like some easy VTuber money
Or whatever terminology it was like
Okay fuck it one we're gonna
Toe my baby her ass and two
We're actually gonna teach her how to be a VTuber
And it wasn't
Like I
Don't think you understand how
Easily I could have been
Like just
Absolutely dog piled
But you reeflings didn't do that
You were like oh no
Come on like right so this is how it's done
Like when you're talking
In chat here's a rule you don't say
People's name unless it's a donation or whatever
Okay and you guys had the patience
And then I did an ASMR stream
And I interrupted myself to
Respond to donos and then rather
Than being like man fuck this
So unprofessional I'm just gonna watch
Someone else that knows what they're doing
Instead it was like okay right next time
Stroni um
Leave it all to the end that's all you need to do
Just leave it to the end oh okay okay okay
Right um
What's another thing right don't play
Games on stream that you have an inclination
That you're not gonna like oh right okay
Okay got it got it
I will not feel forced to play games
Or obligated to play games that I don't like
It creates an
Pleasant atmosphere okay okay what's next
Um
You know like oh baby
Stroni got grim now she's the grim
Aren't real and true
Um
Like these are examples of how
Open you guys were
To me
And I will never
Be able to repay
That and I actually
Do genuinely mean that
You might be like hey Stroni
You're going crazy doing like 100 collabs
Of VTubers and you know we get to see
The video or you're doing like
1k thank you
Or meme ASMRs of this or if we ask
For an audio you're more than open to getting it
The truth of
The matter is
I will never
Be able to repay the true
Kindness that you have shown me
Unconditionally so the
The best I can do
Is
You know say it out loud
That
What you've done for me
I can you know
Say that I love you because I think it's fair to say
We love each other I don't I don't think anyone
Would come into stream and be like
Oh Stroni doesn't like the reef lens
Reef lens don't like Stroni like
I don't think anyone would ever
Say anything of that accord you know
Stroni was groomed into VTuber and it seems
That apprentices surpassed the master
Stop this one
Um like
That's like
Kind of at a surface level
But the deeper layer is like
I can never repay the way
That I was so
Accepted because
But I'm also aware
This is where like my kind of tinfoil
This kind of comes in slightly
It's not too much tinfoil but
I'm also aware of
Social rejection
I'm also aware
Of brainworms
You guys actually taught me about brainworms because I didn't
I didn't understand it because I didn't really
Have it like if I don't have it
I don't understand it that well
Um
It's my first time hearing of this as well as a new
You've left
You've let one of my favourite VTubers
To bloom beautifully
A lot happened in a month
That's all I'm gonna say
Who's a fucking whirlwind
Anime wound plays RuneScape
Oh fucking delicious
Um
Where was I? I've lost my point
Ah where was I? Go back
Um right hold on
Let me go through your sentence again
It's easy to do the bare minimum to keep
You around
I am so serious when I say
You do not have to give me money
You do not have to fucking
Feel obligated to show up
You do not have to be like
Oh strongy was nice to me so I'm gonna watch her streams
Even though I would rather watch another
VTuber or another
Consume another type of content
I truly want
The best for you
And if in the moment the best
For you is to consume another content creator
So you can de-stress from the day
You can learn something new
You can get distracted from
The world at large
I don't get insulted like that
I don't get jealous like that
Um just
I just want the best for you
And I think we can all
Agree that
In our kind of
For those of us that are in western society
Obviously I can only really speak
For Scotland if I'm being honest
Um
I think we can all nod our heads and agree
And say there's definitely
Issues with socialization
And men and showing
Um affection
Being shown affection
Um as soon as
As soon as you pass childhood
You know
You no longer get hugs, you no longer get kissed
On your cheek by family members
Um it's all handshakes and
Yeah yeah yeah
And you know it's almost as if
As you grew up in your
Childhood you were told
To
Open up like a pathway
In your brain of
You know you'll feel big emotions
You'll be angry as you grow up
You'll feel this, you'll feel that
But as soon as puberty strikes
It's like almost all of society go
Uh no hold on a minute
You're not allowed to go down that pathway
You're not allowed to emotionally develop
You're not allowed to socially develop
To um feel the very
Natural need
For attention
The very natural need
For community
It's almost like you get shamed and shunned for it
You know
Um type thing
And I
Personally like this is just
My two pennies and my two cents
Like
If
Like you know
Uh
It's hard like
I guess community, community is the word
Okay community is the word
We might
Not be able to do a refland farm
Okay I might not be able to hook you up
To the milken machines that's awful
When I'm trying to be serious
But
What I hope that I could offer you
In exchange of
Um your time
Your attention as a sense of community
A sense of belonging
A sense of definitely not
Being used either
Um
I think that's very
Important I think there is
Um a lot of
Kind of stigma
When it comes to a guy
Consuming a girl's content
As well I could maybe go into that
In an educational stream so
Terminology sorry I'm like proper
Going on a ramble here um
So ah you're uncorking
My balls I feel tears
Oh darling
It's it's hard
It's hard having
That pathway closed off to you
For how many years
For from years upon years
Upon years you know
Feeling that societal pressure
Of you're a man
Um no more emotions
Um the only kind of
Emotions actually I've seen it on tiktok
This is a kind of tiktok I see
Is a girl will record
Her boyfriend
And um he's like
Hugging up and being all snuggly
In a baby voice with her
Um and rather than
That being appreciated
As a moment of affection
Where the guys defenses
Are all down it turns
Into oh you caught me on camera
Moment he he he oh no I'm a macho
Man and it's like no that
Moment is
That guys
You know way to drop his
Barriers for the first time in
However long because
Um you know you only get that unconditional
Love via family
Growing up now obviously
You could come into the argument that
Some people have shit family it's just facts
It is an absolute
Dice roll gamba
Okay um
It is an absolute
Dice roll gamba if
Um you know
It's your family
You're gonna look after you the way it is
So for me personally my family
Hug kiss on the cheek that's how you do it
How you been missed you right
Let's you know get the family together
Because it's been a month it's been a while
That's kind of the thing um
You know um
Yes that's actually really
Important as well like
Emotional
Outlet
What is socially acceptable
For a man to experience
So a man's allowed to feel anger
But that emotion
Is such a negative experience in itself
You know I missed the start of stream
This is gonna make no fucking context
From what I'm going on about
Um a man is
Socially acceptable to experience
Anger now anger is a
Stressful emotion
It is a fight
Or flight
Reaction you make sure nervous system
Thingy and why is that the only
Thing that's like socially acceptable
Or why is it
That is only straight up
Neutral
You're only allowed to be neutral
You're only allowed to be angry
And you know
Like
I'm wondering if I can
Hold on let me see if I can pull up this chart
I'm not even kidding sorry
I'm like straight up going in the middle of an education stream
I'm like doing education
Straight up in the middle of this fucking thing okay
Right
Okay this is a
Looks a bit simplistic for the
Um
I don't know this one looks pretty complicated
And it's a shitty website that has like a billion things
Oh god can I
I'm even gonna be able to read that
Um god there's so much fish on the floor
Geez I wonder if it's because of this
Cuttlefish
Okay hold on
Why is that even smaller
Bro this I'm
Oh well
Hold on you didn't hear that because my desktop is
Muted but I didn't let me save
The image
Can I save this image
Or do I need to go on your fucking dodgy website
Oh get to fuck man
Get to fuck
Oh right I'm just taking a screenshot and fucking
M.S. Pain I'm sorry I'm M.S. Pain
But what is going on
I want to achieve one thing
Please
Okay here
Okay it's for kids
But it applies to adults
Because adults are just growing up kids
Okay relax I know
Don't you have any stories trying to fucking save your children
No mother fucker stop it
Well
That sucks just to happen
Did I show anything that
Was supposed to be shown I don't think so
I think it was fine
Jumped air I don't even know how that opened
Up on the floor
Dogs
I don't know if I did anything
I have no idea
No not the curtain
Time is broken now
What wait what should
Stop you're making me nervous
Stop
What should hold on
Wait I need to go back and see it hold on
Right okay
What
Fucking education
Education
Okay no nothing should
As far as I can tell
What a stupid fucking thing
Honestly
Sorry right we're safe
We're safe sorry I really
Can't stand that fish like
Don't give me a heart attack okay right
Back to my
Massive rant literally this is all
Because of like one question
It's not even a rant is it
No it's not a rant that's not how it works
Okay so back on
Societal factors okay so
What are men
Allowed to feel in society
And we have anger okay and if we look at
Anger look at what negative
Associated
Emotions come with
That like what the fuck are you talking
About like hostile
Enraged agitated furious
Disgusted annoyed frustrated
Why is this the vod
Timer is gone Bernal
Was not expecting deep emotional counseling
This stream I'm passionate
About I have to admit I'm passionate about it
Because
I have consumed these topics in the past
Where it's like
You know women came
The
They argue that like
Men have it easy and don't want to listen
To anything that men might not have
Easy on and you know
I'm going to go out on a limb here
And say if someone without a willy
If a guy with a willy you know
Tells me you know what
I actually really had a rough time
And then I read it again online
And then I read it for like the billion time online
Who am I going to listen to
Me who's had no experience having a winky
Or
The guys online that are like
Hey I have it rough hey I have it rough
And it's like
And especially sadness
It has to be hidden
It has to be hidden you're not allowed
To feel sad you're not allowed to feel upset
You're not allowed to cry
Like fuck me at the most
Basic human instinct
Level do you know what crying actually is
It's you getting
Stress out
It's you getting stress out at the
Is the function of crying
Is to lower
The cortisol levels in your body
Because having a
Buildup of cortisol is
Bad for your body's function
Okay at the most basic
Level
Crying is to reduce your stress
And holy fuck
Societies like guys are not even allowed to cry
Like fuck it now
Like
It is a bit much I have to admit
It is a bit much so
You know
A community I feel like
I don't know it's like a deeper word than that
But holy fuck at least hopefully
I can offer some sort of outlet
And you know there's no judgment
And there's no this there's no that you know
Pop off mummy
Literally
How's that going
It's going good I'm currently doing a
Demonstration on
Why guys need jobbies for 30 minutes
And we've got an emotional chart
Of
Yes
No
I ain't crying in public though
Only angry a lot
Now
If a guy is seen happy
What's the first thing society says
If a guy genuinely seems a static
A happy
What's the first thing society goes oh you've had a bj in the morning
Haven't you
And it's like oh a fucking god
Can someone not just be fucking happy
Why does it have to be like some sort of
Seeking reward
Fucking
Sexual encounter type thing like oh you're happy
You must have had you know a little cheeky
What what
Or if you're too happy in the wrong way
Exactly no you said it
You said it
If you're too happy in the wrong way
You're seen as
Seen as a homosexual because you're
Being effeminate in your emotions
And you are fucking
Mercy I'm so sorry you're coming in the middle
Of a schizophrenic rant from me
Okay I'm so sorry
Ohio
Type thing okay
And then surprise
You know are you allowed
To be shocked are you allowed to say oh
You know what I didn't know
That
Are you made to feel like a fool if you didn't know
Absolutely everything about something or would you
Rather be quiet and not make a mistake
Say something that might not
Be the truth but you honestly thought was
Like do you get ridiculed
Do you get ridiculed if you share something
That you thought was right
Instead of just being like
Casually being told like
Oh actually it goes like this I think
Instead it's like
Oh you got it wrong you got it wrong
Oh say like
Like this all starts in high school
It's called secondary socialization
Is it schizophrenia if it's true oh my god
Oh my god Mercy's on the same page
Oh
Like so primary socialization
Is when your family has raised you
Okay your family and your most immediate
Caretakers have raised you okay
Secondary
Society is your
High school experiences everything else
Your workplace experience that's why
Workplace also has a lot of bullying
Connotations the bullying
Does not end in high school
I'm sorry to burst anyone's bubble
But there
Will always be people
Who feel the need to
Put others down and if
You're the one who gets picked on
There's nothing
You can do about it in the workplace
Because then instead of the
Response of high school being like oh they're
Teenagers let it figure out it's
Oh yes there are all adults here
You can't be fighting like
What do you want us to do yes there are adults
Yes there are adults and it was like
Motherfucker that's not how
Socialization works
Making the environment hostile
For one of
Anyway
So yeah
Where was I
We'll go back to the question
I got here
Okay
But you go above and beyond
For people and do things
Under no obligation so that's
Kind of coming back to me as an
Answer
I do feel obligated
In terms of I will never be able to
Repay the favor so I repay
The favor in any way I can
Okay I love mommy and she's right
That's right you preach mercy
Amen hallelujah
Thank you so much Rissy
Love you too mercy my daughter
Mercy should have picked mercy
But that's kind of my
My way of saying thank you isn't
Going oh thank you I appreciate that
No I will say it if like if someone
Worshiped I do say your name and then
I say like thank you so much for
Going from there
But my way of saying thank you is
Like here's free to access
Content do you guys want
A fun audio on the alt twitter okay
I'll write down that idea
That's for me the way
That I say thank you
For me personally is like you get to
See what you want that's how I do it okay
Mercy is doomed by that song
No it's me that's doing it to her
That's something that strong is the base
My knees are breaking the foundation of the house
Are you going through the floor
You put so much effort
Into making everyone happy
And building people up even at your own expense
I wouldn't say
It's at my own expense
Unfortunately I can't think of an example
Of me going on a ramble
That's at my own expense
But I hope
I do build you guys up and make you happy
You know you don't treat men like
There's some vile disease on this planet
No this is kind of the socialization
Again now I do
Want to warn all of you
Who consume
Any kind of media
It is a multi
Billion
Dollar industry
Of rage bait
Of
Of things done against
This happens to both sexes
Okay
So
If you scroll social media
On a new account
And it identifies you as a guy
It's going to push rage bait to you
Okay
It'll actually happen to my dad while he was here
He was like Ostrone
Why is it showing me content like this
And I'd explain to him what the rage bait is
What it is, what the hook is and all that
And I was saying
You will watch the most
Ridiculous staged
Contents that look real
And it's like
You know like Reddit stories for example
Just off the top of my head
The AI reading Reddit stories
That are like low effort content
People are manufacturing stories
Of like my wife
Of 10 years
Left me because
I became bald
Now if you didn't know
Everyone's going to become bald
It's perfectly natural for guys
To become bald
The baldness gene is in men
It also happens to women as well
So sorry to hear if you've got it type thing
But it's just a fact of life
It's a shame
That it has such an effect
But
Now listen to this point
Because it is such a sore
Aspect for some
And this is true
And it's okay to have your feelings hurt by this
It's truly okay to be like
Fuck
It's natural
If it didn't happen
You want to know the facts
If it didn't happen it's more unnatural
But because
It is such a insecurity
That's the word insecurity
So just as for women the makeup industry
Is a billion dollar insecurity thing
And Botox and all of this
As two
It's the same for guys
Okay and when it comes to factors like that
So rage bait is built upon this
So the most common rage bait you will most likely see is
My girlfriend left me
My wife left me
My fiance left me
And the most common
Things are to cheating
Are to
No longer in love with you
But it's not just no longer in love with you
It's the insecurity of like
Your baldness, your body's changed
You've got an older type thing
These are insecurities that manifest in guys
And it's okay if it manifested in you
That is what happens
Okay
It's perfectly natural to be insecure
What isn't
Good for you
My darling reefling
Is letting it control
Your life
Okay darling, I'm serious about that
Now
There's a lot of
Now I'm not just talking on rage bait
But
I do want to say
It's much easier said than done
But don't lock away yourself
From the world because you're insecure
Okay
The world
Is an absolutely stunning
And beautiful place
Okay and
There are so many people out there
That will give you just as much
As a laugh and a giggle as me
Okay
Please
I urge you in any context
Not just insecurities
In any context as a being
Do not be the one
That is holding yourself back
Via your ankle
Don't be grabbing onto your own ankles
And stopping you from watching
Walking forward
Guy on tiktok interviewing women
Who are rich and eight feet tall
Perfect example of rage bait
I completely forgot about that
I couldn't give two shits about height
So I'll always forget about that one
You will be made to feel insecure
About things you cannot control
You cannot control the balding gene
You cannot control your height
You spawn in with that
Again you spawn in with the balding gene
You cannot control the way
You physically look in the way your face is
You are a
Absolutely beautiful
Amalgamation
Of all your ancestors
Who fell in love before you
Okay
Please understand
When you consume social media
You consume people
With filters
That you wouldn't even know
You consume people who
Algorithm push
Pretty people
This is true and this is
That's how it is
Do not have a warped perception
On reality
Especially if you might be a reefling
That doesn't go outside often
You work from home or maybe you are
Just being chilling at home
Please take what you see
With a grain of salt darlings
Okay
Look at the sunlight
The lights in the city sparkle
Did you notice the flower that's growing
In between the sidewalk crack
At the wall
The world is beautiful and so are you
Exactly
Yes
You must be careful
Thank you
Oh reefling
Are you okay darlin
You are more than welcome
MNS
Thank you for the super chat
It's
It's such a hard topic
To tackle
Because it's not
Like it's not like
It's a circle and we can be like
Okay this is everything in this circle
It is like the absolutely
Nightmare of a spider web
And how you even begin to talk
About one aspect of it without
You know trying to
Push through all these other aspects
That come into it okay
I'm tearing up oh no I should have stopped
I don't want to make you upset darlings
But yes
The influence of social media is
Real
Who knew mercy could be so poetic
And who knew a cuttlefish would be
More wholesome than all of society
Imagine the cuttlefish
Is lore which is to destroy
All of humanity turns into
Reset all of humanity
I will bring you to a
New age
Come one come aura
Don't lock yourself away
Because you're insecure
All the heart-hitting kindness
And old school runescape I love the
It's a combination for the ages
Combination
Got me feeling so many emotions
I came to cheer on it
And I got a lot more
Oh no I'm sorry I'm sorry already
Sorry I need to stop
Destroyers with bliss
I think I understand now I get it
You go out of your way to make them
Feel like it's a safe space to relax
And enjoy and
What they like without condemnation
Okay now this is where I'm getting
A bit tinfoil hat Eve
It's not really tinfoil hat because again it's true
So now
Let's tackle the terminology
Simp
Now it got banned on Twitch if you didn't know that
That terminology got banned on Twitch
The internet
Use it
Against men
Who enjoy content
From women
That's the most basic description
You could ever do it
Now
It's used to
Again
Make you
Feel bad about
Simply enjoying yourself
Enjoying content you consume
And connecting with a creator
That happens to be a chick
Again it is another
Kind of
Destroy society
But when she learned the evils of the world
She decided to save people as reeflings
Destroy the high table
Thank you tiny spiny
Even urban living can pose stress
It is
Please don't think like
I'm not got a job and paying taxes
I'm worthless in society
Motherfucker
That's not how it works
My darling
I assure you you do not have to be a cog in the
Aim
Your life has value outside
Of paying taxes to the federals
I assure you
Wholeheartedly
Your life has more meaning
Than
Shoving some money into the endless pit of
Taxes against the fucking porpoise
You know
Don't worry about none of that if you're worried about that
I don't want to go to work today
This is too confusing
Sorry
Things in needs is quite good
One of the best things about
Other is all tags are welcome here
Not everyone should have to work
Oh wait until I get into how long
You guys should actually work a week
It's over
Oh my god oh I'd love to do an education stream
About like pre-improved capital
Are you good at me right now?
Stop
Aww
Do you realize how rare that combo is?
Now be the mother of my children
Plop plop plop plop
Gen 2 confirmed plop plop plop plop plop
Thank you Zarian for the tip
I don't like how people
Excessive fan
Obsessive fan of power social
So I'm a dumbass I thought power social meant
When they show up at your house and I was like
Ooh that's dangerous
I don't know the definition of power social
Very well so I can't talk on it
Um
But I think the terminology
Is just dedicated fan
I don't really
For me personally I don't really like
Referring to you guys as fans
I'd rather just call you my response
Than a bit more personal than like fan
I feel like fan is like
An idol on a stage
And you're in the audience with the glow sticks
Like that to me that's fan
Whereas like I'm looking
At your profile picture
And I'm reading out what you're saying
Like a few like different
There's levels and it's a little far
Now power social is a one sided relationship
Dreaming of labour
Is the biggest mistake they try and rope you into
Oh my god
Wait a minute
Nori kinda
She's kind of spitting on the mic though
Kind of spitting on the mic
Yes I could go into the whole
What skills all of that
Um
A few streamers are standings for pals
Or that kind of thing that's power social
But then that brings up the question
Cause obviously I see a lot of things
About how hard it is to make like
Friends as adults
Like and especially
If it's outside drinking as well
Oh my god I've literally not watched one freaking
Vod of a genmey and we're already like an hour
We've already blown past an hour and I've not even
Watched one second of a Vod
Um no no does that break
Oh it broke
Oh no it didn't
I don't know what broke
Something broke
Um she's licking at us
Literally with my eyeballs
Wait did I finish the question
You know that
I hope my question doesn't come across
Negatively you're briefed for this and don't change
Okay thank you reefling
Thank you for um
Your question
I have no idea if I even answered the question
If I'm being honest
Thank you so much I'm not even sure
I managed to get to the point
If I'm being honest
I think I like somehow
Just went on a massive tangent for each
Did I answer it
Question work
Did it? Okay okay
Right if we're satisfied with that
I'll take it
Dumbass honestly
What dumbass
Maybe maybe not
Okay
Um something's helped
Johnny I'm so pent up
Literally the question was
Why the reefling
Stop
Now you're gonna make me cry
I'm pulling up the quote right now
I'm literally greeting stop
Stop hold on
Why the halfling quote
Are you squidding me right now?
Sorry to go back to balding
But if reeflings are suffering from it
Ask your doctor about finasteride
It regulates testosterone
Which in excess causes balding
It's actually a miracle
Strani has a full set of hair
With her level of testosterone
Wait because you guys are pumping testosterone into me
Thank you Zarian
Um
I think there's also
Something called mox
It's not moxicillin
I think you
Put it in your hair
No
Moxicillin is a penicillin
Don't listen to me that's an antibiotic
Shit it's something that begins with
M that you put in your hair
You can also use rosemary oil as well
Antibiotics for balding
Stop
Don't take antibiotics for balding
That's a terrible thing
You didn't know
Balding is actually because you produce so much testosterone
That your body is like
I'm gonna explode
And that's true in me
Oh dumbass
Mixed
Minoxidil
And you began with an M
No don't use antibiotics
Use antibiotics
When you have a bacterial
Infection
Normally a viral infection
Does not work with antibiotics
And it's causing the rise
Of antibiotic resistant
Thingamabobbers, okay
If you've got a cough that's a virus
If you've got the sniffles that's a virus
If you've got pus oozing out of your body
That is not a virus and you can get hope for that
Okay
That's an infection
N-A-E
Mummy is bald confirmed
Should I ask Nori for a bald toggle
And then you can see what I look like under all this hair
Oh wait no
I have video footage of me bald
When I was getting made
When the mecca was getting made
Thank you, Vulcan Dynasty
Am I going crazy in saying that
Spellt wrong from Star Trek
If that was from Star Trek
We all can
Sorry
Is mummy hair even hair or is it tentacles
No but my alternates
Is going to have tentacles
I'm going to have you coming at my butt
Okay, sorry
To get back on topic
If I can
Find the quill
It's refusing to come out
Oh my god
Okay here we go
Mithrandir
Reefling
I don't know
Saruman believes that is only great power
That can hold evil in check
But that is not what I have found
I've found that it's the small things
Everyday deeds of ordinary folk
That keep the darkness at bay
Simple acts of kindness and love
But why
Reefling
Perhaps it is because I am afraid
And he gives me courage
Yeah
That's how I would sum up
My
Why the Reefling
She just evolved
She just didn't say where
I just spanked it in another
I wish I could engage more
With the stream it sounds like the Reefling philosophy is strong
Don't worry about it
You are welcome to lurk in the shadows
But don't say Shadow the Hedgehog
Or Amy is going to pop up from you
My plot
Did you use this in the ASMR
Why did I remember it
I used it in
Pregnant with you ASMR
If you are on Patreon
I said that cool
Shadow the Hedgehog
Sonic Heroes
I only want that
And then it all ends in 30 years
Do the Bilbo speech before please
I am going for another 30 years
Forget 4 more years
30 more years
Amy said no
Play Sonic X Shadows
Day 1
I don't know that one
Hello
We get
Oh he said hello not hello
Sorry
Speaking of hello
Here's the schedule for the week
That's the emotional wellbeing chart
Yes I will finish up Sonic Heroes
I may actually
100% the game
I may actually do
Because I've already done rows
We're about to do Team Chaotic
I have done Sonic Heroes
30 more years
I will be the first Guilf Vechuber
Is there a Guilf Vechuber
Can I take that title
Sorry can I take the title as the first Guilf Vechuber
Because you know
These girls ain't as dedicated
The emotional schedule
Schedule is the wheel of emotions
Like huge old granny's throwing
Virtual old bacha
No wait that's so cute though
Good morning my E-Flings
I feel like my Scottish accent
Is going to really come back the older I get
Oh who's it going my wee E-Flings
Good morning
Are you ready from a blast from the past
Today
We're going to play Black Ops 1
Campaign
And later I'm going to record
A wee ASMR
Of us making cookies together
I will be the cutest granny
Vechuber ever
Oh boss on
You would never speak German
Oh bits of bits of
Do you know that old lady please
Yes
She's been confirmed
Publicly to be
In Elden School
Sick Elden School
I think I'm saying that absolutely horrifically
Well
Granny's Gummars
Excuse me
Did my eyes deceive me
Does that say Granny's Gummars
You're getting timed out for 10 seconds
For that one chief
That was foul
I literally manually tamed you
Out myself for that comment
That was foul young man
That's strong behaviour
They need to do that again
Oh no
Wait with that
Granny Granny Gummars
I literally hears me like
Such a cute old boss on
Son and then
I get fucking Granny Gummars
Gummars
No
He took one for the team coming out without one
Elden Scrolls is my favourite
Stop Eldar
Scrolls are Elden
Ring
That was funnily farewell
Spank
I think Cure Dolly was an older woman
Hmm
Chat reflects this
How dare you
No you're not becoming
Queeflins again
I liked all the other variations
That these came up with
It was very cute
Right I'll make you a deal
At the two of her mark
We'll actually watch my
Watch Genmate Vods
Skyrim Granny confirmed for Gen 2
I mean
I think she'd be down
Sorry but I think she was
And she can like
Play all the mods and stuff
No
Where are the Short Kinglings
Oh that's so cute
Oh yeah
While we're talking about Ragebait
That one gets done all the time
Sorry to kind of backtrack a wee bit
That Ragebait gets done all the time
Where it's like
If he doesn't make quarter of a million
US dollars
Every week
I don't want him
And obviously the girl's been scouted
For how pretty she looks
And then
What a guy's takeaway is
If you do not
If you have the glasses on
Where you do genuinely not know
What Ragebait content is
You're gonna be left
Feeling like
What the fuck
Is this really
I
Sent you a picture
Is management bullying me
What the fuck
I make you all this money and you're fucking doing
What
Oh no
Oh my god
Would you still love me
If I didn't use moxicillin
On my head
Even though that's not the right one
My eyes
Honestly but look you can see my ears though
See I told you I don't have normal human ears
I have they're a little bit pointed
Almost look like a vampire wee bit
If you take away my hair
I don't really look as cephalopod-esque
But my hair gives an indication
I like cuter bald
Stop bald stream when
Honestly
There's three round things
In this picture
If you know when I'm shinin'
A vampire
Squid honestly
Bald
Shawnee in her
Oh my god I can't say that
I'll have the same heart of gold
Okay let's pop away
Right thank you for your tip
She's going down the stairs
Okay that's actually
So true for the random thing
I'll pop that there in case I put something in its place
That is hilarious
Thank you I like you cut G
Thank you Anon for spanking me
On the back of my bald ass head
Bring her back now almost 18k
Stop stop the ASMR debt rises
I can hardly keep up I'm literally uploading
Pregnancy ASMR and then
I'm gonna try and edit
My side collab and then
I'm gonna try for the snowberries
The AC one out because it actually wasn't that bad to edit
So snowberries
Potentially
A snowberry warning
You might have an ASMR roleplay
From AC
But please do not hold me to that
Because I am
About to do an endurance stream
And I also
I'm also
Kind of going back
To prioritizing my content a little bit
I put a lot of my stuff on pause
To help the girls out but I'm gonna
We've got a meeting this week
And I'm gonna tell them
Like if you're gonna leave me to do
Stuff for you
I'm gonna do it eventually
But it's gonna be delayed because I put a lot of my stuff on
Pause
To enable them but now it's kind of time for me
To be like hey ho
You know how you wanted that thing
I actually know
You have editing skills
You know like that kind of thing
So what's the sequel to the pregnancy ASMR
Strongly gives birth to a hotfish
I'm not gonna do a freaking birth
Like no
I doubt anyone would even do that
I feel like that's like really
You will need to do logarithmic milestones
Next to handle the ASMR
No, so I have a lot of stuff
Just sitting there waiting to be recorded
Or waiting to be uploaded
But thanks to YouTube giving me a warning
For breathing in the air
I would like to remind everyone who doesn't know
I uploaded
A video of me
Clapping with
My hands ASMR, okay
Ah, the video did not get removed
Because of that
The video got removed because I breathed
In the ear of the microphone
Fast
So I know
I'm too scared to upload anything
That I'm like unsure of
So I need to wait
Until the warning is off my channel
To then I can start like uploading
Cause like I've got burp ASMR
Waiting to upload
Well you were clapping with your hands
Why would it get, yeah
Yeah, yeah, my hands, of course
I'll need to get going now, see you later
See you later alligator in a wild crocodile
I'll still be here
It's an endurance, so if you need to sleep
Or you need to catch up on some household tasks
Or you need to prepare yourself some food
Please don't worry, I'mma be here
Oh no, breathing, that's too obscene
Literally
If they remove the pregnancy one, no
So there's actually nothing wrong with the pregnancy one
There's nothing offensive
There's nothing weird about it
Now, I'm sure you can be like
Oh it's weird because
Like you're literally pretending that
Reefland's in the womb, but it's cute
Like sorry, but it's kawaii name
Like, you know, Ohio it's kawaii name
You know what I'm saying?
You can't know what I'm saying, like it's actually kawaii name
Right, I'll refresh Marshmallow
And I'll try and blitz through them, okay
You're supposed to be
The pregnancy was supposed to be cursed
But it was wholesome, yeah
I can't wait to see YouTube's reaction to it
Is it? Yeah
If we remember it, we're right
I can't say anything weird about it
Wasn't there a pair of vTubers that streamed
They birthed their first child like a script?
I had no idea
That's bizarre
Okay, Marshmallow
Hi strongy, this might be a bit too real
But I need to get it out of here
Should we do a cathartic street?
It's the word cathartic, hold on
cathartic
cathartic, providing
psychological relief
through the open expression of strong
emotions
Would you guys like a cathartic stream?
Or would you like me
to, if there's any Marshmallows
that appear to be
cathartic, should I not
say them out loud and read them
personally?
I was calling a confetti
That did it, why am I not
surprised it was calling a confetti
Fuck it
She's hilarious, honestly
I believe even Narissa from
Holo wants to do a birthstream
I love cathartic
Ready or more
What you read
doesn't tell the entire meaning of cathartic yet
Did I not say it?
Oops, I said it wrong
I've no got a clue
I'm just going off of
Google
smile
Isn't that what we're doing right now?
I mean, I guess
Yeah, I don't know if I can
read these ones out
I'm gonna be on
you
I'll
I'll read
the ones that I don't think
I'll read them personally
Does that make sense?
Yeah
Are you squiddin' me right now?
I don't think anyone would ever send
you a marshmallow if they didn't
trust you
Yeah
Question from one of the girls
Are we allowed to mention bandsly streams
on the schedule since they get uploaded?
No
It would have to be
put on the
Patreon
version that goes on their alt twitter
They can't mention it on their schedules
It cannot be mentioned on schedules
It's inappropriate conduct
But it can be mentioned on their Patreon alt posts
Okay, the blue side
Real and true
The girls at me in the discord
and I'm just straight up going on a massive rant
about the Injustice Society
Okay, no, they're literally
AC's like
How would we go about announcing that or even talking about it?
I think
AC's very excited to
do this little bandsly moment
Right, I've closed that off because I don't want any leaks
I bet you
I'll be the first one to leak something from the fucking Pishon discord
Honestly, I'll be that twat bag that does it
Oh my god, sorry, I need a fart
Can you give me one second?
Oh
I didn't have to
I didn't have to douse the
loaf of bread and water just so you guys know
I did it naturally
and a lot came out of me with this stuff
Hi, Strony, let me just say that you
cooked with Veal. Oh, thank you
They're based on all my fashions
Every channel
brings AC
and
her
Snowberries give men a platform where they can have
a little one who wants to rely on them
All men like to be seen as a provider
Ooh, we're getting an anopsis
on a
ad?
Does that just accidentally add someone?
I don't know
All men wants to be seen
Mercy brings a woman who's obsessed over you
No matter how crazy she makes you
She once loved so badly
that someone loved so badly
they looked past murder
Emi gives the one who is seen as the
gender, it's a place to belong
Eh
Azura gives those who have an inner child
inside that would never let a chance
to rest and be pampered without judgement
Where's Sheevee?
Did you forget about Sheevee?
What?
Did you
forget the Sheevee? Wait, am I
blind? I see Mercy
Emi Azura and you Miss
Ronnie Cotter's our genius to brought them all together
I'm going to blow
your mind, okay?
There's a 6th member of
Vilaura and I'm so excited to share her
with you, her name's Sheevee
Cottonbum, she's
Milf Bunny
Dominatrix, she's also a girl
failure, you're gonna love her, her link
is in the description, I've
blown your mind that there's actually a 6th
member of Gen 1 Vilaura which is fantastic
What's that girl
Vilaura?
The secret 6th member of
Vilaura, true
I think, I think, I think Reeflin just forgot
to, I'm just
teasing you Reeflin, please don't panic
I'm teasing you, I know you
you've probably just mistyped and
accidentally deleted the paragraph
or whatever, the sentence on Sheevee, please
don't worry, Sheevee said that one
6th member, Lee?
Did they mention Mercy? Yeah, they said Mercy
Mercy brings
a woman who is obsessed over you, no matter how
crazy she may seem, some
want love so badly, they can
look past, murder
I have terrible news for the
Senpais, it kind of all ends
the same with Mercy at some point
or another, the
6th shouldn't hide in somewhere in the school
Wait, what's wrong?
M
U
What mummy, if you want
a good laugh, just keep some
absolutely ridiculous tabs open
in your browser so if it leaks
everyone has a good time
Gay M with hats on is a
classic stop, what?
Oh no, I'd want to put something controversial
then
AI, Shia Lily, popcorn
I said what it is
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Teasing, but
And then you should feel very ashamed
You're not able
Thank you
basically Wiz for
adding on to the
shiwi difference, so guys
just want to announce that I am actually
the 6th member real or real
Andrew
Hi strongy, if you want
kids, if so, how many?
My nipples are going to remain
pink, thank you for asking
As for
strongy
strongy is going to
birth
6 plus 6, which is
6 plus 6 is 12
and plus 5
is 17
right?
I need 17 children from you, do you think you can
bear that for me?
Do you think you can have that responsibility
of clapping when it's my ovulation time?
17, she can do math, yay!
I had to put only 17
I cannot go further
than a gen 3, are you joking me?
I'll be
my
badly packed
kebab would be whistling
by the time I got to the 17th child
I don't think I need any more than
a 17, I'm going to be shattered
okay
the wind
tunnel, a chance to close up again
about Jesus
mommy, you have no idea
riefling, sorry, mommy, riefling
you have no idea how low quality
most hypno content creation is
someone with genuine interest
who isn't after the easy money
or
degrading offshoots like
abadal, abadal?
what's abadal?
adult baby diaper
what?
I popped, I popped, I'm level
we popped rieflings
level 94
abadabadingdong
we popped it
only
we did it!
and we've already burnt through
3000 wines already
self-wetting
is a rarity for those of us
who have been in the space a long time
can't wait to see you go
yeah, I have to admit
whilst going on my travels
of looking at what other content creators do
in particular
can I, I'm just going to say
how it is
there's a lot of sophistication
like, a lot
of like
astronomical numbers
of it
okay, you know, there's a lot of it
like, a lot
okay, but that was just, that's just my content
oh, they've got another hypnosis comment
hell yeah, sorry
can I be an ego Andy for like 5 seconds
I had no idea how well
that hypnosis stream was going to go down
and I like feel so
confident now
what color are your underwear today
um
it's the same from yesterday
the purple ones
if that's gross I can take them off
I'm sorry, it's the same ones as yesterday
I don't know if that's gross
or not, marinate in
pretty much, pheromone max
then just take them all
hahaha
sniffer, honestly
uh
mummy was rewatching the John Wick Vod
since I missed watching the first few movies
and you and something came up
how's the toe
I've now got a toenail
it's healed
it's pretty much healed
I can touch it
the sensation is new
I did
I didn't really want to get into it too much
when I had the procedure
I could still feel pain
unfortunately the anesthetic didn't work
and it was pretty
rough
so I didn't really want to talk about it
when it just happened but
I've healed up nicely
I don't have to do bandages or anything
anymore
it's getting used to the sensation now
it's quite strange
merci's pheromone max in 2
the senpai's will be happy
it really didn't grow brat
grow back, no
I'm ill-fee toeless
but it's okay
but what did papa ink think about
I never told him I was too embarrassed
oh by the way
I got a pedicure
and it resulted in me losing a toenail
forever and he's like
what? I'm like yeah
I never explained that to him
but I showed him like pretty much everything else
that I've been doing like on streams and that
here I told just
me and my dad
we watched the mech assault stream together
and he was absolutely
laughing at me panicking on the bridge
he was like
the bridge sequence I was like this is the one
that I couldn't do I don't remember you
playing this map and I told him like
I actually only remember me replaying
the second
last one or the last one over and over again
um
it will be a
tiny nub wow you wouldn't let me
ink you with my tiny nub
of a toe wow I can't believe you're so
toist don't be toist
mercy do not shower
give us
seven days it's okay
I go for a week without showing drugs
casually
hi strony can I ask my mercies
neko stream got taken down
it was too adorable and it breaks
my heart to see it go
it's completely up to the girls
what they'd like to leave off or take down
um I don't
I was not me I promise
management are not like that at veal
or I promise we aren't like take that down
take that down right now
you were too perfect and adorable in that stream
um there may be
a multitude of factors on why
the girls would like to take something down
um it was too
saucy okay so
okay so mercy
says it was too saucy that is an example so one
example is dmc
another example is going a bit too far
by accident
another example
um could be
that someone's trying
to be malicious in something they said in a
clip and they just want to take the whole thing down like
I I do not
make the girls you know we
the management
all that we don't make the girls do anything they
don't want to do you know
um they're on to us take that down
obviously if it was on
get us stated
what on earth did you get up to my beloved
yann dairy for I actually didn't know
you got in trouble thank you anonymous for the tip
please don't be afraid to ask
questions for free however
in chat you do not have to
pay money to ask questions
I feel really bad when you guys
ask questions so it's for
through money okay
um
just a few more days for
mersey's
plans
say
um better to
take it down then get a strike so
mersey doesn't have a warning on her channel
so even if she was a naughty saucepan
she would actually
get a warning first
um azura
me and myself are waiting for
her warnings to expire
um it literally is in September
and I'm like
quite well
what are we August September yeah
so the the clap
ASMR the burp ASMR
I've got like a few other ones that I'm too scared
to upload until the warning is gone
basically I have this short
by the way that is about ear licking
um
and I thought it was so
good but I'm too scared to upload it in case
youtube are like
you're looking
and then they suspend me for
a week basically
if I can't stream for a week please
know that I will cook so hard on all the ASMRs
if I ever like got banned for a week
any chance gen 2 will have
met oh darlin
no I'm so sorry
is that are you trolling with that
is that troll
are you teasing
don't want them to look into my history and be like
one warning and he goes a ban
so I actually do need to highlight that
to all of you
girlies
youtube no longer need to do a
one two three strike system and then your channel is gone
if youtube look at your channel
and they find sufficient
evidence to suggest that it's
based on
that kind of content alone
they can just straight up take it offline now
merci
Kohai I assure you you do not
need to worry you're sitting
in killer 7
and harvester
and you know you're giffin off with some
ASMR
as well recently and you've got short variation
you do not need to worry merci
I promise you that much you do not need to worry
I wasn't
youtube prude hate
ever
ever ever
wait I'ma be honest
it needed to be deleted
wait
snippets
was merci
a whack
was merci being too much
oh my god the corruption
arc is real
snippets
corruption arc real
I'll DM you stop hold on
literally opening up discord on the screen
shhh
me waiting for the DM
oh the DMs I've got 2 DMs
okay I'm gonna be honest
merci
I'm with merci on that one
I think that void needed to be taken down
okay thank you merci for
putting it into together
oh my gosh
okay
I didn't oh my
oh my okay I'm gonna close the
I'm gonna close the DM
okay tell us
I don't even think I can say it out loud
what she did
imagine what she's gonna do on blue
oh my gosh
right
let's see if I can see
wait hold on
hold on a minute
oh my god
oh my god what
wait
you know how I drew gen 2
oh my god
wait someone drew my gen 2
interpretation but like
actually went for it and sent it
what
no way
that's absolutely insane
hold on can I like it
I think I can
hold on let me put it on screen
no way someone drew my gen 2
someone just straight up drew gen 2
what
gen 2
bases by merci he he
no those bases aren't by merci you drew it yourself
oh my god
right slime slimy magie
the slime milf
discord kitten
male fries
male feats for the velgins
goblin orc short stack
gobby the noblin
oh my god
the harm assist
uneology
oh my god fuck
wait no thank you
thank you if you could just go off the screen for a moment
though
oh my gosh
and look
and goth i hop hex
i hop on your
and oh my god she's giving the middle finger
with a cigarette sorry I'm completely
covering up the gameplay please admire
this though like literally please admire
look there's me at the bottom I promise it's fine
oh my gosh
that's insane sorry I'm gonna retweet
that this
is
actually insane
because for some reason they
work together so well
thank you for
ending the time to do this
oh my
I'm put a little green heart
and then I'm gonna
put um
uneology love because I love uneology
sorry I might actually get that developed
I'm not even kidding so fuck you if anyone
tries to take it I already have the copyright and IP
yeah
uh love
although I saw you guys want
a Elgoblina short stack
and I'm like oh very
very unworthy give me that little
scientist honestly I really like the idea
of uneology
I think it's a really good idea
holey moley
steel
steel-toed boots for uneology
oh that's it for pizza
I've retweeted it if you want to check it out on Twitter
the booty
the booty lord
and then 16 backwards and backwards
the booty lord 16 thank you for becoming
a member
mummy you still need to fix the vod timer
what do you mean
well
for the watch along
this
for the when we're gonna watch along a vod
huh
it's gone
are you squidding me right now
yeah I've not started
mouse train conductor and evil scientist
confirmed as the lollipops for gen 2
heh
no
thank you tiny spiny
spiny ship
spiny spiny
it's been two hours watch long time yes
okay
for the reeflings
that are
in some heavy hitting messages
in marshmallow
you are more than welcome
to use my marshmallow
as an outlet if you need to
I will read it offline
I'm not going to read anything
online that's personal so please don't worry
but if you genuinely need
after a very loaded conversation
if you genuinely need
an outlet and you've got nowhere else to go
please use my marshmallow
I'll read it
I won't respond like I don't
I won't respond like publicly privately but
if you need that you're more than welcome to do so
okay
well no but actually yes I've never seen
no
urine is so dang and romping
style too
oh I've not played it
the sail is
I'm sorry
right hold on
right we're gonna watch a vod
okay
um
okay there we go right
has everyone got sheebie's stream
open we're gonna do some react
andy to my own gen mates because
I don't have enough time to watch
my darling gen mates
um
yes if a reefling wants something personal to be
allowed to be read they can always put it in the message
absolutely yes oh is that what you mean by
I keep using it
is it wrong
do I keep using cathartic wrong
I think I'm using it in the wrong context
I'm so sorry is there a lot of trauma
dumping no there's not a lot
of outlets for reeflings
to kind of be like this is what's going on
or this is what's been weighing on my mind so
if you want to use my marshmallow for it you can
but out of respect I'm not gonna
um say it watch streaming it
look at the pinned chat
it should be
by sheebie cotton bottom
bum
you should collab with azura, emmy and mersey
nothing is wrong so originally
they were supposed to play uno
but everything blew up in their face
basically
um
yeah
I can't wait for your reaction she'll love them
azura was so unhinged at one point
munkah yes munkah yes
goodbye to those who have to go
um
uh
yeah
okay
I actually need to do an uno collab
with some weechoo bab
weechoo bab
yeah
I've never seen an uno stream work correctly no matter what
I've seen holo live pull it off
and I'm like fuck yeah
and egauda came back for it she was like commenting on it
it was so adorable she was like
what time are we at
so if you look top left
on my screen right now
the vod should be
now we're 49 minutes
and 43 seconds long okay
we're all gonna hit play at the same time
and if you lose your place don't worry
about it
holo live didn't pull off easily
the day was so fun every girl made a thumbnail
with ubisoft new logo where I put emoji
on her face isn't kathar
rizism the relief
I've ever went through heavy emotions
aww okay I think I'm
I'm definitely not saying the word right
when I'm saying it I'm sorry to anyone
there'll be some linguistic refling
that's like oh my god women
please
an air free game is not possible
okay right
it's everyone got the stream open
from sheeby cotton bum
azzura
that's who
okay
I will say 3 2 1 go
and on go you click
click play okay
right
3 2
1 go
now
I'm not playing the audio or anything
but you will be able to see
the little timer in case
we're out of sync
I did not realise
how outrageous I had made the loading screen
for sheeby
oh I need to get it updated
so it looks like she
well I was gonna
watch it on mersey's
channel
but I couldn't find it
maybe need to show her the ropes of
what youtube find good or bad type thing
thank you anonymous for the tip
why is everyone
yes
I'm like
so I
sheeby has her
actual
model skin colour now
I think it should be her now
I don't know if she's fully using the model
when she uses like both attachments
sheeby goes reverse to white
again fucking ridiculous
literally whitewashed mottlin talent
like fucking cringe man
I actually grimace thinking about it
oh hey by the way become white women now
like fuck me man
violour exposed whitewashing
talents right off the bat
but she now has
a much more reflective
skin tone colour
I don't know what you want to call it
which I'm very happy about
and I will see if I can
try and update her
loading screen yumi yumi works
I cannot tell you how fantastic yumi yumi
works is to work with
melanin acquired
oh my god actually though
she had a funny sheeby had a funny post
on her alternative twitter
there was like people coming here
being like why are you black
why are you white equally
I thought I was
fucking hilarious
sheeby
copper bum
did she call herself that
oh they're up they're up
she used the stinger oh my god she's so professional
she actually used the stingers can't relate
oh hi guys
oh it's my daughters
bar we icy
oh hi oh they're so cute coming together
he's gonna take control of the collab
oh mercy to control
interesting
you always need
someone to control the collab
in terms of like this is what we're gonna do
this is what we're gonna discuss
and then the rest happens naturally
job box Sydney work
oh would you rather
she popped off with her matey
so I'm glad she got back
yeah whenever the girls like get both assets
or assets for v-tubers
I'm really thankful that
sorry mercy's talking and my brain's like listen
yes she did do a collab
a smart with uv as well
as roommate
for them the collab never
it's like a vtuber curse honestly
wait they say ube soft
isn't it not ube soft
like you are soft ube soft
ube soft
ube ube sounds ridiculous
rip ube soft sponsor
gmaster the it sale collection
just fucking sponsor me
I'll influence so hard
I'll influence all over the screen
ube soft
what's going on
we are reacting to a vod of my gen mate
it is pinned in
the chat
actually
tell you what I'll add a text
I'll use text
and text
React
and watching
hold on that's so big
okay it was funny I'll give you that
that's actually really funny
Oh wait, oh good, that's the first question, make me nervous, I wasn't even in the stream!
Oh that's tiny now, oh it's so blurry because it's so tiny, hold on, hold on.
I'm American, I don't care, whoa!
What was that?
What were they asking?
Wait, maybe I can like do it long.
Okay, they all see the fallacy issue with that thing as well.
Aw, evening, that's so good.
It's too far apetics, stop it.
Wow.
I love this too, it's so scuffed already.
Correct translation of Ubisoft can be found on Wikipedia as far as I can tell.
Ubisoft, oh no, it is right.
Scuffed accent, and me.
Okay.
Okay I'm with Amy on that one, not bothered with the sun, it's dangerous.
Fucking hell, what are these questions?
Is the sun even visible in Scotland? No.
I came to Australia with a vitamin D deficiency, severe vitamin D deficiency.
Aw, they must have been so tired trying to get the fucking Uno game to work.
Mercy.
Okay Azura, the mother, literally coming in this way.
What? Mercy?
She wants to eradicate an entire country?
I'm on Android, oh I'm so sorry, it's gonna make no sense this stream, I'm so sorry.
Shibi might be coming online, she might be online by now actually.
Oh, Amy! Amy!
I need to fucking clip that, that's hilarious.
Mercy says the joke, she's like, I'm just kidding, Amy, no destroy France at once.
I need to clip that, that's hilarious, what the heck.
She has no qualms, I'm going berserk.
Oh no, Shibi's taking the day off today.
Okay, Amy might be coming on later, question mark.
I'm not sure.
I can't remember everyone's schedule.
She predicted the Olympics.
What, from death? Are you talking about death now, aye?
Not too late, nyeh.
We've started watching the first GenMeatVod, it's pinned if you want to watch along at the same time, that little timer is how far we're in.
Bruh.
Aww.
My dad lost 50 quid, Annie somehow got it back.
Somehow.
Literally the plot of my favourite anime, Maria and Nikki.
Clipping is weird on YouTube, it is.
I think they're going to improve the system, it would help so much with content creators on YouTube if they overhauled the clipping process the way they do it on Twitch.
Twitch is so easy to clip, sorry about that.
Oh my god.
Does Amy not know?
Somalia's pirate territory.
Oh she does it, okay.
Somalia's literally known for piracy.
Yes!
Us.
Oh my god, Mercy's freaking going hard.
These questions are, did they change to something else or did they just do the questions the whole stream?
I see for one, they changed, okay.
They did Maros, okay Maros is fun, I like when you guys like say stuff to them.
She's like a neural implant.
Mercy should be called Mercy-less, honestly.
Amy and Mercy are unten, Shibi's trying to lead the gang and Azur is too nice and sweet, real.
It was so hard for me to pull off this collab by the way, I just thought you should know.
Well I had to do all the voices at the same time and Adelaide and all that, it was quite awkward but I got there in the end.
Teasing.
Cheese, I'm all a bit lower, you didn't know?
She's a talented VA, real.
But you're able to do it, yeah see, everyone thought it was Ubisoft's fault, it's because I couldn't have four computers connect to each other and play at the same time, clearly.
That literally just ends like me with my family, I can't even see them every year.
Azur is straight to the point, you know, true.
Azur is ready, she's like, like, all I'm saying is when Azur moves out, life's good, I'm gonna be very happy, Bunny, when Azur moves out.
Collaborate with Dad when?
Unironically, Marilyn, soon, I'm not even kidding, thank you for this, super chat.
My dad recorded a short of naming the YouTubers but I need to order assets for it because it's gonna be funnier if assets come along with it, so I need to do that.
Soon, you pay with your soul, but, oh, oh no, do you want to know if I've written lore about Emmy, I think I've said it at the start.
So, when the girls have had enough at Violaure, there's gonna be a released video of their happy ending, okay?
And everyone's happy ending is related to their lore, okay?
So, Emmy finally achieves her forbidden love and she does get her brother back in the end.
But if and when the girls are like, okay, I'm satisfied with what I've done at Violaure, I don't want to do anymore, I will ask for one request which is please voice this ending sequence and we'll curtain call.
And they have the best, yes, please tell me you're not leaving, no, no, stop the, no, don't throw up, put it back in your mouth, swallow it, swallow it, don't throw up, it's okay, I'm not leaving.
Like, my lore, for example, my ending will be like, it's obviously gonna be the farm, let's be honest, that would be enough to make her grow, I think it's cute even though it's so sad.
Yes, I like the idea of a bittersweet thing of closing the story off, but obviously if a girl were to leave, they have an account and as I said, if and when a girl leaves Violaure on their account, the last tweet will be, my adventure here is over but my adventure continues on whatever social media account they're gonna continue on.
As I said, we're not a fucking weird ass agent, say that's like, oh my god, you've never been a content creator, no, what the fuck, we still want them to succeed.
It's kind of one of those, it's one of those scenes where it's like, I still want you to eat, just not at my table, because if you're, I threw up, stop.
It's Emmy's Final Four, Margaret Thatcher, it's technically, it's either the darkness in quotation marks or the devil is holding her brother back,
but she's basically gonna become powerful enough over time to overthrow and, you know, make them a little, and basically get her brother back and they live together happily ever after and they do not have children, but they do the other stuff, which is fine.
Because they're both consenting adults, the devil herself and it's fucking Margaret Thatcher, that's fine.
All the wishy marks that used to be in my username are for each of the wishes I lost during the first three months of this year is ten a month.
What's that, V-Reverie? That must be V-Reverie.
I nearly choked on an ice cube, it's so over, guys. Wait, why are you choking on an ice cube?
The coffin catcher, Margaret Thatcher.
Wait, I'm getting sad. Stop getting sad, what, this, I'm talking about like, freaking five years in the future.
As I said, I'm probably gonna continue as strong as independent, like, once Veilers closed its wee doors and stuff.
Don't take my ice cube.
Thank you, Vulcan Dynasty.
Please don't choke on that ice cube.
No, five years? No, I'm gonna continue as Strongzo. I like Strongzo, I like Strongzo, it's very neat.
Azur is literally like...
Oh, Emi, Emi stopped aging once she got the book.
Emi is a bit malnourished because she lived a wild life.
For anyone who wants to be a weirdo.
No, they're adults.
Strongzo sounds like a clown name.
It's the nickname of Strongzo, it's running.
Can the girls buy the IP if they leave?
Originally I thought it would be possible, but it's not.
Now, this wouldn't happen, but if in theory the IP was sold, it's recognized as Veilers.
And then one of the girls went on a most schizophrenic rant of the most racist, vile stuff you could imagine.
I can't have that because we still need the rights of the IP.
And if we wanted to put out merch even without the talent present, for example, like, happily ever after type merch or story-wise or just something.
And unfortunately, we, Veiler, need to retain the right to the IP.
But the girls are aware of that, like, when they signed on the contract,
they knew they were getting a whole new model handed to them and all of that.
YelfTuberPlan confirmed, I'm V-sucking on a bicycle.
What? I'm V-sucking? Oh my god, we created a new verb.
Can't tell the IP the same reason you didn't buy IP.
No, I would never ask a V-tuber to hand me their IP. Absolutely, I would not do it.
The brocomnomicom holds power beyond comprehension.
I like that the detail that ICSF is based on materials from a crash plane.
I fucking asked the concept artist about that and he was like,
I'm like, I mean, actually, because she could only scavenge what was around, you know.
What's going on? We are watching the pinned VOD.
There's a timestamp top left if you want to watch the VOD in the background and I'm yapping over it as always.
Happy accident in concept art? No, no, no, no.
So AC doesn't have access. AC lore-wise does not have access to civilization or anything like that.
So the only clothes she could get was whatever she had at the time when she was found by her mother bear and her brother and sister bear
and whatever was scavenged in the wildlife.
Are they fighting?
What are they doing?
I love it.
I can't burp on command. I can't do it.
I can't do it.
What? Can they all burp on command and I can?
Oh my gosh.
I'm jealous. They can all burp on command?
What? How do you do that?
I can't do it, bro.
Oh, teach me the secret.
Bro, I need to turn that into a short as well. What the heck? The stream's so good.
You need to gulp air.
I don't know how to do it. I don't know how to do it. I don't know how to do it. I don't know how to do it. I don't know how to do it.
I don't know how to do it.
How do you swallow air?
Do you need to bite it?
With your throat, then the burp goes up.
Breathe in quick and deep.
You know how mercy can't whistle? I can't burp on command. I don't understand what they're doing.
You just swallow bubble air.
I'm going to teach you during the convention.
Cappadi.
I would say me. I'd actually say me.
Are you dumb?
Oh, dumb! I thought she said dumb.
Dumb. Not me, then.
She burps in French.
Okay, I want mercy. I heard dumb.
I love mercy's laugh.
She be then stroney for dumb?
She be.
Lore-wise, yes.
Is that how you say keyfabe? I thought it was keyfab.
Keyfabe.
I prefer to produce dumb content. I have a preference for it, like, definitely.
What the fuck? This is so clippable.
Why have none of them submitted these clips to me?
Please, Reflins, if you're doing this, please clip this on ShoeV's channel so I can get access to the clips.
Oh my gosh.
Everyone was too busy watching the clip one-handed, honestly.
Just wait the rest of the streamers like this.
Ah.
Crestroom is good. Just streams it.
Maybe they felt it. It's spicy.
Clippers, you're being signed.
I'll pass it on.
I hit her.
Fucking hell, she be burping me under the table. Hold on a minute here. I think I'm getting out-burped.
Yeah, Mercy did do it. She cooked.
Is he getting in?
Sleep. Slee in the Banking Edgeville, Denver.
Oh, me?
Wait, do you think I'm a degenerate?
Yeah.
Denver, did I tell you my ace mould arrived?
I was going to take a picture and tag you in it and be like, you're such a trend, sir, Denver.
And then I was going to take a picture- I was going to take ShoeV and Emy's picture of it,
and I was going to add you, Denver, and be like, look what you've done to it.
Be a lure you've affected.
You have had catastrophic effects on a V-Suber company, how dare you, Denver, how dare you.
You have a black mill bit. It makes me so bad.
Soju. I've never had soju. I dare you to do it.
Okay, okay, let me- let me cook after the stream. As I'm cooking these wines, let me cook and eat for a minute.
The mould is, I think it's the exact same one that you've got, Denver.
That thing- that thing was thang and that thing is big.
It packs our meaty wallop. I've not put it in the mould and put it in the freezer yet,
but that's happened, they're all fine.
A giant ace is genuinely convenient, though.
Sestrone can never claim to be hot- ShoeV again, what the-
That person- the person that made the entire company render face-
This is almost a Jenshawkin.
V-Suck is real, I knew it. How dare you, Vulcan dynasty. How dare you.
What are we-
We're-
Oh.
What?!
Where is this conversation going?!
Oh my god, that makes so much sense why someone posted that meme about ShoeV.
I have my head on- I have my hand on my head right now.
I'm seriously using it to put in my Stanley and keep my drinks cool.
Oh my god, I'm gobsmacked.
There's an all-by-yourself handsome-
Hey, let's go ShoeV, she knew it.
Hey, she knew it.
That accusation.
That's good.
Actually, speaking of hydration, Riflin hydrate for me darling.
It's been two and a half hours when you hydrate.
Ugh.
I love when ShoeV walked away from the lake.
Mm-hmm.
This is my first stream of all skirmishes.
I have not played the game.
Why are we trying to reach 99 in Cookin? Is it useful or is it a goal?
It's a goal of mine as a child to reach one skill 99
and I picked Cookin purely based on the fact that I'm a woman.
I said what I said.
And we're just doing it now.
We're an edge bill.
And then we're watching a vaude in the background.
Real.
I didn't...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Here's Johnny, anytime stamp where you are on said vaude.
I'm not in this vaude. I'm watching my gen mates.
Unless you mean this top left.
I missed what she said.
Whoops.
What?
Ah.
They were down bad this stream.
Unironically.
Time to make some cosplay.
You guys show up to the convention and masks and stuff
and they'll be like literally flying over the panel desk to come see you.
What the fuck?
Well, there's going to be a lot of pyramid head cosplays in the Veeler.
Real.
What the fuck?
That makes me such a dick.
Oh my god.
She's feral.
Yeah.
Put me in the water.
I'll fuck them up.
Actually, I'm a really good swimmer.
Just to flake that one.
I want to take up swimming again.
I should.
It would be a healthy outlook for me.
They're already doing one.
In August.
Some of them who's already recorded it at that point.
That's a fucking nightmare.
But it'll be out soon.
I hate swimming.
I'm not a water person.
I might go for a small nap.
Rest well. Sleepy head.
I'll still be on.
I'm doing endurance.
Rest well, those who need to sleep or do some stuff.
A Scott thinks she'd win in the fight.
I'm shocked.
A scrawny in a swimsuit.
I wear the swimsuits that cover all of me up.
It goes down my thighs and spoof.
I'll still be on.
I think it passed, though.
I can't answer that.
So that's a hard question.
That's important.
Yeah!
Amy! Oh my god. Mercy actually getting on her corruption arc. She's so embarrassed.
That's adorable.
Are you squidding me right now?
You fucking troll. Go enjoy your anniversary with your wife. I didn't know that fuckers the concept artist that we gave the secret thing to and it is their anniversary today with their wife
What the fuck are you? Go spend the day with your fucking wife. That's an order.
Don't fuck around on old school runescape. Fucking watch in the stream. Go hang out with your wife. It is a happy anniversary unironically though.
Here's to many more for you two together.
That's the real concept artist that's just donated for Veiler. It is truly the anniversary with him and his wife today.
Amy's just fucking donated. Don't watch this stream. Go plop each other or whatever it is people do on their anniversaries. Order takeout. Don't fucking think about work.
You've been taking off the roster. Happy anniversary unironically though. Congrats. That's adorable.
Go plop each other. I'm crying.
That's the fucking concept artist for folks sake.
What if they're fucking right now?
Great for ASMR when? Do you want it?
It's literally the concept artist that's made Gen 2 and Gen 1. Fuck.
No, you're not winding me up for that.
It's literally the concept artist.
I haven't seen so much in Strong though.
Rage bait. I'm actually falling for it though unironically.
Gen 2 leaks. We just do a little trolling.
Temp at 30.
Mercy getting more corrupted each stream is a fun... look. I knew you guys wanted a corruption arc. I gave you it.
You wanted a don't-n-hack? I gave you a don't-n-hack. You wanted a corruption arc yandere? I gave you a corruption arc yandere.
Shawnee makes me so H-word. Tempo.
I thought Teemo. Yeah, yeah, Teemo's that legal legend.
Wait, isn't Teemo the purple one that lives in a jungle or something?
Debut reference. We lived...
Teemo is a tiny... that's Lulu.
Am I thinking of Beemo from Adventure Time?
Teemo is a little piece of squirrel. Okay, I'm sensing a bit of hate against Teemo.
I'm afraid I don't know legal legends at all.
What's the Brazilian one that looks like a lizard from League of Legends?
She's a girl. She's got purple hair and she has a voice like this kind of.
I cast Brazil. Niko! Niko! Yeah, Niko. I like Niko.
Now, before anyone's like, you please... no, I haven't played it yet.
Go now. Bye-bye. Thanks for hanging. That's not an hour in a day.
Clearly we have a legal legend player here.
Is there a way she stops breathing? It's so cute, Monkaeth.
A voice going on in this board!
Peter, the voice is here.
They don't know how to do Lois Griffin's voice?
Fuck, that was really good. What the fuck? The Scottish one can do the fucking impersonation better than like the American Canadians?
Chibi's lollipop voice is really... Oh, Lois's good voice.
Big stretch!
Okay.
The space of life. You do it better than everyone?
I don't even know whether...
Peter, look. Okay, fine. You win with your gay stuff.
I can't remember what other Lois quotes there are.
My cat just went...
Actually, I'm not going to upset Gimli and Beagle if I do that.
Pina, the voice is here.
No, it's a quote! Lois Griffin goes like...
Fine, you win with your gay stuff.
It's a quote, it's a quote.
There we are. That's an airhead.
Pina, we have a ham pot. Stop throwing your dirty clothes in the toilet.
I'm not kind of lost out there. American Laffy Taffy, okay.
She went for a drink.
What are you all talking about? Why didn't I join them when she was getting cute?
I fucking love that, I swear to you.
Oh, she's a weird...
Just cute, funny, though.
Saltwater Taffy, is it only except Saltwater Taffy?
We need to keep it funny ASMR Club.
What, all of us? I'll do that, don't think I want to arrange that.
I'll unironically do it.
How much will it cost to get the artwork?
How much would it cost to get the artwork?
I'll try to think.
How about I make you a deal?
Next month, I will get that arranged.
All six of us cute and funny ASMR Club deal.
What would the premise of the ASMR be?
That fucking thing that's really popular, it's like sleep next to a lollipop for eight hours.
Sleep next to six lollipops for 12 hours.
And I'll get all of us drawn in the bed around you.
I'll spend some fat stacks on that artwork to do it justice.
Deal? Okay.
Deal, but no requirement on our set.
Nah, you don't have to do anything. I'll just do it.
You guys don't have to do anything for that. It's fun.
Let me take a more wedding.
I was just going to get my music.
Shut up and take my money.
Oh, why not free for all oily mud wrestling days?
Bro, how would we even try and make the folly sounds for that?
It would basically just be all six of us grunting into the microphone, like Neanderthals.
And then oil sounds mixed in and skin and shuffling.
A little strongy better be cuddled up or latched onto our leg.
I'm going to have to get a really good artist for it.
I don't want to waste my money if they ain't going to draw it Kawaii-nee, you know what I'm saying?
Imagine Kawaii-nee, little Azura as well with her wee baby version of her horns and everything because they're not fully grown in yet.
So cute.
Was that the robot's death sound?
Mail and stream just kidding, she was a deep boy.
Neanderthal grunting is hitting the spot.
Oily six bodies found unconscious in the head.
Well, I don't know what we want. I've read that one.
Does her hair glow in the dark?
It doesn't glow in the dark, but it does this.
When I want to do hypnosis, I'm a cult fish.
This is what my hair is.
I don't glow in the dark.
I'm kind of a gluttony as well. I fucking love food, sorry.
How's Strony in it? Well listen, shimplash.
Six lollipops in a bed, sounds like some sort of FBI honeypot.
Call me Winnie the Pooh if it's a honeypot.
I'll make that ASMR and we'll all go on a list equally.
I'll get kicked out of Australia because you know.
And then it'll take me like a day to get to Scotland.
But in...
Sin said, if I'm ever in an emergency, she'd unironically let me go to her house.
So don't be surprised if I end up in Sin's house at some point.
Just take a seat right now.
Fetch me their souls.
Actually, I want to play Cod Zombies with you guys.
Can we get in Lobby's or Danny Addis' friend?
Strony streams from Melbourne Airport to not break her streams.
Real and true, real and true.
Fucking take a stop in London on the flight.
And like very quickly like fucking pop that shit up.
She shouldn't. No one got V Bridger.
No, I didn't order it.
It's probably leftover.
Yeah, eventually.
Eventually.
I don't know, I've never played Cod before.
Cod also has Prop Hunt.
I wouldn't mind playing Prop Hunt with you guys.
Shibu plays Gary's mod, Prop Hunt, and I want her to teach me.
Or like Trouble and Terrorist 10, I want to do that as well.
Oh my god.
Prop Hunt would be amazing.
Trouble and Terrorist 10 would be good.
Black Ops 6 will have normal brown base zombies again.
Wait, the other ones don't?
Did they change up the formula?
The girls are so unhinged, honestly.
Oh, not this again.
You're fucking ginger!
She's orange!
No, you're red at the end to compliment the accent colour in your design, Shibu!
Shibu's hair gets red at the end, but she's blonde.
No, not this debate again!
I can't escape it!
I have to start throwing hands again.
Hit him with a pose!
I'm level 97, kicking!
How are you ahead of me?!
You've been doing it off stream, how do you?
We looked at it, Emi's hair is mostly your memory.
Her concept art is a redhead, but the art is lightened or a bit...
Right.
As long as we agree concepted Emi is a ginger, okay?
And she's changed her hair to be more ginger anyway.
But she is ginger, sorry, but she's not blonde.
I can literally see the orange hue in her hair, and what world is that blonde as ginger?
She brought it back, you should just fight people at this point.
Honestly, the gloves are off at the convention.
I'll have an extra little scene that says you think that Emi is blonde, and then I just straight up start fighting you.
I just chalk you out with my thighs as a result.
Emi's so cute, she can't do it.
Are you watching something?
Yes, it's linked in chat.
The timestamp is top left.
We're watching me gen mates.
Shimpalash.
Oh no, please beat me up and choke me out.
Emi was blonde all along.
I dare you.
For your insolence, you will receive one choking out.
Oh.
Aww, that's pretty.
Aww.
Honestly, gothify everyone.
Never ask a man his salary.
Never ask a woman her age.
Never ask a reflin on his opinion at 2001 Space Odyssey.
And never ask a story about Emi's hair color, true.
Golf company, honestly?
Very plausible.
Incredibly plausible.
For AC, she's like, legit adorable princess style.
Gothalur, Gialur.
I'd be sorry.
Yeah, pastel goth phrase.
What's the RK?
If gender or Goths, then really if I'm going to lose the golf court.
Maybe I just attract them.
Jirai Ke, it's an outfit style.
Oh, I'm learning.
It's like dark but still feminine.
Really educated.
Aww.
Do not wait for Gen 2.
Gen 1 is already all Goths.
I'm starting to think we might be, AC might be the pastel exception.
Ezra's tracking so good.
Broad-narrated soil on us.
Oh!
Damn, Emi, Emi needing that zoomer attention, the fuck.
Oh, right, she means H word.
Okay, that's different, she means H word.
Who is asking my daughter about her fucking...
Shit and havers.
AC could be like the goth that is another phase.
Gotta get ready to go visit families.
Jani, love you, really be refilling.
Everyone have a good night.
Enjoy visiting the fam.
I'll probably be on by the time you're back.
AC is a cyber goth.
Ooh.
Does it smell cute and funny?
My brothers.
Wait, what was the content?
Oh, was it the puke one?
Veiler figure in a jar?
I don't know, I think Hulk gluen's pretty nice.
I'm like crazy, I'm probably crazy for that but I think it's cool.
Ooh.
She carved a name into her figure.
Oh, I never saw that.
Oh my god.
The figure is just gone.
It's fucking gone.
I'm out, I'm out.
Oh.
Okay, I think I know why Mercy took this then.
Ah.
The woman was too stunned to speak.
The woman was too stunned to speak, honestly.
Hey.
The mayor's the machine but she is crazy with what she planned for the girl coming to Wonderland.
Doesn't know this isn't even the worst part, yeah.
I like how they're all in tech support midstream, that's amazing.
It gets better.
Yeah, I'm inclined to Mercy.
Look, I like complimenting my daughters.
Shit, I'm guilty of fucking complimenting my daughters.
Shit, arrest me, arrest me if it's a crime.
He just got called out, literally.
They made it against the law to compliment my daughters.
I'm gonna shock him.
Oh no.
I will get a fucking gore.
Look, look, I'm just, I like everyone.
I will arrest you on the charge of making all of us hatred on the team, caught in 4k.
Trying to get hit with right and left by the girl, sounds like you have things to confess.
No.
Oh, she's gone, Azur is gone again.
Stop right there, you violated the law.
Scratch, scratch and strays left and right, you can just imagine what's going on in the discord.
Look, look.
As I said, everyone may or may not have been made a little in my image.
Azur not being in the frame, but yeah, literally.
What's she be said?
Shawnee after stream gonna be like, girls, I saw a certain stream.
Oh, we're almost in the tens of thousands instead of the 20th thousands.
Azur's good boy, what little thing would you do at your gym mate?
You mean like if I had an ideal scenario with them?
I'm not even sure I'm allowed to see it out loud.
I'll tell you after the stream because I can't focus while they talk at the same time.
You guys will remind me of that question at the end of the stream because I like watching this VOD, sorry.
Because I can't focus and talk at the same time and listen at the same time, it's too much as an overload.
After the stream stream, we can't emergency meeting.
Don't you ever do that?
Stun Lord.
She's not even able to look.
Okay, okay, okay, I see it.
Blindfold her gets a second eye patch.
Zero bat, mommy taking notes for future inspirations, y'all.
Elf cob's gonna be something else.
The biohazard we'll create together.
Oh, no steps, sis, I'm stuck under the desk.
Ooh, romantic.
The base gremlin laugh.
Ugh.
No?
All the girls have wonderful love.
Mercy's just so unique in those enemies.
Hey, she's as good as well. Everyone's laughing, sis.
Oh my god.
Love tabs.
Monka is.
Oh my god.
We're gonna explicit detail.
Monka is.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit, that was good.
And then you know when Mercy deleted the mod from her own channel, she can't handle it.
That's so cute.
Oh, that's so cute, though.
You know, I'm not gonna lie, Azura actually eats a lot, talks a lot about eating Mercy.
And I'm starting to think she ain't joking no more because it's been mentioned quite a few times.
What the fuck? She's not even kidding.
She's not even kidding. You can tell when Azura is joking. She's not even kidding.
I need to write that freaking vor right away. What the fuck?
Azura got yellow fever? What? When did she divulge this information?
You thought the goddess of fertility was just in there?
Wait two more times, it's not a joke anymore.
Oh my god, no Emmys drilling, I've just noticed her drillers.
Oh, she missed the walk away?
She had to walk away, that's hilarious.
She's sweating now. It's super effective, Pokemon style.
No, no, no, no, no, it's part of the aesthetics.
Okay, they peeled it back.
If you censor it and get around it girls, you can do it.
Aesthetic! Everyone has taken psychic damage.
Azura's supremacy.
They totally peeled it back.
Wait, does she?
No, I lost mine. I lost mine in the Great War. I lost mine in the Great War of Transport.
I need to order, I want to order new ones. I lost tons in the Great War.
No, I think it's Emmy, sorry, I think it's Emmy. I want to say it's Emmy.
So many have been sacrificed, literally.
Thank you, thank you, I'll be here all day.
There's one thing Azura, she's the goddess of fertility, not fertility, goddess.
And there's a difference between them, and she says fertility goddess.
And I'm always trying to gentle pair it and be goddess of fertility, but I'm just letting her have it.
But she's the goddess of fertility, not fertility goddess. Does that make sense?
What's the difference? So a fertility goddess could be anything.
You could have implies there can be multiple of this vocation, whereas the goddess of fertility, there is only one true goddess of fertility, which is Azura.
That makes sense. And lore-wise Azura is everyone's mum, which is the difference.
And there is only one Azura, you know?
Fertility goddess of fertility implies people.
No, she's the goddess of fertility. You've got it the other way around.
Wait, that's not the exact opposite. No, you've done it the other way around.
Oh, that's the fertility goddess. Oh, they're also a fertility goddess.
But that's Azura, the goddess of fertility. Hold up, let her cook.
Oh.
Goddess of fertility of fertility, got it.
No, no, that's not how it works.
Are you still planning on watching Genmate's Vods?
I have absolutely terrible news for you. We're watching one right now. All the information's at the top of the stream.
The timestamp, what we're watching, and it's LinkedIn Gen Chat, like in the general chat.
Oh, she's not telling us.
How bad was the costume, god damn!
A bit too supportive of her. Will you be streaming to others? I'm going to try to, whether or not we get there.
I unfortunately have been taking a lot of HP damage behind the scenes recently.
What was she? I don't know, I don't remember her posting anything.
We tried to get her to tell us she still wouldn't do it.
Have any of you broken the law?
Oh, G-Walking's real, I forgot about that. Public indecency.
Yeah, it was me.
She did it, please tell me she didn't.
I saw a watch when I was 5 or something. Confession stream starts now.
Do you have any marks on your leg lift? I don't know, they all went. No, they're all gone.
It looked like it had a weird version of chickenpox.
I don't know.
G-Walking? Yeah, no bruising.
Her M-E-M-E-D-E-D-E-D-E-D-E-D-E recently.
Noted, E-M-E. Noted.
Noted. I have a very unique plot for E-M-E, actually.
She's the daughter of a mafia boss and she needs to break you, basically, to do the bidding of the family, so...
I'm gonna see what I can do, but she basically degrades you, and it's with her feet.
I don't know if I made her do a foot recently, but I really like the concept and the premise.
I'm gonna try and develop it further.
Is that a banger plot? Yeah, you like it? Have you committed a crime? Public indecency, probably.
Al Capone mentioned, mafia boss daughter or peer? Weirdly common.
Good one. Are the ASMRs cannot? No.
It is not possible for the girls to produce audios in the same lower...
It limits them severely. I would never do that. I would never do that.
What's your favourite audio? My? Of me?
I actually like the Reefling Honey Tea one, because we wrote it together and it felt so much more special than what I'm guessing.
It felt really nice. We wrote it together and then produced it. It was really nice. I liked that. It was very nice.
Surely made an offer they can't refuse.
So you come to me on the day of my daughter's... something.
Ooh, did that pop?
Finish a race on a day? Is this what they're asking?
No, she beats fucking background music coming out of nowhere.
It means like four or something.
Yeah, literally, you got me, Stevie.
Wait, can they have multiple?
Can they have multiple?
I don't have that ability.
On the day of my daughter's wedding.
Just straight up a gunin' session. What the fuck is this?
How do you even get in dolphins after like the third batch? I don't know.
Wanna find out if you can?
Okay, that was smooth. I'll give you that reform. That was smooth.
Don't make me boot up Supermarket Simulator, okay?
That stream got limited ads, because of how much I was talking about Inca news in the back.
I don't have that ability. What the fuck? I need like a hot patch or something.
Put me in. Developers, what the fuck?
One, when you put the G-spot in my fucking ass, which makes no sense.
Two, you deny me the multiple fucking collateral that everyone else gets. What the fuck?
What?
What? Two minutes?
Hello, hi.
I'm one and done in like maybe seven seconds.
If I'm, you know, if it's a lucky day, maybe, you know, a whole ten seconds of joy.
Like shit.
Uh...
She's mercy cheesin'.
Real.
We're reaching the fireworks. Is there a freak?
Do I need a reflux and play with her?
Like a player like a violin and sure about a body can really do it?
MonkaS? Is that a threat or a problem?
We're approaching 95. We absolutely are.
We're at 141 for remaining.
Honestly, real and true.
I'm sorry, but if I had one reflux, it'd be over. You'd be my first target.
I'd be honing in.
I'd be honing in on your address.
Stacking donuts is so real, though.
That should be my sequel. Please let me stack donuts on it, please.
Right, I'm going to write the sequel to the please let me hold it.
It's please let me stack donuts on it.
Next, let me write that down on a piece of paper.
Write that down, write that down.
Hold on.
Please let me stack donuts on it.
On it.
Post donut clarity, real!
You can stack your donuts on it.
Yes, mummy, this'll win. Right now, bend over, darling.
Text? How much can you feel with it?
No, no, that's not real. I think that's a meme.
I think that was a prank that guys put together, okay?
Yeah, I think that was a meme that guys put together to confuse women.
No, don't do that.
No, reflins, don't do that either.
I have not dipped my nuts in soy sauce to confirm.
Reflin, no!
Reflin, did you actually test it out after reading it?
What?
Girlfriend begs you to dip in soy sauce to see if you can taste it.
Really sure.
I'll make me like a Twitter one.
My ex.
This actually happened on Sheeby's Twitter? What?
No, I mean, that just sounds inconvenient.
I know someone who did alcohol with his moh.
It makes you like, how dare you, RuneScape, you've been playing for a while, consider taking a break from your screen.
How dare you care for my health and well-being.
I'm gonna go pee, I'll pee and we'll get a break after the vodka's finished and we'll get up and stretch and pee and I'll get food as well.
Okay.
What's the question?
Four!
No, the vodka's ending.
What's the tape?
Is that not anything?
It's not a freak, but in a good way.
Well, do you just seem to have been looking at the screen the whole time?
Soy sauce is the beginner level. We're trying hot sauce.
Oh, God.
Oh, bless her.
Bless her.
Cut his or his face.
But but, three holes, four toys.
One wouldn't be put on the peril.
Hot sauce on the torture zone was an Aztec method.
I'm sorry.
Lurking them shadows.
Badimts.
I literally, Kohai, never seen you so quiet before.
Our little yapper.
She's scared.
Veil or meet-up cancelled after this stream.
I wish it.
Aw, that'd be adorable.
Mercy's sort of classed here.
Oh, yeah, basically.
Yeah, we love AC, please.
Is that me?
Or is that AC?
No.
That was where AC.
Oh, okay, right.
I was like, okay.
Hello, replaying.
We AC's weave is so good.
Oh, I hear it now, I hear it now.
It's cute, it's adorable.
So cute.
AC innocent, that woman wants us nowhere,
so we're on a train on it, real.
Oh, it's already got monetized.
God, that's such a nightmare.
Yep.
Azura was last, but not least.
YouTube made her jump through hoops.
Eh, close enough, close enough, yeah, it's fine.
Girls.
This is how...
they are, actually.
Oh, Amy must have been on the other side.
Oh, my tummy's getting sore,
because I'm hungry.
Hawaii.
Eat, Momay, I'll eat when I get up.
I'll finish this board, and then we'll eat.
What's the name?
Oh, Shiver.
I'm with the science team.
Ah.
Holy shit, I can't handle vibration.
I can't handle vibration.
Too much.
Oh, they all, oh my, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I think I'm broken, I think I'm secretly a guy
somehow or something, because, yeah.
Because, literally, it's too much, it's far too much.
Eh, what board are we watching next?
We will find out, we're going to take a break,
I'm going to get some food, I'm going to make a cup of tea,
I'm going to go for a pee, because my bladder's full,
my stomach's empty.
And then we will pick the next board to watch.
I don't know what kind of ones you guys recommend.
I think, I really don't know what kind of ones
you guys recommend.
I don't know what kind of ones you guys recommend.
I think, I really want to watch Emmy's Handcam stream
with Esteban and all of that, where the rats were out,
because that was really cute, I think that was really cute.
And I really want to see it.
Oh, for fuck's sake, I never wrote the name.
My favorite Emmy, Lily Poff.
Oh, Maryse told the truth, she did need to go on.
The rats stole everything?
Yeah, I think the kick and stream of the rats is adorable.
Yeah, Emmy's shit, yeah, kind of kicked on Emmy's,
Mama, you're going to get some food.
Yeah, I'm going to get some food, because I'm starving.
That looks like she's vaping, like randomly.
Okay, that was funny.
Oh, Maryse is so shy, she's so adorable.
Anime Astrome, right?
She was strong, she was going to tell us what she was going to do at Gemma's.
Oh, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
Can I get food first though?
I'm starving, I'm so exquisiting.
Oh, Maryse.
We just need to make her more comfortable with being a degenerate on main.
Rats.
Oh, Azura's gone, she's had enough.
Maryse.
Maryse must be dreading the awful album.
No, no.
Thanks for coming to the, she should have stopped it.
Thanks for coming.
What's really real?
Real.
I have told her, her discord make does not like her, and she can't go through her pit.
And she's like, you know what's wrong, eh?
And I'm like, yes, Azura.
Burpee.
Maryse in the off collab.
I'm in danger, honestly.
Oh my God, I wish I had time to edit and draw this, like my version.
You know the anime girl that's hiding under the desk?
Put Maryse there, and the rest of us are like, oh, Maryse.
And it's like POV violers first off collab, and we're like coming after her.
The one we're tearing it.
I don't know, there's like an anime girl under a desk.
I got it edited with a death claw when we played Fallout.
Because the fucking thing chased me in our bloody hoose.
Is she pulling Emmy up? She is.
She is.
Emmy's grippers for free, real.
If in the future you want to watch more of us, feel free to do it.
This is fantastic. You've not already watched it, your reactions are cute.
Oh my God, you can't say that.
Even if it's true.
It's too much for Maryse, but the rest is okay.
Oh, she doesn't want to get a warning.
Maryse wants to be a well-behaved yandere.
Aww.
Aww, baby.
Aww, she's so cute.
She's so cute.
Aww, she's so cute, Maryse.
Aww, bless their cotton book.
That's actually the reason.
Aww, yeah.
We'll turn her into one of us soon enough.
Oh, about 77,000 until the next level.
I'm not sure how many wings that is.
Yubi's shit.
Aww, that's adorable.
They're on the same brain wave length.
Yeah, they should refund this.
Yeah, I know that.
Sorry, I'm playing with that squishy bowl if you can hear me.
Maryse, something in the background, just in case.
Heh.
I love the tech support live on stream.
I'm adoring this.
Live tech support on getting a refund.
It came with your eggs, fuck.
Oh my god, this is precious.
What an air.
No way, they're doing live tech support
so if you can get a refund, that is adorable.
Oh, she's talking through it.
Oh my god, this is precious.
My tech illiterate little sister.
She was like, she didn't care what V-Sync was the other day
when she was playing Poppy Playtime and I'm like,
darling?
Real? True?
Sweetheart.
She doesn't know what resolution monitor was.
Adorable!
Aw, they all redirected an Ezreal, that's nice.
I like that.
Drumroll.
Wholesome allegations, upheld.
Technologically illiterate V to this.
Actually, I want to watch Azur's membership celebration as well.
We'll watch Amy's rights, Azur's membership,
and then we'll see what kind of team we're looking at
because I don't know what the deal is.
Bye!
Bye-bye!
We've got a little kiss on Sheeby's paws.
Okay, we did it!
Okay, I paused it, it says pause but don't worry,
it'll change its pickle in a second.
Right, we are gonna pop these wines
and then I'm gonna go for a pee.
Didn't she celebrate by playing League? She better not have.
I thought she did a hand cam stream where she really did one stuff.
She was wrong bleeding hearts. Yes, I want to watch that one
because I've not watched that one.
Did you like it?
There was a lot of clip-able moments.
I'm gonna maybe be naughty and go on Sheeby's account
and just gonna walk and check out who's been clippin' her
because the clip said...
Oh, I popped it! 95!
I thought it would... 95, let's go!
Level 95!
We can now make a summer pie!
Ooh!
A summer pie!
Only a cabillion more XP to go.
But we started at 30K.
We are now getting into the tens.
So that's really good for us.
Honestly, depending on how close it is,
I might be tempted to just do an all-nighter
and we'll get this shipped.
And then that'll be me...
Like, I can cross it off my goals list.
Only like 20...
I am considering it.
A summer pie... I don't even know what summer pie is.
Fruits, maybe?
Summer pie!
But yeah, I might lock in
and we'll do an all-nighter, possibly.
We are playing Blinks tomorrow.
How did you send a message with nothing in it?
Oh, okay, I did it as well. I'm sorry.
Um...
We are playing Blinks tomorrow,
which is like a strawberry watermelon and apple.
Here's a bit of sleep. I need to watch a cutfish goodnight.
I still need 40K wines.
I am thankfully at 20K right now.
Not to rub it in your face, but...
I'm at 20K.
If...
And it's like...
I don't know.
We'll know closer to the time
if we're there or not.
And if we could... I could maybe pop out the last endurance of it.
The last... No, I don't know how I'm going to say it,
because obviously right now we're only four hours in.
That's not really that rough.
But once we hit the, like, you know,
pushing the eight hour mark,
that's when the body starts becoming weary.
And I'm like, ooh, you know?
You can rub something in our faces.
It's my peaches and stuff.
I don't need sleep. I need to cook!
I need to ferment this wine.
That's what I need to deal with.
And then we'll go to the Grand Exchange
and sell all the wines off for, like, pennies.
Like, literal pennies.
Mmm.
Right.
I would like to urge everyone,
please get up and stretch your legs.
Please go to the toilet. Please get a drink.
Please get food.
I am going to be a solid five minutes,
because I'm going to put...
I'm going to put chicken in the air fryer.
Like, it's like this breaded chicken.
So I will need to go get it in 20 minutes
when it's ready.
But please do get food. Please do stretch.
I'm going to get a cup of tea. I'm going to get water.
I'm going to see if I've got any fizzy juice as well.
I always make sure to get every...
up every two hours.
Yes, I do that too, wink, wink.
You can ferment yourself for the reef.
What does that mean? What does that mean?
My legs.
I can't feel my legs.
I was like, I said I'm going to...
I already baked a loaf of bread yesterday.
I had to squeeze that fucker out.
Ah, that's disgusting.
Shut ups for me, honestly.
Right.
I will be back in five minutes.
And then we will
watch Amy's
Poppin Cooking,
I believe it is called.
And she brings out her lovely jubbly
rats. I believe it's a two hour long
bod. And then we'll do a
zura.
And then we'll see what kind of time we're looking at.
Because I don't know if I have enough time
between to watch everyone
unless it is endurance.
I don't know.
Lieutenant Dan, you ain't got no legs.
Even though I've not seen that film.
Right, I'm going to be a solid
freaking four or five minutes.
The way I do it is I have to
boil the kettle first.
And then I go pee while the thing
boils.
And then I go in the fridge and shove stuff
in the microwave or whatever.
And then normally Gimli and Vigo
come flying around and asking me
for a licky lick. And I'm like, right, right,
I'll give you a licky lick.
They're really patient, actually,
when I do an endurance cream, which I'm really
lucky with. Do you have a breath pee?
I'm so sorry.
Dear hero, I don't know.
Microwaving maxing, which they take
your time to bring yourself out.
Burn myself out. I got
head to work. I'll still be able to listen.
Ooh, lurking in the shadows.
Okay.
I will very quickly go get all that
done. I'm just going to get one more, one more
wine in, okay? One more wine in.
Let me click, let me click. Ready, steady,
go!
Okay.
Oh, no, this can't be.
Oh, yeah.
I'm back.
Let me in. Let me in.
My food is going to take six
minutes, so I'm going to go back
in like a millisecond.
But I just need to grab it
out of the air fryer, so it's not a problem.
It's not like an issue or anything like that.
Okay.
Hmm.
Boy, Ray kuma,
momolowe and cam keos, don't think
I don't see you. Don't think I don't see
what you're doing.
I'm so old. I remember
when runescape yet to let your character
sleep. Is that real?
I say Xtorsion
one the Xtorsion rey fun.
I didn't even,
I do not,
not at all.
She got us. Caught you in 4k, so our stream elements is figure it catch me now.
Yeah, back in classic it had a fatigue mechanic.
Oh, I didn't know anything about that.
I'm actually such a fake RuneScape fan that I didn't even know that.
Such a fake gamer.
Such a fake, fake, fake gamer.
What's that? You don't know the name of the director's cousin?
Oh, fake fan. You didn't play the game. You're just pretending.
Did I tell you guys I did that to someone one time?
They were like, I can't remember. It was in another life.
And it wasn't the last life. It was the other other life.
And he was like, oh, why do you talk about games all the time?
Like, why do you say that you play games?
And I was like, I used to talk about it as a subject in general.
So I DM'd back sarcastically.
And I was like, message back sarcastically.
Like, oh, I just pretend to like games to get guys' attention.
And it backfired horrendously because he actually genuinely believed that.
And he probably still to this day believes it because he'll be like,
oh, I spoke to a girl one time and she said she did it for male attention.
I was like, oh, it was the fact they didn't even question it.
I was like, it was clearly sarcastic.
I was like, oh, I just pretend I like video games to get guys' attention.
Like, what? And he believed it.
So that guy now has a fallacy about girls pretending to enjoy video games.
So just in case you wanted to use humor and sarcasm against via text,
it does not work unless someone can hear the tone of your voice.
You literally fail for it. You have all of her attention.
To be fair, there are girls that do that.
I can't imagine a girl sitting through all the harassment of playing a multiplayer game
just to be like, I do this for attention.
Unless I'm misunderstanding what you mean.
I can't imagine that.
Did you not type I'm kidding?
I think either they never responded or they responded with like,
oh, thanks for clarifying.
Have a nice day.
The conversation ended after the message.
So it wasn't like I was like, bro, I'm obviously joking.
I just sit and play games like anyone else.
I have access to video games.
You have access to video games.
It's nothing special.
You underestimate mental illness.
No.
But that's what I'm saying.
Now that guy like straight up has a fallacy.
Like, girl, girl pretend.
People do more and worse things for attention.
To be fair, it's working on us.
Oh, yeah.
You think that this is a live stream and not pre-recorded?
Because apparently all my streams are pre-recorded met us.
How dare you.
She just makes videos with controllers and things and say that I'm a gamer.
Real me posing with a controller.
Actually, I know a girl that tried to play Rinscape to get a guy's attention.
You know, go give it to her.
Some people fake hobbies in general.
I don't know why though.
I think some people might feel that they don't have value.
If they don't have something they pursue.
But you don't have to pursue anything.
I mean, like, shit.
If you want to tell, if you want to say what my hobbies are,
playing video games, drinking cola, and being a weirdo,
and going into people's gardens to collect seeds.
Like, you don't need to be interested in to have value.
You can be the most, like, normal, plain Jane type thing.
I think maybe that's why people would try and lie.
And to make themselves seem more exciting and more...
Because obviously you want social favour with people.
And, you know, if it's your perception that the group around you would like that you're a gamer,
because they talk about games.
And yeah, you might be like, oh, I've heard of that game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the reality is maybe you've only heard about it in passing.
And, you know, you read an article.
It's just the next Dark Souls type thing.
I've wasted 25 years of your life?
No, you've not.
Don't make me put my tinfoil hat on.
You cannot waste life.
Because if you're telling me your value only comes by being a cog in the machine,
it's over for you.
Hey guys, Strone Stream Script to here.
Did you like the tongue and cheek jokes Strone just made about scripting and pre-recording streams?
We're playing about with meta-humour, so give us feedback and we'll improve the script.
You're actually done.
So give us feedback and we'll improve the script.
Thank you for the tip.
Strone Stream Scripts are...
Something I'm not on to you.
This is obviously a pre-recorded stream.
Strone is in hypnosis and clairvoyance.
Oh my god, I got a really nice comment.
That was like, oh, even though I don't, like, consume your content,
I can just tell that, like, you're a trustworthy hypnotist and I'm like,
oh my fucking god, you're like, stop.
Like, even being allocated the title hypnotist, I'm like,
stop, I will cream my custards right now.
I think Strone Streams are live.
She just pre-records her streams as the other girls.
What are you talking about?
Snowberries.
I have no idea.
Anyway, I think Amy is streaming later.
But I'm really laying on that accent there.
I don't want a little bit of shite, a little bit of shite.
Yeah, the rest of us were here last week to record this footage.
Oh my god, real in-game footage.
The reflands came together to make this legit.
Blowing into people's gardens to collect seeds.
Is that a euphemism?
No, I collect seeds.
I just find them really fascinating.
There's that big Norwegian bunker in the ice, perma-ice,
that's like frozen all the seeds.
I would love to visit there one day,
but I don't even think it's accessible to the public.
But that's my dream date.
Cheeky bit of Lord of the Rings, cheeky bit of Takeaway,
and we go to that bunker all the seeds in it
just so I can look and observe at the absolute beauty
that Mother Nature is in her diversity,
in her perseverance, in her just-
oh, in awe, awe.
Cannae, just gorgeous, gorgeous, gorgeous, gorgeous.
The diversity in how nature overcomes
and becomes such unique organisms
is just fantastic.
That's what it really is.
I think I can smell that my ear fryer is done.
Global Seed Vault, you should travel a lot
to see more and more seeds along here.
Is that what I think it is?
Is that an in-bait for me to ask?
Right, I'm gonna go very quickly
get my chicken tendies as I chuckle my spit unironically.
Fucking, it's a bit dry in here.
Yeah, damn.
Right, I'll be one second.
Okay.
I hit no.
Reflings, look, I don't judge if it's floppy
or it's hard, but that chicken looked a bit floppy
so I'll put it in for another two minutes.
It was a bit too floppy for me.
A bit too floppy.
I don't know, she's lost efficiency.
Stop.
Come on, guys.
Thank you, Momolo, Aipu, Rekumon, Kamki.
My kitchen's literally right there, so, you know.
Literally, it was floppy.
I'm like, no, I'm gonna put you back in.
Just a little bit back in for a bit longer.
I'm not messing with floppy chicken.
The medium girlfriend ties you down
and tells you about C's ASMR.
So, I think the title would probably
just be autistic girlfriend rambles
about her seed collection,
but then I'll just straight up start putting
actual pictures of my seeds on the screen
and be like, hey, this is the one I collected.
That chicken got that, it's a bit flaccid.
Yeah, I'm not sure it can go inside me
if it's a bit flaccid.
Yay, yay, zing, get it, get it,
because I'm talking about floppy salmonella chicken.
And nothing else.
Nothing else can be ascertained
from that string of sentences.
Hardy, hardy, hard.
Listening to a girl who's super in her hobby is interesting.
Aw, I'm sure about that.
It needs to be harder, honestly,
but it actually comes from her seed collection.
It's just me jumping on your lap
and, you know, going,
Right, once my food is here,
we will put on Emma's lovely wee vlog.
What are we at?
We're almost, I want the 19s.
I'm a bit, I'm actually thinking.
Right, hear me out, this is what I'm thinking.
We do an endurance stream,
which will leave us with maybe four hours
to finish it off, okay?
Rather than doing an all-nighter,
which is going to be catastrophic to my already
catastrophic, catastrophic health
that's already in the gutter.
Instead, I will do a catch-up stream
where we finish Sonic Heroes Chaos,
we finish RuneScape 99,
and we finish the DLC on a little to the left,
because apparently there's a DLC on that game
that I didn't play,
and I really enjoyed a little to the left.
So we'll call it the finishing stream,
because I've edged you with the other things.
That sounds like a deal.
Wait, Sonic, you didn't even done the part
where you say what you would do at your dinner.
Oh!
Obviously, I see, like, the princess treatment.
She gives me brat tamer vibes
where she pretends she doesn't like it,
but it's just so obvious that she does.
Like, no matter what you do,
she deep down wants to please you
and pretends to be, like, she needs tamed,
but it only takes you a couple of minutes,
and, you know, she's already, like,
putty in your hands, type thing.
Emmy, everyone's really gone harsh on Emmy.
Ah!
Look, Emmy's gone through something traumatic.
I will never be able to replace her brother.
I've accepted that fact.
So what Emmy actually needs
is just an experience to bide her time, okay?
So I'm going to leave Emmy intact
because that V-card is for the pin pals, okay?
And instead, I'd rather do
a peril stimulation on her.
Just simple, basic, nothing really else to it.
You know, just tongue type thing
and just listen to her squirm, all that kind of thing.
Like, force the legs open kind of deal.
Just keep her intact, you know?
Go leave her for the pin pals.
Mersey, Mersey's definitely vanilla,
so you need to take it easy,
but what you need to do is enable her
to be comfortable in the environment
that you're prepping.
And she has said that she's into pet play,
so you need to very gently enter that space.
Let her enter that space while you enable her
in terms of, like, a collar, a leash,
maybe even just the threat of accessories
such as a dog cage or a bowl of milk, for example,
that kind of thing.
You kind of need to be gentle with Mersey,
but you need to let her at any moment,
like, be able to be like, I don't want this
and that's absolutely perfectly fine.
It would just be probably figuratively nice and easy
on her force.
If she's doing pet play, she's getting treated like a pup,
so, on her force.
And she's not allowed to speak,
so maybe like a bone gag in her mouth would be really cute.
Where are you getting these ideas from?
My head?
Western work.
You thought I'd pre-written these down or something?
No, this is coming from me.
It would be a bag of milk, actually.
How dare you.
She be...
Because she's been given the dominant role,
I think it would be nice
if she just got sozzled on some wine
in, like, whatever happens, happens type thing.
She doesn't have to be in a role.
She doesn't have to play the authoritative figure.
She doesn't have to be the dominant figure.
It's just whatever happens happens.
It's a giggle fest, you know,
things are being touched and felt and experienced
and, you know, probably the...
I don't know, she mentioned toys.
It's probably the, like, vibrator kind of stuff.
Just, like, having a giggle and be a relaxed atmosphere.
Azura scares me.
I don't even...
Okay, if, for whatever reason,
I could remove her ability to become a giantess...
Oh, hold on a minute.
Make her become a giantess,
then I can do some exploring.
You know what I'm saying?
Ooh, would she be into that?
I don't know.
Hmm.
No, I don't think I'll do that.
Splunking? No, not splunking, Azura.
Azura scares you, you should be scared.
She knows I should be into that.
No, but you'll be into her! Hey!
Okay, I'm going to do a very quick one,
and then go get my chicken that surely is erect by now.
So I don't want any fluffy chicken. I'll be right...
I'll be having it!
Stop giving me money for walking away, honestly.
You guys haven't seen it in a while.
Wow.
Thank you very much, Kalka and Zarian.
But knock it off, okay?
A bunch of yapping is what you miss.
After the grocery shop.
Any grocery shoppers?
Eh, right.
Let's get prepared to play Amy's Vod, okay?
Eh, I'm going to go a little bit quiet,
because I would like to munch my face off,
if that's okay with you guys, right? Hold on.
Give me a cheeky bit of Amy Vizu,
a poppin' chicken.
Amy Vizu, poppin' chicken.
I actually bought this stuff for that.
Oh, it's three hours long, it's a big Vod.
I saw.
This is definitely the one with the rats,
because all the rats are in it!
Ah, do this correctly.
Right, first, let's yank the title of the stream.
We're watching Making Candy with Pimpelz
on Amy Vizu.
Okay, she must have rolled her eyes when I gave her her name.
She's like, you can't go on any more stereo, typical friend.
Yes!
How do you? Right next,
the poppin' piece, the link into the
stereo, the URL, go.
Okay, we're good.
Oh shit, it started right away.
Okay, cheeky waffle.
Is it the candy stream?
Yes, the one with her cats.
Eh, her cats, her rats came out.
She doesn't have cats, she has rats.
Wait, love in my autogest stop.
Who named her?
Honestly, that's outrageous.
Don't forget to update the pinned message.
Wow, that's all I was not going to.
One...
One momento, por favor.
Okay.
I can't type in my own chat.
I said subscriber only mode.
Fuck.
What?
Hold on, let me refresh.
That can't be right.
And won't let me type.
I just...
I've been kicked out of my YouTube account!
Oh my god, did I have my password?
Oh, for pissing sake.
I've got kicked out of my YouTube account.
Bro, I better still be live though.
Hold on.
Hold on, let me just say a little...
I need to change on time.
YouTube literally kicked me out all the fucking time.
Um...
YouTube password.
I don't know why YouTube has such issues with me.
Just being Chinese.
Don't you laugh.
Being Chinese.
It fucking like despises me.
I don't know why.
I don't do anything to it.
I don't know.
I'm getting a bit ridiculous.
It was funny the first few times you kicked me out,
but I have to admit.
I don't know.
I love when YouTube hits me.
All of this because I want to watch an Emmy stream.
My oppressors are working.
Clearly, they're working overtime to hit the fuck.
Okay, I'm in! I'm in! I'm in! I'm in!
Okay, right.
We're in World 380.
We're edging.
In Edgeville.
And we're watching.
And then get the link to the video.
I'll see.
See.
And then...
Kissing my...
No.
No, wait.
What the fuck is this?
World 380.
Yeah.
Let me send.
And then watching.
Look at that book.
God, that was like way harder than it had to be.
Ten.
Watching an Emmy.
Okay.
We got there in the end.
Are we ready?
Replaying.
Do you have your little sister on screen?
Also, I have a blueberry muffin.
It's really imperative that you know I have a blueberry muffin.
Just so you should know.
It's imperative information.
I have a blueberry muffin.
I should be back on my PC and things.
Okay, we're ready.
On 3, 2, 1, go.
Ready.
3, 2, 1, go.
Oh, who cooked on this?
What an amazing background music.
Truly cooking.
Aren't you two seconds in?
Oh shit, maybe two seconds ahead.
You'll have to go ahead and then pause and then meet me.
It's so good.
It's my favourite.
Sorry, it's literally my favourite background music.
I don't know what to make Unconfirmed Gen 2's background based on.
I might do Legend of Zelda Minish Cap.
I'm not sure yet.
I might listen to the OSP.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
I wouldn't say him Heimcastle.
Super Mario.
I've never played that.
One day I might have a waiting screen to do.
Not our day.
I'm eating gems.
Mmm, mmm.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
I'm eating little gems.
Munch in and dance them.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
She's giggling.
She's always in that.
I don't know what game.
What childhood game?
Base them off a halo.
It's cute when girls dance and eat at the same time.
I'll be inhaling the ship.
Although I'm worried I'm going to burn my mouth on the chicken though.
I promise you my chicken is hard.
I solemnly swear the poultry is erect.
Amen.
Minish Cap.
Yeah, I thought about Minish Cap.
I'm going to have to listen to the OSP on Minish Cap.
Well, it might be a bit hard.
Sonic Heroes had a very diverse soundtrack,
which is why it was like a no-brainer
when I was pregnant with Gen 1.
But how hard was it?
Oh, it's so hard.
Hmm.
Oh, my sister's on.
Amy!
Hi.
It's her behind.
It sounds fine to me.
We have to cook, Amy.
We're already a reference to...
Wopa.
Is it tasty? It's delicious.
Gen 2 All Goth and background music is doom.
I hope Minish Cap has some diverse soundtracks,
but I can't remember.
Maybe Pokemon?
Maybe Pokemon Ruby?
Possibly.
Possibly Gen 3 Pokemon Inspiration.
That's plausible.
Cameo has some diverse soundtracks as well.
I don't know about Conker's Bad Friday.
Is that the real Amy Bezu from Generation V?
My poor Amy.
A message there about the cough,
and she was like,
it is what it is, and I said,
well, you don't have to do what you have to do,
you know what I mean?
Oh, she's on the floor!
Oh, my gosh, she's on the floor for the pentals.
Butter and Forte.
Are you a Sonic fan? Yay, Sonic Heroes!
Mega Man? I've never played Mega Man.
I'm trying to be selfish
and make it up about video games that I've played.
Oh, God, the Gen 3 Trumpets?
What?
Oh, the Gen 3...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pokemon, the Gen 3, literally.
It's so good.
Sonic Unleash.
Because it's already been based on Sonic,
I wouldn't go back to Sonic Influence for the background music.
Aw.
He got wee plasters
because she cannae stop picking her wee scabs up.
Aw.
And she painted her nails black as well
to be more accurate.
What a legend, honestly.
See these wee details that the girls do,
like, I don't even request none of this.
It's just, I'm doing, in real life stream,
okay, here's some of your schedule,
and they go above and beyond.
Mercy got matching nail polish
to band-aids and that.
The girls put so much effort into it.
They're so fantastic.
The pixel was on.
What are those?
I've never played Mega Man?
Mega Man?
GTA?
It has to be, like, nostalgic for me,
which limits the list so, so tiny.
Radiation?
Who said that?
Mint Pier?
Temple of Droplets?
I'll take a look into Pokmon
and Legend of Zelda Minish Cap.
Those are mostly, I'm gonna be honest with you,
I'm gonna see.
Sorry, I have food in my mouth,
like, so I can't see properly.
Hold on.
Hold on, and you go turn off the heat
and I'm getting cooked alive in here.
I'm so sorry, I had food in my mouth
so I couldn't see, I just had to,
I just had to fucking go,
I still feel it in my nose though.
Oh, sorry.
It's very unpleasant.
Rather unpleasant than trying to,
oh, she's going BRB already?
She's gonna try and fix the camera?
It's no big deal.
Colofish, more like, I sounded like a goose?
I thought it sounded more like a race car.
Hold on, can you get a drink of water?
It feels like,
like there's food at the back of my nose
that I can't, like, yeah.
I don't know if that makes any sense.
The peach, she's so cute.
Sheavey wanted that asset as well, actually.
I don't know.
I just remembered,
I bought Mercy artwork for a song cover.
I need to bother her about that.
And she put it on the back burner,
I can't remember why we paused it up.
I said it's what, when?
What, you mean like, April Fools?
What are you eating today, Reef Lim?
I got my chicken tendies.
I feed you my chicken tendies and my gems.
Or tater tots, as you guys call it, tater tots.
Let me get some tater tots.
And some rib eye steak.
And I'll take the,
the col, the slaw, I'll take the slaw.
Where else?
Do you stereotypically eat?
Oh, and the cornbread, I'll say I have cornbread.
I've never had cornbread in my life.
They're called gems.
Yep.
Tater tots are called gems.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Cornbread is so blue. Cornbread is fucking delicious.
Okay, we have two opposing opinions.
You're gonna eat your cornbread.
Also, no one eats tater tots with steak.
Steak are like high class.
Oh, I have steak and gems.
My dad actually wasn't happy.
I had steak and tater tots or gems.
And he was, like, having it in a fried egg.
And he was, like, strutty.
And I'm like, whoa!
How do I like to eat it?
I just mash it all together. It's nice.
I'll actually starch and then meat protein and all that jazz.
Iron.
I'm enjoying the fuck out of this food.
I literally never ate anything.
It's been five hours since I woke up.
And I don't, like, eat before bed or anything like that.
I know some people have a midnight snack,
which is quite, quite Kauai-ne.
Okay, I might need to drink my tea.
I'm using this teacup that's fricking rubbish for retaining heat,
so it gets cold so quick.
Well, it's already cold, so there you go.
While we're at it at Star Wars, what about candy corn?
I've never tried it.
Is it actually a piece of corn that's got sugar on it?
Or is it, like, a replica of food that's to look like corn?
And, like, that's where its name is?
Or is it just, like, all sugar?
Is it, like, a sugar cube?
Candy corn is shite?
Take a early bit. No.
It's all just sugar.
That's a good crime.
Does anyone like candy corn?
It tastes like plastic.
Oh, is it, like, ultra-processed?
Like, the Twizzlers?
I think it was a Twizzler I tried.
Like, that red stick.
There is nothing to...
It's a replica. It's pure sugar and corn syrup in the shape of corn.
When we took the corn,
took the sugary, fructose-high percentage,
shoved it back in the sun and it looked like corn.
Candy corn's gross.
Just even like, I love candy corn.
You're against the grain.
Get back from work.
Make sure to hydrate and take your 30-minute push-work-shit-refling.
Yeah, you need to get out of your system.
Unless you bombed the toilets at your workplace and that's different.
Then that just proves what a chad you are,
your biological warfare at the workplace.
What about peeps?
I got to try the blue peeps.
I was scared to swallow it.
No, obviously I'm overreacting,
but it actually was like, made me scared to swallow it.
Isn't shitting on company-time mail?
Oh, it should be.
Why do you think the girls take idle meetings midstream, huh?
Boss makes a dollar, I'll make a dime.
That's why shitting on company-time.
Why were you scared to swallow the peep?
I don't know.
It was just like, my brain was like, this is not edible.
The texture, the flavor.
My brain manually overreads my ability to swallow them.
It was like, this is not good to go.
So, I trusted my brain and spat it out on that stream.
And I've still got a bone to pick with a waterpatch,
was it waterpatch melon candy or something?
Oh wait, what am I trying to say?
Watermelon candypatch kids, shit.
Something like that.
Silverpatch kids?
Was it silverpatch watermelon?
Aye, I've still got a bone to pick with that.
Where's the flavor go?
Nothing disappeared, literally.
They literally was gone.
I was like, oh.
Oh, itadakimasu!
Why would you not just eat regular?
I was in this foreign sweet shop and I just picked whatever.
And I'm like, oh, Americans always go on about candy.
Watermelon, I'm like, oh fuck it, I'll get that flavor.
Good call.
A lot of candy in the US is an edible proof.
Hershey's chocolate is made with something that makes the chocolate taste like vomit.
Why?
But why?
I'm not even questioning, I actually think that's true.
Is it to cheapen the fucking value?
The flavor is the silver part.
That's the powder coating that dissolves very quickly.
Yeah, literally it's gone.
When I was kid, I had a gummy shark.
I kept away because I thought it was a friend but I was forced to throw it away.
Like an actual shark?
You found one?
Or am I being dumb?
It has a chemical that is produced in vomit but not everyone can taste it.
Hershey's taste doesn't like vomit.
Keep that shelf life higher.
They got to limit the supply to make it look like it's a salt after thing.
When reality is, they could just ship more of it.
I never really understood the chocolate alias though.
In Europe, it's a higher sugar and milk content, I think.
And then, it's better, American, I don't know.
Fucking hell, Amy, come on.
Poor Amy, actually, you know what it is?
She's a perfectionist and she doesn't want the camera bugging out, but it is.
And it's upset her, which is a shame.
I hope she's okay.
She is a bit of a perfectionist.
I hope it doesn't stress her out too much, honestly.
I was in another country last month and the Dr Pepper there wasn't made with corn syrup
and were significantly better.
I can find it myself to forgive you for giving it a seat here.
You are forgiven, dear Reefling, you understand now.
So there's this drink called Orange Gina in the UK and Europe and it's absolutely gorgeous.
But the best country I've ever tasted it in is in France, Orange Gina, France.
It's just so good.
So, so good.
Mm-hmm.
It's good. Almost finished eating.
Almost.
Mexican Coca-Cola is really sweet and good.
I've always wanted to try it.
They say the Mexican Cola is the best.
Mm-hmm.
Wait.
Is what?
The Orange Gina is marketed to French furries?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, two voodoo leon.
Bark, bark.
And, you know, I've forgotten all my French.
I cannot string a sentence together for the life of me.
Like, how do you advertise to French furries?
Bark, or what?
Mm-hmm.
En chien.
Et tu en chien?
Drink Orange Gina then.
Are you a dog?
Chien?
Mm-hmm.
The Mexican Coca-Cola is good.
I can't remember if I've ever gotten to try Orange Gina.
I don't know if it's elsewhere but it is in Europe.
I've had it in France, I've had it in the UK.
And I remember asking my dad, I was like,
why does the British version not taste as good as the French version?
And he was like, he had to explain to me that different products
are in different countries under the same brand,
but other countries will have better quality and all that.
And the UK's food quality is going down every year type thing
compared to the rest of Europe basically.
So that was, you know, fun to learn.
Ooh, we're almost 19,000.
We're getting close.
We're getting so close.
Oh wait.
I have curiosity since Amy's still getting the rats ready.
And...
French?
No!
Oh, is she back?
Is she back?
French? Orange Gina?
Oh shit, she's back. Okay, bad timing.
Put the board on! Look at the board!
Forget the French furries!
Abort! Abort!
Okay.
Well that's, okay, I see her.
Is she okay?
She's back.
What time are we on the board?
In the top left corner
has the ongoing time stamp
of like what, where I am at.
And you can go ahead a few seconds
to match up to me and pause and play
like when I'm on that second.
I'm now going to eat a blueberry muffin
as my sweet treat after eating savoury food.
Love being British.
Looking nothing better than having a sweet treat
after a savoury meal.
Oh, there's her!
That's so cute!
Oh, bless her.
Is that your favorite Sonic character?
Probably.
Amy or maybe Mr. Big?
I like Amy, Cream and Mr. Big together.
They're cute as fuck.
Oh, we, Amy, that actually sends Ray on par.
She's secretly a klutz.
Oh, that's how our rats were on the floor.
I was going to say, because wouldn't it be dangerous
for rats to be on a table? They might jump off.
It's fine, Amy, it's fine, we love you.
Cream just calls everyone Mr. and Mrs.
Oh.
Where's your pride at being a Scott?
Right, okay, sometimes, sometimes
British ain't being so bad, okay.
But I'm a Scott though, you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm a Scott though, but you know, sometimes.
I mean, I spawned him with a British tea,
so fuck, that's what I've got to be thankful for.
What?
I have a plate Sonic Rush.
The Nintendo DS game?
I played the Nintendo DS game.
Oh my god, Amy does sound like that
1A smart creator, lividly, that does
yandere roleplays. That's crazy.
That's wild.
She sounds like a lighter pitched, lividly.
Bizarre, truly.
Maybe they're like sisters, probably.
How strange, truly.
Isn't British and Scottish the same?
Don't, don't you pipe up.
Only I'm allowed to make them jokes.
You're not allowed to pipe up like that.
Yeah, I must be some sort of poser
trying to like take Amy's clout or something.
That's bizarre.
You know, like when VTubers do that, trying...
I just want you to know that I'm dropping
blueberry muffin crumbs all over myself.
Yep.
You can lick them off if you're hungry
for a little snack.
That's disgusting.
It just comes out.
Can we have lividly, lividly at home?
Should I make that meme and give it to her?
Just be like, hey, do you want me...
There is a meme I was going to tweet at her,
but then I got too shy to do it.
I get shy around Amy, I'm just like,
oh god, I hope she doesn't find me too unprofessional.
But...
It's because Amy does her own thing,
like super does her own thing.
She never asks for help,
she never asks for
literally anything.
The one thing she's asked me for
was to do the collab script
on Icey's channel next.
That's the only thing she's asked me for,
so I get nervous. I'm like,
am I doing enough for you, my daughter?
Do you need more?
Yes!
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Let's see your babies.
Halfway through 95, not bad, not bad.
She's a strong independent little sister,
so I don't need no nanny.
Actually, she requires no hand-holding,
she gets to fucking work.
Sorry, I need to fart, hold on.
And we didn't hear it,
but that was a bum note.
Oh, hell no!
Oh no, I missed it!
I was too busy farting, unironically,
to see her rat.
She's almost at 28,
oh my god, 20% of the way
to a play button is insane, that's fantastic.
I hope she gets that play button, I really do.
I'll put my stonks into her.
Imagine her getting a play button.
I could already see it,
she'd like piss on it in a video or something.
She'd be like,
I started the peeler allegations,
I'ma end them right here, like pee on it in a video.
Aw, they're so shy!
Hold on, I'm gonna drop
the blueberry crumbs on the floor.
That'll prove her, and
I'll probably
get the motivation to clean up in like two months' time.
But right now, no.
I'm doing no cleaning.
Whenever I am creative,
my entire, like, dwelling
turns to shit when I'm really creative
and like in the zone, and then I wake up
on the other end and I'm like, oh, this place is a mess.
Oh, hello, Luna!
Oh, look at that we have
like half kind of light brown on top
and then the white on the body
and then a little mark and that's precious.
Here we go.
Oh, she shoulders her feet!
Aw.
Aw!
That's right, that's right,
guilt tripper into signing the contract for another year.
Yes! Yes!
Make all the girls want to be on for another year!
I'm so nervous about them not wanting to be on
for another year, I have to be honest.
I'm like, next year,
A515 split,
and they get an alternative costume
and I'm so nervous they don't want to sign on.
Like, I'm actually fucking bricking it
when it comes to me next year.
Like, do you guys want to sign on again? Smile.
Did we do enough for you? Smile.
Oh, my God!
Look at the wee thing!
Oh, she got red eyes?
Or...
I'm glad it was the camera.
How long is her initial contract?
Runs out on June 1st.
Like, well, technically May 31st,
but...
I wouldn't make them stream
on June 1st, that doesn't make sense.
Like...
But it does expire June 1st.
Obviously,
they can sign the contract in advance
for a second year, I'll ask them in May.
I'm fucking bricking it.
I'm not scared of many things,
but the contract renewal,
that's what I'm fucking terrified of.
That's what truly shits me up at night,
is the contract renewal.
Where I have to be like,
did you enjoy your time here?
Do you want to come on another year
under this IP?
And all that.
Just let them end on February
29th.
How does that mean?
What happens on the 29th?
I have poppin' kit,
but mine's different from Amy's.
Mine was like...
It's a leap year?
There you go. Sorry!
Sorry!
Maybe?
Mods based on...
No, they need to be...
Yep.
Mods can't have rates to do that kind of stuff
where they cause chaos on stream.
One fear, truly.
29th is a leap year.
She didn't know the mods meant no.
If they're a different kind of moderator,
then we can, but...
I hope they have fun and decide to stay a little while.
I bloody hope so, too.
I really hope they achieve new heights
under me type thing.
It's not really under me,
let's be honest.
Just follow it under the table
to get the emotion and stuff.
We actually, that clipping program,
I'm a bit miffed at myself.
I really don't like it,
but it's the only way I can see it.
For established,
we need established clipping channels
to clip the girls.
I've had to lure...
So the base fee is you get paid
10 quids for clipping the girl.
And then you get paid
$2...
$10 per clip,
even if it's a minute long type thing.
As long as you're not taking the piss,
there's going to be a disclaimer
and be like, if you get accepted
and then you're shipping out low quality stuff
just to claim that 10 quid
over and over again, we have the right to be
like, right, we're not going to do business with you anymore.
And it's $2 per every
1000 views.
I need to write it out in all the terms in that,
but it launches on August 1st,
and I hope it goes well.
There'll be a section on the website as well,
that mentions it.
I think I'm going to take down the
who's on the team,
because it's so outdated.
There's so many more people now.
It's just ridiculous.
And there's like, the script writers
that are listed on the website
are no longer on the team,
because we now have a script master,
like that's outdated.
I think I'm just going to take it down.
Wait, how did he predict 3 hours?
How did he predict 3 hours?
Can't celebrate drinking wine
since it's all getting sold to the Grand Exchange,
honestly.
Stony, don't play Splatoon.
No, I've never played it before.
Apparently it's not a very good stream game.
And we're in the 19,000s
if I didn't celebrate that yet.
Wow.
Another proof every stream is pre-recorded.
This is all a lie.
Literally, I was like, how did they record that?
How did they predict that it was 3 hours long?
Would you end it?
Yeah, there we go.
If they're not under you, we can't.
I'd rather talk to you.
Would you make a discord if you had the chance?
Um...
History...
There is a notification discord.
Yes, but...
I predicted 3 hours because I'm the stream script writer
for the long run.
Okay, that's why we're removing who's on the team
is to hide the fact that we have
a stream script writer.
Thank you, tiny spiny.
I can't believe it.
Um...
Two hours streams it with some success,
but it can be a hit or miss, depending on what occurs.
Stony, take exposure like that for me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
There's a notification only discord
for Veeler.
If you want to not miss
anything from your particular
girl that you like,
or if you like us all.
It'll notify you short,
it'll notify you streams, it'll notify you videos.
And it's good for the algorithm
for the girls to have
a link that shares
the embed and all that.
Like, it's good for their promotion.
So, if you feel so inclined
on the Veeler Twitter's
pinned post,
you can...
Um...
You can just join
and it literally, you just click who you want
and then that's it all done.
Oh, there you go. There's an invite.
And no, find me about your clip today.
Oh, we'll clip him out today.
God, Emmy's coughing up a storm.
I think I need to tell her maybe this...
...
... her daughter.
Okay.
Can I say something behind the scenes
that you guys already know
that you're not really supposed to say?
I told her she can knock off the voice
if it's affecting her too much.
And she'll take it
and, you know, she's got full permission to
not use that.
I don't want to damage her beyond repair.
That's not my intention.
And...
I think that cough started
when she started her voice,
unfortunately, which makes me worried,
but, um, yeah...
Muppered.
Muppered, baby.
Gosh, she has such tiny hands.
I feel like she must be tiny in real life.
Like, you know how my hands are
like, kinda like long...
elongated kinda hands?
Because Emmy's hands are so tiny,
I think I'm, like, way taller than her.
I must be. There's no way in hell I'm not.
If we're comparing our hands...
Your hands are cute.
I've got elongated hands compared to Emmy.
Definitely elongated.
Okay.
Oh, my God! I know what she's talking about!
I know what she's talking about.
I know exactly what she's talking about!
No, there's no advice. It's just an army, darlin'.
It either works for you or it does me.
Yes, Johnny, your hands are cute.
Johnny, your hands are beautiful.
And I'd like to take one of that.
Your arse!
I'll finish that sentence for you.
Johnny's wet, sweaty hands.
My persipitation hands.
I'm gonna get highlight made of the stream.
I'm needing highlight, folk.
We've got short people now.
Wait, that sounds bizarre.
We've got people that make shorts in now,
but I'm needing highlight glitter.
Highlight.
They'll go through a two-hour vod and then make the highlight.
Mercy got one, but that editor,
Chaco editor,
he's absolutely fucking phenomenal,
but he took so long to do the Mercy.
I'm like, nah, we need you for shorts for the girls.
So he's not getting another highlight stream again.
Emmy's got two really good shorts coming out
once they're produced.
I'm really happy with them.
You have short people, stop.
They're in my basement.
Strongly slick digits, honestly.
Optimal hands for ASMR.
I mean, I can always fart with my hands.
Because they're always sweaty.
They just never stop.
My feet are worse.
Wait, who are you, Willy Wonka?
I'm gonna screw up Wonka and the Willy, because it's certainly me.
Covered in siren slain.
Honestly, real.
She brapped on stream.
Emmy?
Oh no, you mean me.
So fucking did my hand.
Thank you for real Joker, for real, for real,
for becoming a member.
Enjoy all the parts.
We do membership streams all the time.
Me.
What are we doing?
Hold on.
Hello?
Am I bad?
What the ffff?
I went to go show my schedule
and then OBS just shut down.
Bruh.
Did you not see me go offline?
Offline?
Did you not see that?
You didn't go offline for us, just start buffering.
Oh, my OBS closed down.
They gave up.
I was gone, I was literally offline.
I was like, hello?
Did I just take my meds?
Where's my refling?
Hash, are you telling me?
Your bodily function.
Oh, are we ran?
Oh, he's a little curious.
Oh, you need to be careful.
Look at the wee tail.
Oh, careful.
No running with scissors.
I almost threw up.
No, no, no, keep it in, keep it in, keep it in.
Keep it inside.
They don't know you can't go on without reflings
if they know they are evil.
Meds taken, reflings gone.
You buffered and I started crying.
Well, literally, I went to go show my schedule
because I was thanking
for Real Joker for becoming a member.
I was like, oh, let's talk about my membership streams this week.
And then the thing just
fucking blew off on me.
I'm like, okay, I'm not doing that again, I guess.
I guess it'll be a surprise when I put up my roster.
Also, I love how I go on Amy's channel
to watch the VOD in the first video.
I see is, would you date a cook?
Oh, that takes so long to get up.
It's so long.
Whoa, she's so close to 20K.
I'm so happy.
Would you date Esteban?
Who said that?
Point and laugh at cook was so fun.
It's also fun she crashed when Esteban appears.
No, she doesn't think there's...
I mean, she owns them,
so I'll take her word over it
than anyone else's.
Esteban's a lady rat?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, she's a lady rat.
Oh, Esteban's a lady rat?
Mm-hmm.
The channel growth of all the ladies in present.
Yeah.
I'm so close to revealing the 10K art.
I'm so...
I'm so excited.
10K art.
Soon TM.
You guys are not ready
for what I ordered.
I ordered it. Order.
I ordered it ages ago. I'm so excited to show it.
Soon TM.
It's real. It's coming.
You bomb?
She's dying.
I'm her little sister.
I must protect.
Uh-huh.
They're like hamsters explode when they die.
They never die a natural death.
They just like fucking...
do something in batshit and scene.
What were your tongue looks like?
Got something physics.
What are you going to do for 20K an aspect?
I've already agreed on it.
I've got...
Oh, sorry. On YouTube.
I'm going to do a work out
ASMR stream on Ring Fit
for one hour and then a shower.
ASMR.
Like, I'm bringing the microphone and then the shower with me.
Hello?
Uh-huh.
And then on the elsewhere, we're going to pick.
Hmm, sure.
I've got my poodles.
Hmm.
Spank my peach.
He's spanking my peach with my own emote.
What's going on here?
I'll definitely make sure I've eaten
properly before that stream so I don't have
a repeat of last time on Ring Fit where I was
like perishing.
And I'll definitely test the freaking audio
so I'm not blown out this time.
I'm so annoyed that stream got blown out.
Ha!
He's like,
give it back!
Aww,
that's her rat origin story.
That's so sweet.
Yeah!
They all pop their clogs
like randomly.
Lucky got to touch the peach.
Don't worry, we have fun anyway.
Oh!
Well, we're getting educated
in this stream.
I don't know how hamsters work up in the head.
Ah.
Oh.
Yeah.
Uh,
is it stream elements that prompts that?
I don't know.
Yab!
I don't really think
I'm so happy.
Oh, we're at 9 million eggs
p though.
You know, I could see myself when I retire
just saying fuck it in like 100%
in our RuneScape account just for the hell of it.
I don't know how to do it for other stuff.
My skills.
So you can just slay her for all of this.
Um.
Did they change RuneCraft?
I think someone said they changed RuneCraft
so it's not as bad. Maybe Gargon would be like
the worst thing one.
Maybe like Fletching in one go.
Oh, my poor little sister.
I didn't realize how bad it was hurting her throat.
Oh, little rat on screen.
I like how they just walk in
and out of frame and out of their leisure.
I think there's a minigame
for it now.
I'm gonna hook it.
Max Cape's little fish.
Oh!
That's so cute.
In Japanese?
Are you okay?
How are you?
Really?
Oh, I see.
I'm Japanese.
Farming will take a while.
Mommy's gonna have a word with me.
No, I messaged her like a couple of days ago
and I was just like, oh, I'm a little worried about your cough.
Cause I caught the back end
of one of her streams.
But this is me actually sitting down
watching one of her vods and I'm like,
oh, I'm like concerned.
I'm like, bruv.
Cause it was me
who kind of called the shots on the voice
and I'm like, I don't want to give you permanent damage.
Like, I don't give a fuck about me.
Like permanent damage on the map.
I'm not gonna subject someone else to permanent damage.
But I've given her full permission
to do what she wants.
If she wants to, you know,
pause Trump, then she most certainly can.
Cause I didn't realise, cause she was like, oh,
I need to clear my throat of phlegm now
all the time and I'm like, oh.
What's your favourite anime?
Kagaguri!
I love it because the protagonist is literally
me.
We're chopped off all my hair.
But my hair's coming back.
She seems to want to continue voicing.
Yeah, no, it's completely up to her.
But I just feel really bad though.
I'm like, oh.
I feel bad.
I feel like a bad mother.
Bad mother!
Never played RuneScape.
So what was RuneCrafting before?
So,
you take
your inventory of blank runes
and then you take it to a stone
and then the stone would convert it
into whatever rune that stone is.
But you only can have a max capacity
of 26 items, I think.
So you could hardly make any progress
like every run, if I'm not mistaken.
I never did it, but I was aware of it.
But apparently there's a minigame now
to kind of help you out a bit.
Sorry.
I find guinea pigs scary.
They look like they have the ability to think.
As soon as something has the ability to think,
I get nervous. I hate when Gimli looks at me
and I can tell she wants something
and I'm like, bruv, what do you want?
I have no idea.
What's your gamba skill at?
I don't know.
Ballot to win.
I wish.
I wanted to visit Supermarket Simulator.
I also really thoroughly enjoyed that game
but I don't know if I can make it in an opinion.
But I really enjoyed it.
If it was like the nice, kind of cozy,
satisfying game.
Having your refunds run essence for you
would probably be pretty good at.
Speed per hour stop.
Do you imagine?
Time to boost mummy on Rinsky.
Time to run dragon bones for me.
To the dragon altar.
Not the altar.
Not the dragon altar, the altar.
I feel that way about birds are too smart.
There's not a single thought in a guinea pig's head.
There are refunds in a nature altar
doing god knows what, literally.
Of course there's some of the most intelligent animals I've ever seen.
Mummy asked grieflings to...
Oh, she's jerking off.
I don't know, keep going, keep going, keep going.
I'm almost there.
The sounding blows really.
I love that one out of context.
Let's get some money and get poker.
Shawnee.
Have you run altars on old school runes?
Grieflings, yes, mummy.
You've been making account just to help mummy
on weekend runes go through.
Oh, you would!
You got to protect me from all the P.K.ers.
Leave us alone!
We're just travellers.
We just need to get to the altar, that's all.
Shawnee, here's noises.
Are they jorking it?
No sending.
Oh, come on, a little bit.
Okay, I won't do it.
No, punk!
You would have loved my puppy.
He was a real doofus, not but loved food walks
and sleeping his head.
Honestly, dogs are so cute.
Maybe looking at you are blind guys.
I just wish cats could communicate.
You have to guess what they want.
That's the only thing that I feel upset.
So, Gimli and Vigo were actually upset
my dad left because they got used to him being here.
And they were meowing.
And I knew they wanted dad,
but I was like...
I don't know how to explain to you,
but...
So, we're on this continent,
and he's in a different continent.
It's really far away, okay?
Really far away.
What? Is she...
Is she role-playing my hero academia or whatever?
What are you doing, young lady?
Little sister bullies you at school,
in front of all your friends
and humiliates you.
And then apologizes in private,
and then you kiss and make up.
Well, I'll keep that in mind for the
vealier package when it's her birthday.
Is that real?
I don't know what...
Right, if you guys can keep it a secret,
I know what artwork I'm going to order for her birthday.
But...
But can you keep it a secret?
I'll get her
in the cocktail
and Baku
and Deku
will be in a made-out
kissing like in that fucking
short that came out.
How do you feel about my hero academia?
I've watched
season
one
and two.
Froppy, obviously best girl
for no particular reason.
Loved me Froppy, simple as.
But
I never watched that other season.
Should love it, literally.
That artist that gets that request
is going to be like, what the...
I don't know.
The long tongue?
No, Froppy looks like me.
Well, a little bit.
I'm not exactly a fucking anime girl in real life,
let's be honest with you.
I'm no looker in real life, but
any design that looks remotely like me,
I'm like, oh my god, best girl.
Best girl, oh my god, black hair?
Best girl.
Long black hair?
Oh my god, me.
What's her name?
Um,
mommy loves the green ladies.
Yeah, green, green as well.
Green gang.
Oh, we got an instruction.
I should honestly probably pay a lot more
attention to this stream, because I'm going to be doing this
shortly. I don't know when, but...
I'm waiting for
my manicure and pedicure
to grow off of my fingernails and my toenails.
Cause, I refuse to go back
to pay money to get this taken off
and it's still growing out.
We'll read the Japanese bits for you.
Are you a weed, be honest?
Thank you.
Thank you for your, um,
your due diligence
to help me do what I need.
Handcam with your pet rat that you currently don't have.
I mean, I could do it on the floor
and Gimli and Vigo can just walk in the room
if they want, and I'll just call the stream
eh,
I mean
I just straight up copy Imi's
fucking stream.
Eh...
How is your nails
perished in the great fires
in the great war of the Vietnamese
uh, nail
salon,
um,
knuckles the enchilado.
Long black hair, what's your thoughts
about braiding it in a one big braid?
Yeah, I know.
Uh, when
when your hair is really long
it's a lot easier to manage just keeping it
in a braid.
But, you're not to have any scalp tension
when you do the braid or that's really
bad for your, your, your scalp
hell.
Which is the only thing I didn't like about having long hair
but now that I have short hair I'm like
ugh, I'm regretting it.
I straight up regret it, bro.
But yeah, stream idea
yonked by Imi.
Yonking Imi's stream idea live.
Reve...
Knuckles the enchilado? What?
Reverse even spelled it right but it's trying to gift it.
Eh...
How's your elf a bull heal?
Yes, my toe is fully healed though.
Who? Get back here, was it Luna?
There's always Esteban
that was causing troubles on this one.
Pigtail braid.
Oh yeah, I love
pigtail braid.
Absolutely.
100%.
Any symmetrical
hair?
I love symmetrical
hair.
For me, symmetrical hair
is just peak design. Some sort of bunches
or anything of that nature
or ugh.
Fucking hell, where's she gone?
She's offline.
The ranks, the ranks.
The rats yonked the wires.
If you want to know what the rats
yonked the wires in one word would be
it would be the ranks.
Just so you know.
Eh...
Did it like reach over?
It has to be Esteban exactly.
Echidna is how it's supposed
is pronounced but spelled echid
oh.
Echidna.
Echidna?
Less than 9k winds to go.
How dare you outdo me.
Not you getting 99 before me.
This is embarrassing, come on.
I'm symmetrical.
That is so smart.
That is so fucking smart.
Sorry, that was so good.
So hair with hands
like bunches, pony tails
anything symmetrical
I'm here for, I love symmetry.
Like I love my hair so much
on my Vtuber model.
I just adore it.
Sorry, but literally double bunches
with all of this.
I just, oh my god you can't get better.
I love it, I love it, I love it.
I love for the symmetry.
Oh, is she like straight up eating on stream?
Harvarts.
Womash.
Avelts.
Hello.
Hi, little cutie.
Oh, it's already away with the cheese.
Come back for more cheese.
Emmy will give you more cheese if you come back on screen.
I have no idea what she...
She cut out the packaging.
It seems like the packaging has instructions on it.
And...
Ooh, I need fart again.
Oh, it was silent.
Silent.
Fun fact, a kitten's nose
or another mammal at least.
Wait, there's more than one of that platypus
with only the exception.
What coincidence.
I love Stony 2, wanna hang out?
What are the odds?
Harvart, like the ice cream.
There's my watamel in here.
Watamel.
Such a good name.
No more Touma, baby.
Only Watamel.
Oh, the wee rat.
Oh my God, it's so cute.
Oh my God.
Are you curious?
That's kind of true, Andrea.
Oh.
Oops.
Did she still try to take it?
Yoinked it.
That was such a good short that came out from these.
Oh!
No, look at it pulling.
No way.
Look how fast it was.
Oh my God.
The sweet back legs were going.
It's coming back for more.
Come on, give me something.
Don't take all of it away.
Amy's trying to stream.
Wait, you have to microwave it?
No.
Oh my God.
Rats are such wee guys, honestly.
I love how there was a piece of the box.
Like the one in her hand.
Honestly.
Rats are so cute.
Amy getting bullied by our rats live on stream.
I think that's what the highlight clip will be called.
Getting bullied by my rats on stream.
And then like the thumbnail will be her looking angry.
And then all our rats are like got little angel wings on.
And uh,
like a halo to be like shown.
Oh no, we behave.
We're good.
But they're naughty.
Oh my God.
That literally she's having to bribe them
not to take her stuff.
They literally like you must pay
the toll and then they walk away again.
That's so precious.
Um,
there is a YouTube short,
but there isn't a highlight reel.
Oh, she's literally getting bribe by fucking rats.
Oh my God.
Oh, look at the way it skips backwards.
That's so cute.
Let's do a little butt shuffle away with it.
She literally extort.
She is being extorted live
by my rats highlight stream.
Oh, it's back for more.
No, no more.
Emmy's not got any more for you.
You've had like a full packet of cheese now.
A full cheese slice.
Our rats bottomless pits.
Do they not get full?
Hi Mercy, in the past.
What a glutton, honestly.
Oh,
naughty.
Naughty.
No, look how cute it is.
It's so elongated.
Such a long thing.
Give that spin back.
Give it back.
Oh my God.
This is so cute.
I'll smile an ear to ear.
Oh, please.
We need another rat stream stream.
I don't know what it will be.
But it's so cute.
I can't handle it.
Okay, BRB.
Bruh.
It's so cute.
I've never known someone with rats before.
Not like a primary school friend.
What are you doing?
It's unattended.
Pin pals, you have to look after the rat.
Pin pals, you need to tell them off.
Or her off even.
Oh, what is it going to do on its own?
What's she doing?
Oh my God, I'm adoring this.
I literally feel like I'm babysitting,
but I can't do anything.
Don't chew the wires on the headset.
Emmy told me that they chew her
wires so much.
I assume animals don't ever stop eating.
It's just an instinct.
Possibly grazing animals type thing.
Cuteness overload.
Esteban's sneaking in while she's doing it.
Literally. Is that Esteban?
That's that one.
I'm rubbish with the names.
I know Lunam is that kind of pale looking one.
Hi Esteban.
You got a little...
Oh, look at it going on its meatback legs.
Oh my God, it's supposed to be cute.
They are gnawing.
I'm gnawing a gnaw.
Esteban stole her headphones,
literally walking away with them.
Why didn't play that game?
That's funny.
Donkey Kong reference
to
Waitin' Brune.
Esteban, the noisiest one.
You can have a sniff of the powder,
but you're not allowed to...
Yeah, that's right.
Trying to fight her, but she got that grip.
Get wrecked. Get wrecked, Esteban.
Time for a pet. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get a pet. Get a pet. Get a pet. Get a pet.
Honestly, that must be...
Fucking circle the rune!
Chaos, Esteban.
Chaos, how dare you?
Tune through it.
I got my first card today, by the way.
Congrats!
Is it Binance?
Or did you pay cash?
And is it Second Hand?
Ooh, we're on 18,000.
Can we do it?
What are we at?
Oh, my...
Okay, so it says I've been streaming for 30 minutes
because my OBS crashed,
so I don't actually know.
Donkey Kong versus King Kong, who I am...
Isn't King Kong, like, massive
and Donkey Kong's, like, two feet off the ground?
Almost six hours, almost five.
Okay.
Sugar. Nah, we can't do it then.
I was 30k at the start,
but it's taken me six hours
to get to thingy.
Then I need, like, another
what, couple of hours stream.
You have been streaming for...
I'm going to be shy.
Okay, there's going to be one more runescape stream,
but I'll do it, as I said.
I'm going to do a finishing
up stream where I'll play
the three games. I'll play a finished Sonic Heroes.
I'll finish
a runescape
and then I'll finish a little to the left DLC
because I missed that, apparently.
And I really enjoyed that game, seriously.
Other than that one refrigerator one.
What did I miss? No!
I should take it.
What did she take?
It's hers now.
No!
Oh, Blizzard.
Her face going straight.
No!
The powder plunge everywhere.
Okay, okay, okay.
How can she make the crumbs
in the towel?
No! Not her trying to pick up the crumbs!
No!
Amy, darling!
She's trying to pick up the crumbs!
That's hilarious!
Oh, Amy!
Oh, Amy, no!
A ledge!
Oh, pervy, Amy!
That's hilarious, sorry.
That's funny as anything.
Pablo Escobar, that shit?
That's my only suggestion
if you want to clean it quick.
What?
Her Amy.
Trying to save them salvageable.
Is she licking the crumbs?
Esteban!
Yes, Esteban.
No way!
No way she prepared a lane
for her rack!
Come on, Amy!
Amy!
This is fucking amazing!
Oh, a ledge.
Literally.
Stony encourage in the Colombians?
No.
It's really weird the effect, the drug.
It gives you an ego, it gives you confidence
out of nowhere, which is bizarre.
I'd really love to do a drugs talk stream.
I love it.
I love me drugs.
Education, I don't actually do anything.
My drug is you, refling.
Smooth, huh?
Just like my...
My class.
My little sister is the one that cooks.
You know, Amy would make a stupid money in a trap.
Whoa!
Hold on a minute, is that what I think that is?
I think that's an American terminology,
but I think I know what it means.
You should get up
to right before 999 off stream
so you can do a big stream celebration 999 party.
I don't know how...
I know this sounds bizarre,
but like...
isn't the celebration just
acts in the chat?
I was gonna do
a repair stream.
Like, I finish off games, I've not finished.
My drug is Stony Typnosis.
Stony Grains, reflans up and snort something.
I would do no such thing
to my darlings.
If anything, I'd extract the ink
and then powderize it
and then
snort it.
That's what I would do.
If you're asking my honest opinion, that's what I would do.
Oh, well, you can...
Oh, and...
Oh, she's making it worse.
Oh, my little sister,
she's making it worse.
Oh, no.
Oh, she's smi...
Oh, you're...
No, you're so...
darlin'.
You're rubbin' it in, you know?
A real...
I actually reeled off that one.
Like, preach that one again and made for me.
Maybe...
a-stained.
Oh!
I think I've ever...
That's...
God, we're already almost at 17,000.
It looks like a...
It literally looks like a skid mark.
You're...
You're Ray. Oh, my God, she's trying to hate it with a cotton board.
That's adorable.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
Yes.
True P'tan.
Design-wise, AC actually has
slight bit of meat.
Design-wise, Amy is True P'tan.
Hi, it's Saban.
I've a love of a daughter, girl, failure.
We saw the pics of the DMA, we know the truth.
Bruh, that clip blew up of her.
I'm so glad.
It threw her head again further, and I'm like, thank...
She's almost at 20k subs, which is amazing.
And Mercy's almost at 10k as well.
And I'm like...
She has to come back
and identify what's missing
before she continues the stream.
That's perfect.
Ooh, 227.
227 and we're at 96.
This is doing numbers.
Literally, this is doing numbers
at a clip, because it was!
It's like, last time I checked it,
it was like 100,000 people
had seen my little sister's
fucking chest.
Going on here.
Dear Algorithm,
please continue to bless the girls.
Seriously, bless them.
You're about to hit 18,000 too.
Just in time to
corrupt 18,000 people
and try and convince them
to click on pregnant with you, ASMR.
Oh, it's all coming together.
Oh, yeah.
She posted a sweater pic
without a...
I know, I saw it.
I look after my little sister.
She just doesn't know
how much I look into her.
I don't think any of them realize
how much I keep up with them
as best I can.
Because they probably are like,
aw, strong streams all day.
There's no way she can stream and then do all the behind the scenes work
and then do all the work she does for the reflins
and then do all the secret stuff that isn't even out yet
and keep up with us.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I haven't slept eight ever since
pre-debut.
I have.
I have slept eight hours at one point,
but I haven't slept a full eight hours
in a very long time.
I'm not sure, though.
The diddly boy.
Well, think, by the way, so
say a clip about how short can be
used to expose for Algo to Workbear.
Something, something, leave the checkbox for information
so that he's like, jumped off of me,
and tells Algo, oh, I didn't know.
I'm seeing how the shorts do
growth-wise on the channels.
Obviously, we've only just got the short people in place.
Like, Sheevee, for example,
here, I'm about to spank you on Sheevee's behalf.
I'm needing you to help Sheevee with clips
for like funny moments, because she has
two Elden Ring clips out with
the pre-recorded stuff and I'm like,
I'm gonna need you guys to help Sheevee
so she can give me these shorts.
Yeah.
But, Reeflings, you guys are pulling
in all the work where the clips are.
Let's just say Arisa,
my clip editor, she is
eating good, okay?
She's eating good. You guys are doing
fantastic work for Arisa,
and she's so, she's so fun to work
with, like, she just comes out,
she like, honestly is just fantastic.
Trying to get her to sleep for a full week challenge
impossible, literally.
Oh, wait, that's me spanking the hair.
I'm real true. 4K.
Hold on.
Reeflings, we need to help Mummy pass.
You know what to do.
Short people. It sounds weird,
but it's called YouTube Shorts because
it's short form content.
Reeflings called her Mummy
at E.P.
Bro, literally I've never been so
had so many
loaf of bread issues in my life,
but I've just completely
forgotten, like, how to
hydrate, and speaking of hydration,
let's all hydrate with some water, okay?
Can't do VOD
watch-alongs more often, just to keep up
with my daughters.
Like, I knew Sheepsters
was collabing with
this French rabbit.
Me too, but I'm like, oh fuck yeah,
Viva la France, mate.
And it was like a hoot in a holler.
I got to lurk that for a little bit.
Yeah,
some
Reeflings should just start dogpiling over Mummy.
Does lemon and leek
count as hydration? It does.
Tea does have hydrating properties,
but it's also a diuretic because of the caffeine
or something like that, which means it wants you to pee.
It feels like you need to pee.
Oh my god, he's only got one health!
Beat him up! Beat him up!
Oh, he's, he's putting...
Who's he getting beaten up by?
Who slayed this poor beast?
It has gone. The beast has been slain.
Damn!
That collab is so funny.
This has come to every family with more of this stuff.
It's only really possible because of RuneScape.
I don't really play any games
that aren't like super mega
and non-engaging.
Hi, Esteban!
Oh my god, look at the
fucking reach!
The rats are so long!
Honestly, they're like long, long critters.
A little broasted, I think I'm drinking too much of it
because
the mouth got that sort of dry after doing it.
Sadly, the vodka doesn't exist for that.
Oh, did it have to go?
I'm actually spanking the girls
in the meeting. I'm going to be like,
you need to stop doing stuff that
um...
Oh my god, it's a chef's hat,
but I have a golden chef's hat
because I have so energy for it.
And look, I've got a reflin on my shoulder.
Look at that.
Look at that lore.
It's a little more accurate, honestly.
I hope the meeting goes, ah, it's fine.
The meetings are really easy.
I'm basically just going to be like,
can we ease up on the DMCA
and the copyright streams
or the streams that need to be taken down all the time
because we're entering, like,
our third month of streaming together.
Like, we're about to complete the second month,
we're about to enter the third month
and everyone's full-time content creators,
but some channels do not look like
they're full-time content creators
because they're having to, like, pull down vods all the time
and I'm like, if we could ease up on that,
that'd be grand type thing.
Is there a cutlery or a squid pet?
There's, like, some sort of water one,
but, you know...
We want to have more vods stay up, basically.
Simple serips that could make for a fizzy juice?
Like, a dilute...
orange...
wobbly.
YouTube is restrictive and it's not getting better.
No, it's getting worse, literally.
I'm so shocked at the ear-licking update.
They've no said anything about it publicly,
but it's getting scary, like...
I want to- I'll probably be eating
my words in what, a year's time
when there's a new policy update,
but I want to say they're not going to get any more restrictive
when it comes to ASMR because that-
that was a bit much after that.
It means me!
Me, Emmy, I'm an architect!
Once you have access
to alternative outlet on BlueSight,
they may be able to have a bit of camera on YouTube.
They'll be able to get all their
all their pent-up energy out.
Educate her mumma.
Oh, well!
She guessed it.
She guessed it, no way!
Or did someone tell her? Did I pin pal tell her?
I lack them big!
I lack them chunky!
Of course, Ronny would know what that means.
Thank you, the shit! You're not even the fart!
Ah, so I'm getting Emmy to cover that song.
Happy going hard!
They break in their hearts!
This girl's thick, but I'm thicker!
I don't know.
Child friendly for the beach.
Yeah, the fake Elsa stuff was hilarious.
Cause apparently it was like this really big
YouTuber.
That was already like super successful and popular.
And then what, like they left in
an accidental scene.
And then like, the whole of
YouTube was like, well, we're not doing that again.
And they're like, outbending stuff.
And do they have YouTube as well?
No, the ice face cover!
Thank you, you're not even the fart!
I'll be going hard!
I need to hurry up and record
some of my parody songs.
I keep stalling on all my projects,
but okay, how about next month?
I upload all of my ASMR collabs.
And I recover my ASMR debt.
Okay, surely, copy them.
And I also record
my song covers
that I want to do.
Cause I wanted to release a song cover every month.
Obviously that's not quite worked out.
But, how about next month
is our month reflings?
Okay, next month,
reflings will rise up.
I will make the content you desire.
The Elsa pregnant by Spider-Man Brain Raw ASMR?
Probably.
Why did you give Emmy the idea to use a Brain Raw ASMR?
It was a
one
before I started getting accused.
I
was specifically requesting
a 60 second ASMR
short from her.
Are you okay?
Emmy?
Are you making her gag on it?
What's going on here?
Emmy?
Is she okay?
Oh,
poor Emmy.
Okay, she didn't like the taste.
Okay, she's okay.
It was actually me on her marshmallow.
It was me.
Real. Real. It was me.
It was actually me on my side.
I'm sorry.
Baseball met.
A song of recorder.
Then you'll be able to
know
things are finally getting like passed out of my hands.
It's just getting them out of my hands.
Like, I say it every week
and I'm like, I'm almost there
and then something gets added to my list
and it just devastates like the behind the scenes.
My goal after this
endurance stream is I'm going to go lie down.
I'll either have a big sleep
or I'll have a nap.
And when I wake up, I'm going to edit the side
collab, okay?
And I'm going to record
the fally sounds for the
Poseidon collab because I need updated sounds.
I am going to record
what is called
wooden soup ASMR.
I've never recorded it before.
I bought like these little
like wooden cubes
and I'm going to put them in a bowl
and then I'm going to circle them around for the ASMR.
It's Esteban back. What is Esteban doing?
You nutty rat you.
Get a little spanking
Esteban.
Okay, we're almost in the 17,000s.
Which is good.
Legal soup.
Literally like wooden soup.
Brain rot with so severe her pee-pee dying.
Literally.
I went to watch your streams
more strongly but I started my new semester
at uni.
I started streaming
at 4M.
Ozy gang, gang, gang, gang, gang.
No, education first.
Education first.
100%.
Education comes first.
See?
So don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
What kind of car do you drive?
I don't know how to drive.
I ride a bike
and I walk.
I am
a bike enthusiast.
I like my bike.
Esteban.
Give me the backup burger.
She tried.
Yes, she tried so hard for the burger.
Esteban.
She drives the strongy on a bike.
Education first with what strongy
means is there
when mommy has the next education stream
real.
I'm not going to be able to watch like at all
in September because I'm going back to uni
and start work again.
Rip.
I like to
definitely see that kind of
life experience.
You don't have to be perfect.
Did she just make the country girls
make do jokes or did I just mishear that?
What if walking for 30 minutes?
Even if walking
for 30 minutes to me sounds insane.
What?
It still boggles the mind that Europeans got all your stuff so close.
Yeah.
I follow a tiktok
that talks about American infrastructure
and how it would be like they take an issue like for example a junction in a
road that's far too busy traffic jam central and how they change it and I
kid you not every solution is put a roundabout at this bit and then the
traffic flows fine but apparently roundabouts aren't really a thing in
America's um yeah she did make that joke oh god how did a pedestrian friendly
infrastructure feels like oh I'm so sorry I'm very lucky they're starting to add
more oh that's fantastic hopefully soon the solution isn't one more lane and
it's like okay roundabout here roundabout here Americans fear the roundabout
they exist somewhere we have roundabouts just not really on main road when a
roundabout got put in my town it saved us literally like at first I suppose
getting used to a new kind of junction in a road that you're not familiar with is
like really intimidating but that's good thank you for coming a member
enjoy the emotes there's tons of them roundabout or roundabout a bound not
roundabout the real fun begins when there's a crash that closes down like
four lanes leaving the city yeah I guess cuz I don't drive I don't understand
how like traffic exists I know that sounds so silly but like there is road
go where's the traffic being formed go forward smile move forward the road
doesn't just disappear and end so how does try like I know it sounds so dumb
and silly but how does traffic work bascoots thank you for the member tier
enjoy the member stream that I don't think I called you a basket the first time
I said that but thank you nonetheless more cars not off-road I fucking hate the
American system roadway system where I live we don't have the best public
transport in the world but it's a thousand times better mmm I love my bike
I'm literally a bike nerd that like keeps me nice and happy and it keeps my
heart healthy more people more cars I thought that close enough did I like
say it terribly wrong
a rat is indestructible in terms of what they can put in their stomach
traffic is formed by human error slowing stopping anything that involves a
slight change of flow known as a traffic snake imagine if a group of kitten
going down a tunnel each kitten basically moves kind of random and they
bump in each other and they get a strike okay the bike would be good for your
heart issues wouldn't it yes and to regularly exercise my heart it's why
I was a bit concerned this morning this is the first time I've had a heart
flutter in a very long time and which makes me a bit nervous because I don't
exercise like after streams at all like I've hardly gone outside like I've gone
outside three times and my dad kind of counted for the other occasions and so
I'm a little bit nervous at that heart flutter I didn't like it but I'll keep
you guys updated like I've got blinks tomorrow which is like I think it's
supposed to be a four-hour stream or something like I'll force myself to go
on a walk and kind of start looking after myself please exercise about me I
will I will I'll play how about we do aim to bring fit streams in a month type
thing I don't want to overdo it but like we'll try and do that like so we get
that thingy either exercise or we'll boycott stream real so what mommy's
saying we're ranked but literally oh do you have a murmur I like what the fuck
are they talking about in the vod I tune out a little bit and I come back to that
question
bruh we can do like a 30 minute straight stream cracks a bit but I want to see
those squats fish women please stretch out a minimum yeah should I do yoga like
self yoga you're an inside cat pretty much I don't do anything I pheromone
max I have an amazing time streaming and then I sleep and record and wake up
and eat and yeah yoga would be a self yoga stream you guys don't be able to
see me though like if I got a 3d model I would definitely do that kind of stuff
more because I love that stuff like I would get those like little steps that
you jump off and we can do like one of those jumping streams motorcycles are
excellent I need to do more ring fit but the light well I was can I didn't know
how much this is allowed or not allowed in the v-tuning world you know how
there's that combat gear that's out and about and it like completely covers up
your face because you put like black marker like over your eye area and
everything I thought about doing a full tactical dress in real life stream like
for exercise but then I was like oh I don't think folk like that in the
v-tuning world you know but like you wouldn't see my face or anything the
most you see is like my hands because everything's in tactical gear what is the
toe stamp I'm with me on this one what is the toe stamp like a fingerprint of
your toe
oil Baron what oil burns get this woman a 3d oh right no no no I was like oh
whoo I mean bow and gearie I don't want to do anything that would affect the
success of the girls and now this is the one thing is by association if one of
us fucks up by association we all fuck up and obviously you as the viewers know
that's not like a real yours it's like that's not a real thing like but public
perception as I said vealers public perception is slowly shifting but it's
still not great like we still have like eight like tons of agencies that ignore
us like we don't really get mentioned anywhere we don't really get invited to
collapse unless we pursue them and so like for the agencies that do fuck with
us we fuck with them very hard type thing and but we are against the odds and
it's a bit like we need to definitely be good you know strongy octopus or squid
cutfish and sweat mentioned tactical you're belching already filtered the
anti-real alright real true real hold on let me just muster up a burp right now I
can't I don't know how the girls work on command don't want to stunt the growth
guilt by association pretty much yes unfortunately this is a very real thing
I've discovered and it sucks it does so I don't want to do anything that and is
too yeah you know what I'm trying to say I just I want I want nothing but the
girls to succeed and the last thing I want is after all this time and love and
effort and energy put into my daughters is for me to be the one to fuck
everything up out of my like raw stupidity you know mostly just in
heel and ear I can't do it I got a gut like how do you like I don't know how
you do I don't know how they're burping on command literally that's crazy like I
can't do it strong about your health do you think you'd enjoy a treadmill and
I've seen those walking Emmy Emmy stop eating the food 3d model fund no thank
you John omni thank you for the 3d model fund and we're actually discussing
that we've got a big old discussion to do about these kind of things you swallow
air than push out how do you swallow air I'm like I don't know how to do it like
Emmy and Azura did it so quickly in that last stream they were like yeah yeah
yeah yeah I guess I've never been able to burp on command make air go down the
wrong hole well see the wrong hole for me is actually the right hole
I tried he imagine you're sucking in a straw then so I can't do it what the
fuck it's not going I tried being a punchline you can't burp either nice
clothes and swallows and your soul for you get off the stage lovingly
God asked about who's the star of the show in this stream I think I've seen
Luna once and have we seen anyone else at all
if anyone was there we don't be like Esteban's obviously flinching because
Emmy abuses her like bullshit Esteban would not be gone that close to me are
you joking
me saying
Mr. Van the man it literally I'm where's Dennis the man so I'm gonna see me
then Luna shine Dennis was afraid of the camera I guess Dennis wasn't used to
the setup Esteban just doesn't like it yeah maybe you're through and Mercer is
's
yeah fortunately that was part of the
Rotism. Rotism. Rotism. I work hard so my babies can have an easy life. They are my responsibility
I will do what I can to make it easy. She says. Have ever come up? No emmy spank. No emmy bad emmy bonk.
Do you think balers made ASMR roleplay channels considered VTuber? No em so if you think in terms of someone who may be an ASMR roleplayer or vice versa a VTuber that is looking to diversify their content both contents have an overlapping niche voice what can you
do with your voice you can do ASMR you can do roleplays you can do alternative audios the overlap between both of those communities is so strong that it is very common and it is very accepted as well because both as I said like obviously this I am not really the regular
VTuber but like my voice is me and well what else can I do with my voice well I can make a roleplay where I am pregnant with you in my tummy because roleplaying is very easily accessible
yeah what your voices you feel my belly no no I'm pregnant I'm pregnant
no emmy emmy stop
I mean I don't want to go too much in a decent way
as I said when if and when the girls leave they're more than welcome to say that they're hey I'm back here
all feels good man oh my god be sure copium my my copium levels are going up strontium copium is going up here in emmy say that because I get still worried the girls are going to be like I don't want to be here for a second year and I'm like okay cry
okay I'm off to kill myself
emmy's getting me pregnant no no no no I'm I'm pregnant I'm pregnant with strontium how does this happen
I had a really funny about that overlap stuff though it went along with bits of VTubers are remarkably heavy due to common tropes that they fill on
it just doesn't bother me none of it bothers me like I feel like just because we're all adults here it's like
I'll be your little seahorse strontium no wait because seahorse males like carry carry
oh emmy mentioned your PL yeah no no I never I said to the girls if you want to mention it you can if you don't need anyone to use anyone to
we'll be here for the second year thank you I thought I was safe from em pregnant no it was a miss it was a miss input it was a miss input come the fuck down
I know I've told everyone why I picked them because I see a bit myself in them is that bad of me to say that I picked
you're right you're right now to go um actually a lot of these smarts can be chipped and get a lot of flak from their ear smart
only viewers real that happened to my friend but you got loads of fucking flak for it oh my god this happens all the time and it's like
bro do you honestly expect someone to sit and do the same same thing for 10 fucking years oh oh you're railing me up
look at the look at my mouse quivering and rage oh do you really expect your content creator to never diversify and do the exact same thing for 10 years
oh I'm quivering I'm quivering look at that mouse look at that mouse I'm quivering I'm quivering I'm quivering I'm reading
it's the whole live meme adjusted for beer alarm yag is home for broken girl oh I didn't realise that sorry you find shadow people ok I'll calm down
I've calmed down I've calmed down I'm ok I'm ok I'm ok a smart only viewers can be finicky literally
Angie you don't want to see her when she's Angie that friend that was supposed to originally guess she'd be snuck up yeah she got flak for it
and I was like I remember reading some of the feedback and I was like at that point had literally been at it for like 4 years
and it was like literally so much free content over like hours upon hours upon hours of free content
and you're complaining that she wants to do something different like it happened with baby pink as well
and I'm like I think Dream of Peach has caught some of it as well and I'm like do you seriously want your content creator to be pigeonholed into this one fucking thing
never diversify their content never be able to achieve their goals of like being a homeowner type thing or like diversifying their income source
because we've seen how quick Patreon can like snap it away how quick YouTube can snap it away like fuck me for doing a bit of a finger in all the pies type method
like oh my god please be nicer your content creators their income is not reassured like at all
a smart only viewers can be very needy the ones aren't shadows just not worth the energy it's the same issue with bands as well
people get so upset when they change their sound
literally you want like do you want the exact same sound every single time
no
oh what is that in me
is that a burger
it looks anemic
why is it anemic
why is
even the chip looks anemic
and now I'll pass
thanks little sis though
oh my god
how dare you pursue your dreams
literally how dare you don't ever be interested in something remotely similar to your like creative outlet
like I'm gonna actually just
I'm gonna just take my five inches already like what
it's made of wax and corsair she worked hard on a woman some peeps really don't understand the idea of having multiple passions
and I know a person that was a smart only but the community ruined it and now she's beat your bro and I
bruh fucking tell him like preach like all the fucking power to like getting it ruined by our sats
how dare you try not to grow men
he he
contains a legal amount of rat hair that's so good
that is so good
imagine getting five inches from me though
cut your losses
yeah from going by the VOD time I think she went more
I don't know considering the VOD goes on for another 58 minutes
I think she might have won
a bit of a bad idea
would you play it on a virtual headset I have never touched 3d
I am begging and pleading that the girls have 3d experience because I have zero if not I'm going on my hands and knees and contacting sin
to be like hey bestie you know how you did that 3d thing
can you just tell me everything and explain it like I'm a toddler so I know what to do for the girls so that'd be great
and sin will be literally in a voice call with me and see you you fucking bitch waking me up at this time cause we're in two different times
I was in a call with her last night I think
no I wasn't I was in a text with her last night
I was in a voice call with her like a couple of days ago
having a kitty on the both of us having a kitty on
I would I either know that same person or another career went through something
give strong credit she has at least six inches I mean it's probably four
I'm just saying five to really
you know what else is 12 inches three of these
3d is pretty cool but 2d works this thing
oh don't get me wrong I'm in no rush to like pop out 3d do you know how expensive like these models were
bruh there's no expense I had
Nari cooked and I adore it but things are very expensive when it comes to like the start up cost of getting to this stage
and it's kind of like we need to return on investment before we like start planning anything like super major that requires like investment money
like when I'm saying like all six of us is lollipop sleep ASMR
although that is technically an investment whoever's channel it goes on I'll probably put on the least subscribed channel
will like benefit from that and subs and views and money type thing and like obviously
I get what I get the company dealer gets 20%
and then it goes to the return on investment which then goes to like 3d all outfits plans are behind the scenes that are developing
and what maybe maybe gen 2 production
yeah I don't know
return on investment inspiring investors come knock no they can literally lick my chocolate starfish
do not even have the audacity to message the website to put your grubby little paws on my daughters it's not happening
you can kiss it goodbye
the only investors I'll allow is a cheeky $3 donation
that's the only investment I'll allow being like this is going towards the
I mean jeez it's I mean oh my god I mean you're so French what the fuck
I know you're French Canadian but really more you're so French Canadian
I'm an investor
no way peach emoji chocolate and lick combo that is outrageous
gen 2 mentioned like productions unconfirmed ok that's all you need at this stage it's like not in production
like it's not confirmed it's unconfirmed
no investors don't get the privilege of the starfish
blessed combo the fans are the true investors
honestly if you want to describe it that way I will genuinely 100% agree
you can fucking put my number down when you apply or if you need a reference on your CV for a job application
put my number down and I'll be like yes this refling Mr. Reefling that we're talking about the same refling
they invested in my company ok and they got the stonks up and they led not only the company to success
but in on an individual scale with their investing opportunity and they led five girls into success
to achieve their goals and their dreams and their aspirations and not only that it had a knock-on effect
to then later help another 12 girls in theory ok so there if you ever need someone to vouch for your job application
you just ring me up ok
ring ring
ah refling senior let me answer about what happened yes refling senior we have very great investment
we certainly invest our time and the return we get is enjoyment I'm glad
no that much chocolate starfish
stop that's terrible
ooh long tour
ok I understand
no this is veiler we invest in our ink so if a donation is an investment does that mean I'll own a share
oh no I shouldn't have said that
I don't like company share ideas thank you Zarian for the investment
is that why I should start instead of be like thank you for the super chat thank you for the tip
thank you for the veiler investment and my daughters that should be like my new thing
thank you for investing in my daughters
we invest our ink into strong it thank you
are we meeting for us Amy
an ink vestment
thank you for the ink vestment in my daughters
strong curls
stonk
oh yeah
ooh we're at 17 we're almost at 16000
8k wines to go just to really rub it in my face okay
shareholder meetings are just the member streams
business business business business business business that's what those the things mean
bonk bonk bonk and bonk there we go
we're almost at 16000
oh my god it's her wee toe on stream oh my god just such tiny little feet
tiny a lot of feet and hands honestly. How small is she? She must be like five foot tall or something.
Did she say how tall she is? I can't remember. I feel like I'm taller than her.
So do you Bila. No but like Emmy's like proper tiny.
Oh sorry. Sorry Edgeville Bank. Just thought I'd edge you a bit more.
You are a cuttlefish of sheer determining nation. 10% determination. Actually 100%
determination. 100% power will. 100% zero concentration because I'm on TikTok brain rotting.
Oh my god her veto is so cute. I miss having a toenail. Oh my god wait I can start making
jokes like that. I wish having a toenail. I miss having a toenail. I'm trying to do
my competition. Okay we're at 16. Let's go. Oh it is a picnic day. That's so cute.
Oh it's a bento box with the panda. Super chat's been called Invicts. Ink vestments is a fun one.
Congrats on 18k. Wait I happened? Not me grinding on runescaping in 18k. What the
fuck? How? I'm not even doing it. I'm literally meming on runescape.
What does it say? Oh my god 18,000 and three subscribers. I'm literally meming on runescape.
Watching a genmeat forward like bro. Oh my god that's insane. Thank you everyone. I promise I'll
make it up to you. Next month is our month of making it up okay. It's my month of making it up to you
with all the ASMR. Just 2k away from 20k. Bro literally that's insane. That runescape boost
literally. Oh my god everyone loves runescape. Everyone's loving runescape. Makeup month literally.
Let it be known that August is makeup month. Tonight I'm recording my ASMR. My last one.
Oh no they've been mensable. Who made me upset? I'm gonna fart on them.
I'm gonna fart on them. Who made my daughter upset?
Who made my daughter upset?
Weflin's gonna get that cake. Congrats on the incredible and visionary
content no other creator dared to do. You really understand the minds of mankind.
Must be the caught fish bov. Ah yes when I dropped my pregnancy ASMR I'm sure everyone
will be like this is exactly the ASMR I wanted.
Where'd it go?
Ah Amy's a cutie pie I think that's it. The rat soup was so funny. Tonight you're
going for a short walk and drinking lots of water and fuck. Right okay water hydration check.
I used to be so good at it last year and I'm fucking doing nothing. Okay hydration.
5k for what?
For what? Showing her her panini? Why is she showing for 5k? I missed it. What was context?
What subscribe? Oh subscribers. Subscribers.
Not her already in the minds of the pinpals before this ends. Who is showing badge? I
thought Amy was but she we're watching an older vod of Amy and she's like for 10k
I'll do something and I'm like wait for 10k but obviously this was back at the start where she
wasn't at 10k subs. This is before she went on holiday. We're watching her play with the rats.
Mm-mm. Azura. Peeler allegations rest with Azura and her doughnathon. I'm gonna put it in her
doughnathon and then she's gonna get it reviewed on stream by the Bleaton Hearts and if they like
it I'm not gonna touch the doughnathon. I love the arc where no matter what strongy does the numbers
go up in a full stream strongy has a cam on a mint plant she waters occasionally 2 million views
and counting she's so confused literally. Abram mercy. Oh we popped! 96. 96. 96. 96.
You leave me in my fanny flaps alone using my wings to fly through strongy's window listen
to my propeller. Sin. What even? Sin structure is that that you're forcing upon us to read. I was
literally just talking about you. I was like oh I was in a voice chat with Sin. I need to ask you
about your 3D setup. I think you're literally the only point of contact I have that knows about 3D.
I don't think anyone any of the girls at Veil or know about 3D. You're literally my fence.
You're my fence sheebie. It's sheebie. Sin.
She went and did it. I was gonna say she went and did it anyway.
Oh my god she called me my PL. Stop! Stop! Oh my god what is Sin supposed to be? Oh my god what?
Napo hire? Back in my day 3D models used to be the go-to now it's the opposite.
You should know that Sin speak of the devil and he shall hear. Say her a long truth.
Fuck it! No don't laugh at me Sin! What the fuck? You'll napo hire you? I'll napo all over you.
Kim's on you? I'll napo on you so hard. Don't think I'll ruin the reputation of Veiler for
being a fair agency. Just the napo hire you. Don't think I won't do it. I'll do it. I'll
absolutely ruin everything. Run it into the ground. As long as you tell me how 3D works
and what your fucking trackers are and how you set it up because I've not got a fucking clue.
Like I need an actual iPhone video from you sent to me in Discord DMs because I don't know what
on earth I need to do for the girls. I'll ink on your nan. I shite, I shite, I shite.
I'll ink on your nan.
What's a nipple hire? No! A napo, nepotism means like oh you get hired purely on the
basis that you ken them like you know about them and that. I'm not actually sure how that
ruined the rep. I think that's called contacts. In the business? I don't know just like because
we kind of got praised publicly for like rooting for the underdog and that and then it's just
like oh napo hire on the agency. Nepo hire, nepotism. Your nan has nae arms, nae legs and lives in a
pillowcase! Everyone who's listening to this in the background like what are they
even on the, what are they bantering with each other then? Also are you smarter than a fifth
grader is like on epic instead of on flipping some fish? Wait am I being an idiot? Did I not
have a collab with AC? Am I being papaga? I think I had a collab with AC. I think I got cancelled.
Am I being dumb?
I think I got cancelled. Actually that just occurred to me. I had a collab with AC at some
point. Is it cancelled or is it two weeks away? I mean Nepo hire is more if you've got no other
redeeming value if they're good at what they do. My brain solution. Isn't AC taking a break? Yeah.
I think we were supposed to, no we couldn't have because I wasn't in the box. I don't know.
I don't know. She's collabing with Emmy this week. How do you know? How do you know that?
What? Who? I stream once a year, Get Me In Lands, Honest. Oh my god portfolio. I'll look, I'm willing
to look over that portfolio if you send me a picture of how you do your 3D streams. Thank you.
That's all I need. Emmy released a schedule. Okay that's fine then. You're allowed to know them.
Yeah. AC and Emmy are collabing. They're gonna play a game called Don't Starve Together and
apparently Willow is the most OP character and all the characters in the game are named after W
like Wilson, Willow, something else. I can't believe it. The portfolio is just the 3D stream
instructions. Literally. No that would be the introduction video. Hi I'm Sin. This is how
I set up my 3D stream. Thank you. I'll take that thing. Say it again. Sin sister will be a slime girl
never hire. Really? You think she'd be a fucking slime girl? Slime girl. Someone actually, I looked
at the 2D, 2D. I looked at the gen to draw in your suggestion stream and someone was like
why do you hate slime girls and I just thought, I just like the gimmick was old and he replied like,
I didn't reply to his response but he said something along the lines of like but there's
so much diversity and I want it to be like but I have to commission the diversity if you want them
fat skinny long does this big boobs no boobs this this toggle that toggle the concept of a slime is
good but to translate into a vtuber model is an absolute nightmare because everyone would be like
well it's the slime girl why can't the slime girl do this this this this this this this this
because that's how it's like now it's like no no no I don't like that. Hi thanks for joining.
Win is for a wombo. Don't starve is great wimmy.
I literally got to pay for a million things. Yeah it's just not possible to translate like it's
just not happening. Sorry like I'm so sorry if like you guys think I'm like oh Australia's clearly
like bluffing on this one thing I am not bluffing I can't I can't give a design to someone that I
think would be a debuff truly. Change it to slime girl. That's true I would pick it would
perish her wallet literally I've had enough perish in the wallets for one day. Put too much
love and care I can't believe that put too much love and care into the girls and I grow boss too hard.
She doesn't hate slime but she loves them. Yes I don't mind the design but in terms of vtuber slime
everyone is going to be like uh why not?
Wow she said it not me we were all thinking about it. As long as I like I'm going to get the
issues she can do anything toggle whip slimy girl strongy when she's ovulating honestly.
I don't know why not ovulation I think ovulation's about
less than 14 days away it's still a little while away yet for me.
She only wants to get a bang to buy a slime but not put one in the gen which is fair right
there don't read that down. Oh my god you're getting a message right now M.A. you're so
fired I can't believe it. AC says that all the time she's like oh my god strongy's gonna fire me
and I'm like what no that's not how it works. Wait did she fart?
First girl's after this. You heard the reflans you have two weeks no not yet
and oh actually my birthday October 10th might actually perfectly align with ovulation
could you imagine? So that's like the 12th I don't know I'll tell you when I'll tell you when
it happens okay. I don't know if I said it in the education stream but you get like a bit of
slime that comes out of you that you can straight up identify as like oh that's ovulation slime
it's bizarre honestly being a woman's bizarre. I just rejoined two weeks for what? Ovulation.
I saw a lot stringier. I'm a hands-on learner I know I think that Emmy's reinforcing the taboo that
makes her happy. Oh that's like a good ASMR sound whatever that is. That was honestly
satisfying hold on a minute M.A. can you send me that for ASMR that'd be great. I turned it like
drrr drrr drrr. Bansley stream ovulation time.
Just trying to speedrun. Everyone expected like an endurance stream or whatever and
literally it's going to be like right let's me down in like less than 10 minutes unless I get too shy.
We're still going we're endurance and we're level 96 only ton only 16,000 more wines to go.
Nice background. The 10 minute birthday stream literally k thanks bye. Let us know when I will
send you something over. Why is it all churned real? Finish in 10 minutes chat for three hours.
Yeah I mean that could be some level of aftercare.
Getting my little sister drunk is my win.
Gonna be the hottest three minutes and 27 seconds. No because that's what's gonna fucking happen.
That's literally what's gonna happen. I'm not even sure how much I'm allowed to laugh.
Oh word speedrun. I still would watch. M.A. is actually getting drunk in this and around
her member stream right now. Is she? Better behave then. I bet that was gonna be gone by the time.
No not at all. Not at all. Pop that cheese down where you please darling.
Are we racing? Oh now this is pod racing. Everyone's laughing until the girl pulls out the megatron
9000. Fucking you know. There are plenty of v-subers that just that's in most streams so I
won't go for like 30 minutes and chat for two hours at all. Just a matter of got content.
Imagine being late to the stream. I don't know I'm gonna have to watch what Mercy and all that
does. They're all like gonna do it first and I need to watch what they do without being a weirdo
just in terms of like what did you do? Does the mod stay up as content? I don't know how any of it
works. I don't know how streaming works on it. Her little cute toys. Oh my god that's so cute.
She loves the cheese.
I can never explain why but whenever my past girlfriends would have their time of
hmm I would get very like sometimes it'd be really and have no idea why until the girl pulls out.
You mean ketchup season or slime season?
Hey Strani I'm coming from Mimi's members stream and she's doing a great career stream.
We are all trying to convince her that you should have her do more cover songs
since she's singing so good. I'm so glad so I picked one song out she picked another song out.
I basically made our deal I said look here's these channels they've all done well doing this
can I ask you to do two song covers and if they do pitch I'll never ask you to do anything else
again and she agreed to it so I do have two songs one's being mixed one's already mixed I'm
waiting on the animation and then the music video can be produced um but I do not I'm not stopping
the girls if they want to do song covers or anything of that accord.
Unsightly like that lute earlick and stuff yeah no I mean you're streamed done in two minutes
and you're already in the aftercare yeah honestly though I get I fart before right sorry this is
like a completely unrelated note I get really nervous before I touch the peril for some reason
and I like to a lot before I do anything I get really nervous to like myself you know I don't
know why I think like something got crossed in my brain wrong or something
let's just know like a little fucking start tooting and shit like what the fuck
that's not hot going like a scrawny cull bun look at buns of steel my last partner was a quick
she was fun to isn't that post um um um torture
oh estaban launched herself
wait so this slimy speak up is different from ketchup so
how do I say this around the filters so the clam is a self cleaning um organ so it needs to expel
stuff at all times old cells old mucus all this kind of thing so it's natural to have this thing
called discharge okay now obviously when it's ketchup season this is in reference to a period so
that's just um the lining shredding and it's very natural for stuff to come out after the red river
has finished flowing a couple of days later ovulation will occur now the reason you can identify
this time frame is because a certain consistency of slime can come out and it's very identifiable
when you know what you're looking for and so pretty much a woman can be like ashes of fertile
because women cannot be impregnated during every single day of the month that's not possible that's
not how the cycle works if for a 48 hour period a woman can become pregnant every month because
of this monthly cycle that's how it works in humans in particular it's quite different from a ton of
different mammals um but yeah the um something going to be posted soon on patreon yes either
most likely tomorrow will be my last audio it'll have multiple endings i'm going to be exhausted
but i'm gonna get it done so most likely after the blinks stream tomorrow the last patreon audio
for me goes up and azura as well goes up and it blows it's nose so here i know it exists but
my part in it need that slime
this is bizarre when talking about it doggies i'm going to hate me
so i'm gonna i'm holding my back from saying disgustingly down bad thing it's really rather
why be the last oh sorry the last of this month every month i'll upload four
alternative audios but i also mix in my early access stuff because i have the resources to
do it that way for the girls it's not really that easy to do it unless i gave them like
direct access to the patreon but i don't want any of the girls to receive any harassment because
patreon doesn't let you shut down dms they are open and readable and i don't want any of the girls
to get harassed so i can't let them in if that makes sense so the girls can view how much they air
and they can see the statistics so and all that no issues but yeah but we love your face and me
you're so cute it's not the last audio some of the towns call it gossip don't question has
been set all over we're taking on as if she's spit what i'm sorry i can't follow your story
i apologize i apologize i should be a little fella i should be that is like conquer's bad for
day our audios from previous months available yep you have previous access to absolutely
everything and i do not believe in removing monthly rewards i do not like that system i think it is
quite now i do understand why other creators do it don't get me wrong but for me i don't like
the system the girls are adhering to the system that i want to implement so everything is accessible
um yeah it's okay new dog new dog was a stray around town for a while no one knew who belonged
to it fam was talking about if it needed dressed or not okay okay okay
what's going on over there at me
mostly everything's available from credit all you got to do is just say yes we do not remove like
so it's july um all the dune contents there all the july contents there and all the content
is gonna remain nothing's gonna be removed unless one of the girls for some reason had a very
valid reason for wanting something removed at the point of upload it's there's no plan for removal
unless at the end of the contract the girls no longer wanted that content up for whatever reason
because if they left um it's kind of their choice of hey we can continue to give you a payout from
this source for people who want access to the content for the first time um or if you want to
take all that content away with you that's your choice um there's a few ways to figure out it's a
bit of a obviously a last thing i want to do is be predatory towards the girls
is that where her notification comes from
i had no clue why her notification was that noise that sent in
um i didn't know that's where it came from i thought pinpals requested it or something
no she was just redoing it all right
not her praise in the corruption arc no emi said it very i think it's just
oh it's in the andy and lily's okay
i need to talk
why is it as soon as i mute to two it goes away
emi is the biggest corruptor and veiler real
oh my god i swear if i know who she's talking about uh i have got i have fell for a creator
who did something like that which is the story
emi's gonna stab you for saying that
oh my gosh
that's actually a really good clip
brah if any any reflin is open on the board please clip that so i can join it that's a really good
clip people are lying online never oh i fell for it with another creator and this creator was like
crying online being like i'm gonna get kicked out and and she had an established ASMR channel
she just never uploaded um and i fell for her crocodile tears and the egg is on my face um she
was like i'm gonna get kicked out my landlord this my landlord that so i don't believe in an exchange
of money so i never gave her any money but she opened up like an emergency fund and like put on
a community post and all that and overnight she made like two thousand us dollars which covered
whatever fee she needed to pay to stay in her rental now this was in december okay so just
keep that in mind it's in december and so she messaged me that she messaged my situation saying
like i'm about to get kicked out if i can't make up this money i said right you go to sleep i'll
take care of everything okay so i stayed up all night i made her eight i think eight to twelve
scripts um i ordered her five emergency artworks where she could just take it and use it on her
channel to get like youtube ad revenue all that thing and then i like wrote all these scripts
all these plots out and then she was like oh but my character is a slime girl that doesn't
fit with the lore of my channel and i was like excuse me i was like are you not about to get
kicked out you've just said publicly you're about to get kicked out you have people that are paying
towards you not to get kicked out and you're concerned about your channel's lore of a slime girl
um and like i did an emergency collab with her and like through the video up overnight had no
sleep whatsoever and i said you can keep a hundred percent of the earnings from the video to stop you
from getting kicked out like please message your landlord ask them and say to them like youtube
pay you on the 25th i can pay you the paypal money as soon as like youtube registers the income from
the video all of this right and then the next day i wake up the video was already up and all that
fan like jaffa raro did amazing he like handed me the artwork and everything and she made the 2000
and i was like oh my gosh that's fantastic i'm so happy for you um and i said to i was like look
here's artwork that i got emergency again you can use the scripts if you revive your channel you'll
never be in that situation again you know you're doing fine you have tons of subscribers it's
just you need to post and then um i never spoke to her for a while but eventually i uploaded the
that was it i uploaded the collab at a later date um and she messages me and she's like uh
strongy um i'm not really happy with that collab audio being uploaded and made to look like you
collabing with like the average um person i'm like oh what do you mean like it's it's still a collab
we did together you know you made the money um you didn't get kicked out type thing so i uploaded it
as a regular video because you know i paid for the artwork i wrote the script i edited it together
like i think it's a fair exchange to say like you don't need the money if that was the problem but
you don't need the money because you know you'd never got kicked out type thing and they're and
they're like i just think it's really like disrespectful like you never told me it was
gonna go up and i was like oh well like i actually do like a lot of stuff in advance especially with
collabs it takes a while for things to like come at the surface because there's so many other backlog
issues like with the changes to youtube and that um and like she had another go at me and she typed
out this big massive paragraph and i was like what do you want as a result of this conversation
and she went i just wish you would have told me you were gonna put that up and i was like uh
all right then and she like unfollowed me um unfriended me so we had like no more communication
i'm like i just fucking like wrote all these scripts for you so obviously i deleted the link
to the script so she didn't have access to them anymore um so she didn't have access to make money
off of my script type thing and then the artwork i actually still have it and i'm so tempted to just
recolor it and use it um because like i paid for it obviously and she never used it and the reason
why it is 10 times worse than you think um the reason why it's 10 times worse than you think
is because every year she now goes on her youtube that she's pretty much abandoned and uploads like
three times a year she has a larger subscriber base than and she says every time right around
november december which just happens to be gift giving season oh oh oh i've no got enough money
and i fucking fail for it and consistently i think it's happened three times in a uh three times
now every year um i take a peek to be like oh you revived your channel whatever and yeah i got i got
i got played but the the funny thing is the collab got me a big bit of pocket money so
i'm very happy to say that i did come out um on top after that very unique experience but
basically if a creator ever comes to me for help now i don't fucking do it i have had so many
creators reach out and be like oh strongy how do i revive my channel and i've sat down for an hour
analyze the fuck out of their channel for them told them what to do what do this do that do this
and been ignored it's happened countless times now so it is very satisfying having the veal or girls
with me because they actually sit listen to what i tell them to do basically fake crisis the standard
november tat yep and you you endure spite success um i can't help but wonder if people are suspicious
that every third video is begging for money yes um but the problem is they want the solution without
effort the thing is they have a ridiculous subscriber amount they could be making bank if they just
uploaded regularly but they don't do it and i don't know why they like obviously i'm not gonna say
names because there's anyone to be a nasty fuck um but like it's just such a frustrating situation
and i have never and because of that bad situation now this is a shame but because of that one bad
situation i have never helped someone to that degree ever again since like i genuinely believe
this person when they were like i'm literally about to get kicked out like they publicly were like
please donate to my coffee like if you can if you have anything and every year they do it they have
a crisis right before december this the fucking christmas sales and it annoys me so much because
i fell for it honestly hold on right let me look it up i don't even know the channel so
um i just remember being dumbfounded when i should have known actually that should have been the
biggest red flag was when i was like right here's four scripts i'm gonna write you some more before
you go to bed but go record them type thing and you can edit all your sound effects in
and they were like oh but but that doesn't that doesn't match my slime girl lore and i'm
slime girl lore you're about to be kicked out are you not because you can't do fucking rent
um yeah their channel's still abandoned let me guess community post oh
oh let me guess
oh let me get there's gonna be a little begging post around uh november
oh they've been deleting the posts where they're asking for money
but yeah they're still gone so that is the the one and only time i was honey potted by
another content creator and i've never done it before seven hour yet was running can't be
better than this i fell for similar ones lost it yeah i i'm glad there was no exchange of money
and i am glad that the collab blew up because i got to pocket the money
because um i think what they were actually going to say in dms but they didn't was i think i have
a right to the money but even though um i she literally celebrated in less than 24 hours she got
the money needed for her rent and i think that's what annoyed her was that i was pocketing the
money even though i did the script i did the edit i bought the artwork uh you know like bro
i think that's what she was actually trying to say but because of the way i'm so direct and i was like
hey what do you want to be the result of this conversation i shit you not that that sentence
please take it with you reeflings whenever you find yourself in a conversation where you're like
what is going on here this makes no sense i'm so sorry i'm talking over in me right now
this makes no sense i don't know just go what do you want to be the result of this conversation
and it cuts any bullshit it cuts through any emotions it cuts through anything it's just
what do you want to be the result of this situation and boom you have the answer and i think what she
really wanted to say was i'm entitled to the money from the youtube video but because i literally
had congratulated on her for making the donation and then yeah
remember guys a japanese girl's literally sold a manual on how to do these things to guys in
to strone apparently stop i got fucking a filth i just felt so bad i was like oh my god you're
about to be kicked out like that's horrible that's terrible right oh you you know your channel does
well right right you just need to upload more that's all and i should have known when it was just
a sea of excuses of being like oh i can't upload because like i haven't been uploading because of
this this this um and i was like do you have an in real life job and it was like no job market's
bad and it was like well you have a successful youtube channel so wouldn't you be a like i like
i look back on it and i feel like an idiot but i will say it's like life experience and
you know those kind of attributes like between her and all the other content creators were like
stroney stroney how do i fix my channel and then completely ignored me it definitely influenced
me to start viola because i can literally go to the girls and be like hey let's do an ASMR train
and they all said yep all right let's do it and it was an absolute massive success type thing like
it is so nice to be listened to oh you know like it's so fucking nice i literally leveled up from
the experience got fucking but literally you live and you learn and i learned my lesson and
you know and now i have five beautiful daughters and i'll just advise the best i can if anything
as i said like some of them are hands off others are like you know gotta advise a wee bit come back
next day and there have been an event with the same guy oh wait hold on bro i had that happen
on a job once and i uh answered and i got such bs and i needed a mental day off to recover to not
snap at him and later he got fired on the account of what happened yeah um having people who actually
listened hell it's so good for your sanity because i have messaged i have been messaged by a lot of
channels being like hey i've noticed my subscribers and numbers are down what i do and i'm like hey
this is what you should do based on your channel history um like i had one girl that was messaging
me every day now unfortunately i am very hard to become friends with i am very easy to become
business acquaintances with i am happy to talk business i am happy to talk xyz i am very bad at
maintaining friendships okay so a lot of people would come to me with business kind of friendships
which i am a hundred percent comfortable with but there was this particular girl who very clearly
wanted to be friends and i i just i said three times like directly i was like look really sorry
i'm a very busy person i don't have time for friendship but you have content creation advice
i'm happy to give it like you know if you have questions i'm happy to give it um because she
was a smaller channel at the time um i don't know she's still grown or not but hopefully she's doing
well um and then every day i would wake up to a question of what do you think i should do
and it got to the point where i wasn't giving advice they were asking me to straight up give them
free channel manager like um guidance and i'm like i'm not doing this i i don't have time to do this
every single day for you and um it's very interesting it's very very interesting um i understand
wanting help and a leg up and all that and like i have collab with tons of folk like i've never
had any issues with collab and i don't mind i'll absolutely adore collab and i like it and
and i'm really thankful to all the v-tubers i've agreed to crazy things with me you know
strongly never feel like an idiot for trying to be a good person like you thought they were
a shitty person brah literally um that's kind of the naivety that i spoke about in the script
and script and the prying with you is more like i'm nave and yeah it has led to like moments
of hurt frustration negativity but you know what actually i'm glad that i'm nave because it makes
it's a part of me and you know what god forbids uh think about the best in people even if they
don't mean it you know let me live my life and kind of just seeing the best even if it might not
necessarily be true at the end of the day i'll i'll keep my naivety because i think it it gives me
an edge to see humanity a bit better than another person you know it means you haven't become jaded
or broken yeah like don't get me wrong being naive has hurt me it has there's no going about it i've
been hurt multiple times because of the the you know the default nature of that but it's a part of
me i want to see the best in people in any way i can and you know just because it happened to one
girl now as i said i never helped anyone to that degree again where i was writing scripts and telling
them what to do and take this money and uh actually i tell her like i did a collab with one girl and
gave her all the money but that was a different situation okay that doesn't count that doesn't
count it was different okay um but oh wait no i did it four more times after that as well no but
that doesn't count as well because there is a that was a situation out of their control right
but what i'm saying is i never did it to the point where like i ordered artwork and stayed up all night
and like gave them 12 roleplays and all that okay sorry sorry i didn't mean it like that i didn't
mean it like that don't you're such a sweetheart the 10 other counts the towns don't count okay
one collab is different from right literally staying up all night and writing like 12 scripts for
this person to use literally no i was like oh you don't even need to credit me or anything and you
can pocket all of the money like oh what was i thinking honestly trusting people come back
fire but that doesn't mean you shouldn't stop all together never change from your care and self
mommy but um i that's sorry i've like completely lowered down the volume of emmy stream i feel
so bad to have that little ramble but uh yeah you'd be surprised what happens behind the scenes
you know everything looks hunky dory on the surface but mommy's still kind of helped them
you're so kind of such a sweet girl i just try my best like um i'm currently in contact with
this really nice girl and i was like hey if anyone else needs help just reach out to me like
there's nothing worse than feeling alone and absolutely like just up shit creek and without
a paddle and i would like to think that i offer what others might offer to me if i reached out and
needed that help because like goodness knows i could have used that at the start um
but obviously i never had that because i wasn't like that you know you didn't reach out for help
i never did anything for like that i was always the one like reaching out to others if that makes
sense you know there's gonna be hugs in it the lesson you want to take from getting um done
30 is learning how to judge better not trustly yeah i'm definitely very skeptical now if i ever
see a channel that has like high subscriber high views but like hardly upload i'm like
i think i know have i meet it with skepticism if there was ever any like oh i need like emergency
funds to exist i'm like hmm why aren't you uploading in general to you know stay on the
the bike that is content creation because it's like riding a bike if you stop pedaling
surprise surprise you aren't gonna get what you want out of it you know i love the idea of
remaining naive unfortunately we're at the point where as much as we stay away the issues are now
coming to us um it's uh a dog eat dog world but you know maybe
maybe the silver lining is the experiences we get along the way because now i get to have a winch
like come on come on i'm scottish i love a good winch okay i love a good winch that remains me
that i can't swim anymore because there's dogs in the war jokes on you having electric bacon it goes
on it's oh and how dare you always look on the bright side of like woohoo woohoo woohoo woohoo
i didn't want to whistle because whistling can be quite stuff oh look at the octopus she made
it's me hold on i'm turning up in me again i'm gonna go back to watching a means what okay ignore
the volume at 56 percent how dare it okay emi's making meatballs we're actually right at the end
of emi's world i'm gonna have to get another water always look on this is why you gotta get jaded
in cynical until yours talks because everyone else please don't do that emi just picked her nose
did she did she just show us a bogey
are you trolling little sister picks her nose and makes you eat it a somewhere
and it's just like severe wrestling noises and like put it in your mouth put it in your mouth
right now emi's so close to 20k that's fantastic i'm so happy how many views does that clip have
of her mountain that's like she's making pumpkin
yeah and then she asks who's gonna look it off stop i didn't know she did the emi she'll be really
she's such a gross little sister
all right
ah
he drink is on p
is that real
he would eat what she eats and then peas and then drinks it
okay congrats on 18k thank you so much i'm so glad to be in 15 000 uh is more
that yippee but i'm working on it yippee
um everyone knows if you pick your nose and eat it it builds up your immune system
uh visit ones maybe please learn quick difference between edamore and glazegar
if you see someone walking down the street with a golf club in edambrough he's gonna go
play go yes oh my god yes true real no put it in a scripture make it the lower it's real
actually real wait she kind of nailed that oh wait no she didn't she nailed the squid
oh wait what's wrong with the panda
what's wrong with the panda
she's scared of that's adorable the rice is gonna get you it's gonna get you
whoa
a genuine real he tried to make it the bear grill special
what we at 15 000 not bad 15 000 wines to go that's not bad at all considering we started
on 30 wines i'm wondering if maybe we can get it to like seven k by the end of stream is that too
seven k
um oh she tried it oh my little sister's so brave
you're welcoming me
yeah
is she gagging who's had enough
i wonder if the stain ever came out of that blanket i'm sure it does
stained with emi you okay darlin i'm getting worried this is in the past
we have mersey whistling she could engage in perfectly
what did she make another script post sorry but i'm literally copying and pasting what she does
and i need to i need to get it out soon soon soon when i'm de-stressed
i need de-stressed when you get any get my ass in gear and stop piss horsing around
love you too emi i'll see you tomorrow
oh i saw a video about negative five site emi is gone
i thought her mouse was like a thing wearing a thong like sideways like a butt wearing a thong
i'm staying i'm staying i'll be a good good pin pal i'll be a good big brother
boom right we'll take a bit of a break from from react andy and even though i yapped through
the whole thing i'm just gonna check over my comments i think i'm gonna get something to eat
right hold on i'm all gonna check don't worry it's actually cringe in normal english too we
just normalize that that must be in reference to me saying daddy and spicy sausage my newest short
with my spacey soul she's strolling your ass has been in gear five all month the gearbox
sounds like an army marching please you think emi's site is bad mine's worse what's your prescription
main one twi- um she was saying she misses she could walk around with ears tail and
i told you you had to enable her i told you i told you
aww someone said cuddly fish on my asian stream
if anyone wants to know that humming in the background is a hundred hertz
how would you know that what is that how do you even um pump up the jam pump it up
while your feet is bumping what are we looking at what are we looking at show us the goods show us
the goods halfway halfway to 97 uh gentiff did mentorship someone commented on my starter
short how dare you negative six jeez strut uh tiny spinny something you can go around and pick up on
did you like a zero's pick up line short am i actually post that
what wait someone watched who wants to be a millionaire watch this as an introduction to
strawney the degree of scottish rage is endearing was that actually really angry in the millionaire
screen i just get frustrated because i'm like some of them are so silly like i looked i watched back
the stream and that lame comment i'm actually still really mad i'm actually still really bad at
the mad at the lame question honestly hi i'm back from little sister stream uh apparently she was
doing karaoke and singing so i hope you pardon me pinpals enjoyed it um she does have two songs
on the way obviously we got filled by the animator so it's been sitting waiting forever
i've never done that again um
aha someone commented on uh real psychoping ASMR one absolute cash grab oh you got me
oh that's right you had to pay to access it oh wait unless i was in reference to the stream
yesterday wait wait a minute wait a minute are you secretly a wiefling and i can't tell the
you're gonna have to put oh emmy you were she threw up and sang too so is she drunk is emmy
drunk we just finished watching uh we were reacting to emmy making candy with her rats
we've just finished the vod i don't know if you see that two hours 46 um emmy raid thank you emmy
and hi pinpals we are just cooking to level 99 we are watching vods of my gen mates unfortunately
emmy says she loves straw night well straw night loves emmy what you gonna do about it huh
hmm huh yeah wait she literally she's gonna go shower and go a bit okay i need to send her a
dm to make sure she's okay hi pinpals emmy raid and also emmy's in game don't worry she's right
here and maybe she's got a ginger pleats and everything um um i don't know if mersey's coming
online later today if mersey is coming online her usual start times an hour and a half we are just
doing a vod watch longs because i don't have time to see my gen mates all the time oh emmy please
drink water and get some food in your tummy we just watched your making candy with my rats and
you were feeding them cheese and we um we estaban every time estaban she got some cheese she would
use her back legs to like paddle backwards to like scoot away with the cheese and it was very cute
do get a shower do get some water no make don't make the shower too hot okay because it'll make
you dizzy and we don't want a dizzy and me no dizziness have some water have some food
rehydrate maybe sweat out some of the alcohol while you're at it you too should kiss and record
it for ace and that's all you guys said when i was reading right in the scripts um
um
what the fuck
yeah um we're gonna pick um azura's um what's it called azura's celebration stream membership
celebration is what we're gonna do next because i never saw it and she was like doodling live
is there a delay membership celebration stream is it two hours if it's okay it's it's fucking three
hours wrap it up you all need to wrap it up no i'm just kidding did the hand come work it did
okay oh that's precious okay we're gonna watch azura next hold on i need to like do all the stuff
at the same time the cooking level is going fantastic we once we finish these 15 000 wine
and grapes we done we done so um i'm not gonna finish it but i'm level 96 i'm not gonna finish
it this stream but that's not a big deal um i'm gonna prepare to put on azura's one though
there we go monetization on azura do titties who said that azura doodling
okay um and then we're gonna copy and paste the linky poo why is
and then we're gonna do that just like that okay and then i'm going to take the link
and i'm going to update my chat with it fondle abuzum how dare you how dare you that was a good
name karam beat is all right if it was a cscl twitter but yeah okay right we are in world
world three ae we're edging in edge vel and watching azura okay wow please don't do anything silly
we don't have yeah and i'm gonna pin this okay we're gonna pin surely that worked surely okay
yeah that worked a friend of mine got really excited seeing runescape and asked six questions
about um your xp job i have no idea what happened but he seemed really happy no idea joy no sorry joy
stick is the best name and please don't think i won't develop it legit because i will i've got
a tap out it's three in the morning okay rest well don't forget that the nuke vods itself at 11
hours 50 okay i'll keep that in mind thank you um oh yeah it's only 15 000 you know like 15 minutes
surely kopium kopium oh pin pals your little sister's almost got 20 000 subscribers she's already
one fifth of the way to a play button thanks to all your support pin pals so you can give yourself
a pat on the back and a cheeky wankers a reward for being so good and supportive to your little sister
and right are we ready are we steady for this azura stream does everyone have azura streams ready
i will say three two one go and then we'll hit go and then that'll be us i'm so happy for her
all right i'm quacking out gonna bask in the afterglow that stream oh that's lovely
i thought play buttons were at 10k it's 100k subscribers for the play button and emmy is
quite literally one fifth of the way there that's like insane she's one fifth of the way there to
a play button like that quick we've not even entered her third month of streaming yet like
just she's doing so good she really pushes herself she doesn't give herself enough credit honestly
yes we were aware that she's amazing good that's what i like to see
now put her oh she marks in your name right now i don't think i'm not one to you right as everyone
got azura stream open i will go three two one go and then go don't forget to like and subscribe
to your little sister her link is in the description below okay azuras monetization celebration stream
and three two one go man what a good starting loading screen oh i came you can't tell me what
to do you are my oh she uh but wouldn't your oh she want you to have her oh she marks in your name
look look sorry i don't make the rules but if you looked your little sister in the eyes and said
sorry i don't have your oh she marks in my youtube name how do you think well how would she respond
would she spit in your face would she stomp on you come on think of your little sister man
can't believe it can't believe i have to tell you how to behave around her my oh she is gone no
i hope next time she chooses something than irish cream it's a really heavy drink
oh does she did was she drinking irish cream that's what can i do
don't get me on my fondle of bosom account is that you on the fucking fondle of bosom account
that's hilarious if so hilarious my oh she oh she mark is on my youtube name
hey there's me down she can try to spit but consequences strong and consequence yeah it was me
oh we found you the real fondle of bosom earth can i hear oh as there is background music is just
a bit low for me it's my headset it's my headset because all my settings are like super low right
now so i don't hurt my ear balls my little ears my the snail in my ear i don't want to hurt the snail
in my ear um your oh she's gone she's gone she's gonna get a shower because apparently she puked
on herself and then continued to sing i don't know what goes on um i don't know what goes on
in the member streams for me but as long as you guys had a good time that's the only thing that's
important okay i can put strongy oh she marks in my youtube uh in because i bring what what the
fuck i don't i don't know how you do that but the three little bones in your ear what are they called
come on i told you in the education stream only real reeflings know what the small three bones
in your ear are called they listen to my education stream the bleeding heart design is so cute need
it as a plushie wouldn't that be so cool if everyone could purchase their mascot merchandise
at the same time and they all got released oh wouldn't that be awesome oh that would be cool
be wicked wouldn't it i actually don't remember the code the free bones hammer anvil and stirrup
you got it ding ding ding ding i just got all the key chains i'm waiting for the key chains come
flying through the door so i can do hand asmr i'm gonna record a video of me like tapping all
the girls and i'll be like this is any and this is me see let them know use codes join you for 10%
off camera slaps or any girl at vl or um not a problem at all
does that hurt that was her pc surely copy um that was her pc that made that noise
my pc didn't make that noise let them know code's running for 10% off camera slaps let's go
let's go i thought i was main as this is i don't know i got a whole new spc it's
nothing but trouble definitely hers what's the members agility herblore thieving
did they not say they remain introduced a new skill at some point i could have sworn uh maybe
i'm starting to fight with demons um are you an iMac user no
i don't know it's a new skill sailing i knew it oh my gosh that'll be interesting i guess it
would kind of be like agility possibly and you're like literally like keyboard the
bleeding heart is adorable like to focus on something else though in the image
look how innocent the bleeding hearts are they're just happy to be there a little goat thing
i love that the mascot like mascot like a child honestly no like mascot like mama
um
oh is there is sleeping in the bath she's asleep oh hear her i hear her i can't see her though
yes it's too early for the pub lunch
hmm also everyone like comment and subscribe sing
as long as she's not lagging her model seems to lag on her pc and i was like
i bought her like a beast of a pc she will not need an upgrade in like five years unironically
i never got to see this stream but i think i really like doodle streams sorry i do i think
they're adorable i said it i think they're adorable i think doodle and creativity streams
like that are just like fun to watch and see what someone else comes up with um
when the 14 000s well definitely 9 000s does she have an i9 processor they've had a lot of
stability i think it was like a beast of a pc management picked out for her um and she's had
nothing but issues with it and it was pre-built as well she just had to pick it up but um i think
there's a power supply issue in her current location which is why i want her to move out like
instantly so i'm praying her donor phone just like blows beyond expectations you know um
i'm hanging on i'm hanging on i promise
does she do a hand cam for the first time oh she's a stinger she's so professional
there she is
hi is there a
oh she's got wee gloves on or is that a remixer
hi oh i've not seen that
on the topic of monetization can i get it can i take a moment to curse they won't let me
transfer a singular donor to renew my straw net uh what the i can't believe it the banks of
infiltrator does the high table no
oh my god this is so cute what the heck
oh this stream is so cute i can't believe i missed it look at the wee lover
oh my god
oh she's so happy
i went to pinch her cheeks the goddess is adorable honestly she's such a cosy babe
oh that's precious
her voice is so soothing literally i'm gonna end up falling asleep at this rate
hi is there a
yippee took long enough youtube took long enough but she got monetized that's the
main thing that's all we care about
she's shy
particular
oh why you goofy goober what how could fingers or fingers
oh like she wants her nails done
aww is there
the hi baby in my left ear yeah yeah yeah
i was so happy to see my camera when she finally got monetized the cream bro youtube oh my i
know what the problem was now and i'm really annoyed that he even flipped through she had to
do a fucking embarrassment ritual and be like i had to sit a bit of video being like i'm a
i make content in my live stream and it's just so silly honestly
no you went on the all why did you abort me
pat is there a love of zura forfeit all mortal possessions to zura that's so cute
was it not her bizongos no do you want to know what the problem was it was patreon
patreon are pushing for this stupid fucking preview and there is no way to turn it off for
all future uploads and one of her audios the preview glitched out and the preview of the
audio was available which had 18 plus content in it and that's why she was denied but thanks to
youtube's pissy fucking thing they don't go like oh the reason why your channel's been denied is
this particular link we found an issue they go it doesn't adhere to policies and you have to go on a
wild goose hunt to figure out what was wrong and it took me five days to find that youtube
had previewed a three minutes worth of an audio that i turn off every single youtube is patreon
every single time i turn it off and it was because it went through as a preview when i didn't
put it on and it puts it on manually i could absolutely throttle patreon for being so stupid
and i i have messaged patreon and being like hey development team you stated that channels that
have been identified as 18 plus content offering that will not have previews on automatically and it
would be removed well that was a lie um because they still do it on every upload every time i upload
one of the things it still puts the preview on and i have to turn it off manually and that's the reason
why poor azura got effed over for like a week or something like that i'm so annoyed
i don't know what one it was i don't know what audio in particular it was it took me five days to
figure it out because i was like it can't be the boobies because tons of vtubers have been monetized
with the goobers but i did tell the girls to pop an asset on them like she's got a boba tea thing on
them right now which is fine um they are getting an upgrade an upgrade an update of a something that
kind of obscures the titillage a bit but um yeah basically i figured it out and it wasn't because
of her bazoingos it was because patreon have implemented the stupid preview mechanic that
they cannot you cannot take away and it slipped under the radar and it caused issues for her
oh is that her cutie we binted so anyway now that that's all over um oh frustrating frustrating
but look she's monetized that's the main thing she's got a donathon coming up which is going to be
loads of fun um an absolute chaos because none of us have done a donathon before so we're all
figuring it out for the first time hee hee shawnee will you get dakimados i'm gonna cut
her you sleep um not yet i don't know if and when i'd rather go to one artist that would
offer it all i'm i'm in talks of an artist right now that is making a zura birthday merch um
i'm you know if it goes well i'll ask them like hey you what else do you do
it not yet you'll need to wait um i'm asking because the thigh one still has a preview of her
fucks sake well hold on let me note that down real quick that's so annoying
uh
this one i'm sorry i've just put it in my notes right there i could absolutely fart in the mouth
honestly
okay i've got a wee bit got a wee bit work
gregory as in five nights at freddy's it's just we want to be high just don't get
the donathon's gonna be fun i'm sure it'll be good for you all uh i'm nervous because i've
like never overseen one before um and as there is first and i'm like none of us have experience
with it so we're like doing it all together for the first time
oh my god my left ear's getting serenaded right now by her notification
maybe a cake mouse pattern i need a shibiraki
gregory you have to return power to the peace of play i wish i wasn't such a
scaredy cat because i would actually genuinely enjoy that game but i get terrified of games
like that i can't play them if i put the heart rate monitor on my heart rate would go over 200 i'm
not even kidding uh gregory you need to sneak into roxy's room to get her past through it i
i mean you need to escape i believe in you superstar you're my superstar scuffed streams
can lead to the best the left ear is less it just keeps going swap your headphones around
fuck it gives the right one some love
is it gonna work
she made a oopsie whoopsie she's allowed to go i'm back and you're still alive
also i won a game of poker and i won i guess you gave me some luck today
did you win actual money are you gambling real money gregory let me introduce you to the talking
cut-o-fishing him strongy don't you i need a strongy ducky plus a desk mat and mouse pat
fork you know i was starting small you know kind of like one new piece of merch out and see how it
goes because um uh i need to look into the girl's merchandise numbers and sales to know if we can
invest in more or not yeah strong maxing
everyone is getting a new piece of birthday merch when it is a birthday there's no that's
definitely happen where's fun time friday when you need him one for us and one for
we should all drop dakis at the same time and then release like hump hump audios hump hump
i love that word
strongy of them in real what we have 14 is that 14 300
1 500 bucks because my friend was being a dumbass in the gamble t he he wasn't counting car
oh well if you insist i'll put up a voucher stream after the
and so is there going to be any limited time merch no every market is super awesome to work with
there's no unlimited type of thing um
or i don't like the idea now now this is actually something that you guys will be able to answer
me hold on let me turn down his or his let me lower the volume in his or stream just so i can
get my ramble out um uh what was i going to say um so normally as a reward for anyone that
monetarily supports the girl it's like a voice pack gets sent out in emails if i'm correct
um if the donation is done through stream elements i think that is the only like
i've not because i've not done the task yet i can't fully answer you that question but i've
not done the task yet so i'll be able to know what it is soon to um um each ducky purchase
should come with an audio well yeah yes right
casinos be like counting cards is cheating my brother in crisis let's just know how odd's
working tracking your chances um yeah i i know more the agencies do it where it's like go purchase
this voice pack but i thought it would just be like a part of the patreon reward
sorry i've not thought about it yet but if you let me think about it what's going to happen is
azur is going to receive the drafted version and she'll show it on stream and then obviously you
guys can come back to me and marshmallow and be like hey strongy maybe this thing don't do that but
you can you can do everything else and then that'll that'll help point us in the right direction
you know she's like strongy strongy you know how you did that one thing not that thing but
everything else looks good okay that's what you're gonna do okay oh you want to sleep style audio
and an alternative audio with the ducky's okay i'll allow it each ducky should come with super
lub what wait does my brain just make that word out no it just says some and washing powder the
rifling had mind supplying opinions i look rough the learning never stops and you guys
i don't know if streamers don't want to admit this or something but you guys know better than me
so who am i to argue against the people you know who actually consume and support who who am i to
argue against the investors of vloor who am i to argue against the investors when the investors
know better in this circumstance this is the only circumstance where the investors know better
so who am i to argue okay a lot of times vtubers will put voice packs in a membership post link
to a google drive or whatever okay okay learning learning i'm learning like i was gonna um i got
some experience about what voice packs are like very thankfully because i'm helping out a friend
um yeah don't doubt the ink vester is real true i love how the feedback is actually yours
rather than just a lip service idea thank you you're welcome the ink vester is yes um we were
joking about like i'm investing in 3d and then it occurred to us that the because i do get investment
offers for the company and i'm like it turn your ass around out the door um but then we were joking
like oh wait the you know if you give money to your oh she does you're the ink vester for real
for real you know stroney gets in that discord with a girl no no if you're gonna groom the girls
do it right i thought about making that audio i'm not even kidding i know that sounds terrible
but i was gonna do an audio and be like where i i catch you trying to enter like the girls discord
and like i come to your house and then basically i go if you're gonna groom the girls do it right
and groom me first and then like you do what you want basically and then i gauge you and i'll be
like no no not like that like this i thought that would be next month's meta audio because that's
funny as fuck um yeah basically reverse like singing i thought it was funny just like if you're
gonna do it right and i'll be like now do what you did to me and i'm like no that's wrong
and then ac and then and then eventually you know what happened to be a naive hey hey hey
i never said i was a degenerate be both naive and a degenerate we need an audio with mummy and one
of the other girls mummy right gating the reefling and helping us i think that's probably gonna end
up a donathan reward with me um uh trying to enter the velar discord mods beat him with hammers
woo mummy right in there no Freudian slip stop stop stop Freudian slip and a mummy and mommy
hello daddy hello mom i'm your jerry bomb hello world i'm your wild girl i'm your jerry bomb
shawnee reeflings zura proud degenerate here
these ideas make me sad for the future oh yeah there's like none of them these behind the scenes
discussions are so fun you wouldn't hear them from a typical vtuber bro i literally cannot stop leaking
anything mildly fun i'm like oh my god you'll never guess what's coming up next and i'll be like
oh mercy has three new shores and like oh zura had four new shores like i'm just so excited every
time something happens i'm like oh emmy has two shores on the way that are really really good and
i think you guys are gonna like it like i just actually can't shut up like i genuinely can't
shut up okay i'm just excited i loved when you sang that song on your first korea i love it hello
world i'm your wild girl i'm your jerry bomb as there is good boy thank you for this wait i just
wanted to get a hold of mummy please understand reefling getting lost in the worst way possible
um you can't keep secrets you tell us everything well i've got one secret and i'm absolutely dying
to leak it but i i take solace in the fact that it gets leaked relatively soon it's not like a six
months away so i i take relief as a psychologist the phrase just because i'm naive doesn't mean i
can't be a degenerate look that should be a model honestly strony model found thank you dr uh look
edgar um literally i think that should be a model sorry i've just made management all right this
is a good discussion strony please keep this a secret strony oh my god reeflings y'all i never
guess what just happened in the meeting honestly me next karaoke stream unfortunately my voice needs
a motherfucking rest um i don't know for those of you who have access to patreon you may or may
not have been aware of how damaged my vocal cords were soft-spoken it's got a little dot um
but yeah the secrets of the veil of girls are actually getting 3d soon if not that they're all
flying a strony turn off the love oh interesting interesting interesting i think gimli and vigo
will be happy to see them i'm gonna make the same joke again strony has loose lips and the tightest
lips in the world will your donations have a fan meet and greet this tear oh my god i see someone
is like a the train conductor main would be ASMR booth oh i thought that was brian for me i was
like i don't see anything and got confused i was brian you're confusing me okay um azura would be like
i mean let's be honest we don't know what azuras would be nursing
hope your vocal cords feel better soon i bloody hope so too she says as she is out of water needs
to go make another cup of tea and hydrate and get a cola again did you mom mommy please rest your
voice i want to hear you sing all the songs are like up here if songs can just be down here
like at whole bit level like
then it goes up again
like everything needs to be deep i need man's songs okay
and boy that whole azura would be baiting bae on azura oh no she would mean yeah okay she would
do to you sorry don't a thun reward mommy records ASMR using a reefland body for noises oh my god
i think he would get executed like picked out one reefling he would get executed let's be honest
reeflands wouldn't tolerate them 20 foot azura with bean bag leg what is your scent 20 foot azura
with bean bag legs what are you communicating to us please elaborate on what on earth you are talking
about bean bag legs what you better start typing you better start explaining yourself a little
reefland so you can lay on them oh okay i get it now i get it now i understand i didn't understand
one earth you mean i thought you meant she would purposely become a giant test to get cellulite
in her legs to look like a bean bag and i was like where are you going with this
what on earth are you talking about is that how i sound
is that how i say earth to you a earth what on earth all right oh no wait a minute
what is that thing it's like air and iron what was someone post that thing where it's like
air and iron and iron urn or whatever the saying is someone post that there is no e kind of air
air air one air
iron and iron urn that's what i say i don't know how you say
iron iron and iron urn how you doing Aussie accent oh reporting live today we find ourselves in the
suburbs of melbourne while we are here we are whining in edgeville unfortunately the accent
is fucking impossible to mimic it's not that easy the best i can do is possibly the news anchor's
presentation kind of iron urners i said bot more accent i can only do australian news anchor
do you like amber yes i do i grew up drinking it so i can drink it no problem hello hello
oh shit went to sandra sully big sandra sully more like sully manikers sorry i don't know
mwah mwah mwah i'm drinking amber and i'm channelling sandra now
i wasn't starting to tell me the weather i wanted to do news anchor australian news anchor does
like a samar on you and next i'm going to take the ear cleaning tool and look after you like this
this we are going to place the tool in the ear cleaning canal
that's the best i can do just do scottish news anchor i don't even know what it's got oh what
is she drawing oh my god it looks like a demon oh no oh no he looks like a weird demon oh he's
got a weed juice pouch though that's cute okay run 13k
don't be momentary i don't know what scottish would sound like
good evening tonight's news
uh there's a yandere on the loose however it seems like the victims are leaving letter
saying they consented i don't know what a scottish thing would sound like quote from i
don't know no but what does the tv news anchor scottish version sound like i drink 500 cans of
pepsi max to do why pepsi max at least make it cola if you're gonna give yourself a heart attack
over it on tonight every right evening ladies and gentlemen tonight on the scottish news
someone got shanked in Glasgow again uh American tourists again have been reported across the
board for being too loud and being a bunch of numpties on the street uh someone has stolen
a cat which is causing a feud between two neighbors uh one is trying to change the name
of the cat via the microchip and its neck at the vets um as for the closing news we have today
um more condoms again were found in the river banks please we urge the public to stop
dogging outside and then littering your used johnny's into the river banks they are harming
the wildlife and introducing microplastics yet again please knock it off and that is the news
tonight with strongy like that's what you want scottish people have news anchor sin is in shambles
right now yandere audio where the listener resists their struggles are so immersion breaking like i
would never struggle kidnap me i'll write that how about i write that for mercy willing listener
i love the strong is that a natural problem over there um dogging yeah uh there's like condoms
like everywhere in parks uh down like down secluded looking areas or places you can hide
they're everywhere they are everywhere you will see more johnny's than you will see needles
in scotland have an opioid crisis so just to put things into perspective uh yeah
um is jim brown in scotch i couldn't answer that i'm very sorry i don't know who jim is big jimmy
then again who big jimmy is um they call condoms jimmies we call them johnny's i love the strong
accent yeah i need to do more strong i need to do strong accent is my oh so what you in for the day
oh you know feeling good and do like a nurse lease check a scottish nurse lease check oh what's
wrong you got oh dear oh dear okay i see your scalp is itchy right you just come you sit down on this
bench dear okay it's just me and you didn't you worry this stays between me you and your parents
no one's gonna find out about it and i'm gonna tell you this right now you're not the only one in
this school okay you're not the only one in this school that's got an itchy head okay that's why i'm
here that's why everyone's been called down to the nurse's office um so please didn't worry right
i'm just gonna take a look through your scalp darlin dinny please don't be embarrassed i know
it's the first it might be the first time you've had it but it's perfectly natural like that i'm
you like strong accent didn't know scott's like um like i'll be like
seeing those funny metal canisters around the footpaths aren't they called whippets or something
like that reefland's come in with seven broken arms and severe cranial trauma but the nurse just
wants to cuddle me some more i don't know about the scalp part but it's good to more
all right darlin okay oh dear right you do you yes i can see some eggs in your hair but it's okay
so what's gonna happen i'll talk you through it darlin okay i'm gonna comb through your hair
with my tools okay now these tools they pick up the lice and the eggs okay and i'm gonna do the best
i can right now okay and then you're gonna get sent home afterwards and what you're gonna tell
your pals if they're asking in the group chat you're just gonna say you've got a sore stomach and
you threw up um and what you're more or your dad is it more dad at home that look after you the most
it's mum okay mum is gonna buy you some shampoo okay you're gonna leave it on your head it's gonna
leave on your head for 15 minutes okay and what it's gonna do i don't know where i'm going with this
it's fucking just doing the live off the top of my head i don't know like i'm supposed to whisper oh
i forgot to say someone uh it is whippets i knew it i knew it's called whippets can't have lice if you
don't have hair oh okay alternative version oh dear you do have lice right time to go bald
and shave all your head off your head off all your hair off right there you go i fixed the problem
dear off you pop back to class don't worry no one's gonna know that you had lice even though you
came back bald incompetent like school nurse shaves you bald deal with lice ASMR or something
that's the script right there literally no head no lice literally without without smarted them
without smarted them my hair didn't deserve the creativity up with the hood
actually i'm gonna write that down that'd be a really funny short sorry uh like doing shorts
like that short fucking scottish oh my god my ink oh my god my ink and my pens actually go on
reefland i need your ink unironically okay oh tiddish nurse lice check short and then a dash
shave's head
just write all my notes down hair clipper ASMR gacha gazzle i used to cut uh i was going to hair
cutting through i was going to have eme and ic do banyural hair cutting sounds but like actually
hair cutting sounds so i'm gonna literally butcher my hair on their behalf love you eme love you ic
i'm literally gonna cut my hair to get real authentic sounds for you guys funny ASMR did you
make up to swap your head i just go off of what the reefland's telling me is a i'm i'm gonna be
honest uh i'm not the funny one it's actually you that's a funny one in this situation ink coming
right up yes mommy okay well done um i think i'm gonna have to scoot away to get a bottle of water
and very quickly and all that you could cut a wig you're a foley arse um i don't make them do any
of the sounds i don't want them to be stressed being like oh wait i actually have to do the
thing just like 1.2 million angst you left wait who for who i'm level 98 one more level how do you
be ahead of me i'm almost 97 imagine an ink cafe like we run it or you literally it's like a revolving
door of reefling and everyone gets ink a bottle of water shiny would you do a blooper reel for any
of the girls the girls i have told them so many times you don't have to edit out your mistakes
that's what the editors are for and they edit out their mistakes i have one mistake from mercy
um isi just sizing hers um because cars always go past isi's location there's always some
fucking piss ass revan car in the background she's like delivering the most delicate gentle beautiful
soul uplifting line and then
and she has to like sit and wait for it to go away like it's so annoying it is so annoying i would
absolutely like annihilate all cars if i can literally she'd be doing the cutest thing ever like
and snow buried i hope you're able to get all the sleep in me i know you're tired and i know
you try so hard for me like rough she records at like fucking midnight and there's still some
freaking bam in his car going by should i just left it in honestly here comes the beat
it's so frustrating it happens to me still like i used to have to wake up at 4 a.m to record
and then i used to have to wake up at midnight and then i'm kind of at the stage where i'm at like
9 p.m i can kind of record but there's like overhead flights and stuff because i live in the city
and it's fucking planes in the background and shit i'm like fuck off get over the
sky it's bedtime go to sleep like the the planes need to sleep as well go to sleep
um i haven't caught much at isaac because of her time i saw the dj stream and she has good music
she loves her dj stream uh me complimenting the dj streams also me uh guys we need to
peel back on the the dmca and the taking down streams
my yander stalker can't stop beatbox and asmr i don't know
i don't think any of us know how to beatbox
how is is she bluetoothing that to the computer how is she sending that to the computer i just
realized there's no cable is there i doesn't look like there's a cable
need to build yourself and oh honestly real i'm sure i want to hear my heartbeat as i deliver the
bluetooth pen beatboxing is just making noises confidently
is that what you wanted you've been playing for a while right maybe i will go get some food okay
scottish last tries beatboxing asmr singing the entire friday night osd
i'd never played that game i only saw like twitter footage of it because hatsumiku got modded
into it and she was like yeah like that's a stretch in water time uh
you should do an nnn art or you'll all go modest and wholesome for a month
ah actually there's a mini event oh it's not really a mini event there's really not much
effort it's not like a big thing no we're not no i've got i've got my personal plan for nnn
i'm gonna be very tired by the end of it but yeah oh she leaking
many events because of weekend no it's not that it's slightly different
it's slightly different i'm not sure what the people's reaction is gonna be but they
didn't really need to react it's just something that i think uh i would like to ask the girls to
do and i don't think the girls are gonna say no when i explain why we're gonna do it
you i won't survive either modest or wholesome terrible teasing and no exception no not at all
right can i very quickly go grab some drinky poos because i'm all out of water
should i need like no income for 30 days more like income 30 days a day
hmm i was gonna do my descriptor and then i was gonna do daily um eights for me but not for you
so i'd let you have access to the audio
like on the alternative twitter
but you're not allowed to that's the challenge
didn't someone die and didi didi shoni you should learn boxing that way if someone
you can punish mommy are you gonna make us participate i mean i'm gonna encourage you
to join me an edge bill but basically every time i finish i still say nope not for you
and then those of you who lose get an extra punishment
and it will be provided in an audio the punishment and you have to do as i say or else
there's no fun in it if you don't play along at home
so cruel do it please get some water okay okay okay i get water
um
that's this is how i perish oh one of the oh what she don't know
one of the bleeding hearts how do we after one it
so you can't be okay
okay
where's the bubble get some water you know what nevermind bring on
is it bad for the tentacle i didn't know that hold on don't need to do some research
before i like literally destroy some pintages i promise you my goal is actually not to destroy
anything of that nature
i love when she says she's gonna grab water real quick and then get us for another yeah
so what i'm an edge bill edge and rinse it
again right right right right i'll go get water
or uh you guys with that stinker she's the stinker okay
is she drawing a pot from elden ring is there a plate elden ring is there a play called she was
talking to me about um college and i was like fucking i'm gonna play college
no don't make me go i want you back oh baby i want you back here
yeah i'm just gonna grab a bowl of water maybe a kind of
the
you can't kill me in a way that matters monkey is i'm trying to kill you
wish i make you you know kind of lose your your inhibitions little be a bit feral you know like
yeah stroney you're a thirsty little forever go water yourself before i alluded to the comment
are you peeing on me did someone draw something where i got peed on hello am i missing it on lore
or is that a reference to that one meme that's like i'm a sunflower
no tell me feral stroney comfort what not you but it was a comic for years oh the silent
sorry sorry i was like wow
i've heard that being an edgeville in runescape is actually not harmful to a tentacle only in
super rare cases so really it's luck of the luck of the spawn is she drawing alexander
from memory and elden ring it looks like she is is she drawing on him
is that is that kpop on the back of her phone shit she's fired
should have known it should have known shocking behavior shocking behavior
well
it's for the tomato sauce
pee and the tentacle the tent itself is only just a profile picture oh you should have a profile
picture one god i fucking wish i could do shit like that i've seen ac do some of them and i'm like
i kind of want to do that but i actually don't know how to draw
and i'd feel bad that couldn't do everyone all at once like what do you mean i can't do all like
fucking 800 members oh i thought i just dropped coal everywhere but only flashed a little bit
i don't know why i cannot control myself easily it seems like i'd be incapable of dealing
with like my hands and stuff
unfortunately i'm getting arthritis in my hands thanks to genetics
um i'm not i'm not developing it yet but it's gonna happen and i'm wondering i don't know what's
going on i can't seem to drink properly around them 12 ever profile picture drawn stream insert that
gift for that guy that's like spamming stuff down literally me water turned into cola to the
drum dimension it's as over banished to the shadow realm
oh okay if i could do what your profile picture already is then there might be hope
i don't know but if it was like create a totally new profile picture that's different
oh she can't draw did she end up no i think you need to draw like mask
but some stuff can't draw real new people's face how's the king good looking it is 96
and we have 13 000 more wings to go and we are done truly and wholeheartedly done so
we are currently watching azura and her membership doodling
oh my god she's just sph experience i can't believe it azura you would make fun of your
creations like that you created them that i'm fucking me
tenor stream maybe i don't i actually don't know how long we've been going for
my obs crashed at one point sadly so i actually don't know how long we've been going for
um shan't be daring to open up my schedule again like excuse me for trying to
about eight hours okay all good
okay i think what we'll do is we'll do a wrap up stream at a later date most likely in three weeks
time and in the wrap up stream we'll do 99 runescape we'll do sonic heroes we'll finish off team
chaotic and we'll do a little to the left and that should be roughly a six to eight hours
day i don't know i feel like sonic heroes isn't gonna take me that long i have no idea how if we've
got another four hours of wine four times two is eight so we'll have roughly five thousands left over
if i don't get too distracted just an equal bit distracted yeah just an equal bit yeah
we're allowed to be distracted i do really it's crazy seeing i'm wondering if i could
commit me to do draw on handcam streams as well i'm just so i just adore drawing like the the talent
the dedication no it's not talent sorry i was it's the dedication to learn the craft and i just
find it like so crazy that like i don't know the artist can just go for it like they can send it
hmm thanks for the stream enjoy your lecture thanks for hanging drawing streams are really hard
to do a lot of artists don't like doing them even if they're good at art yeah but get streets that
live in our 50s so be careful yes guys do warn me because i cannot see how long i've streamed for
so as we approach you know give me like a one hour timer warning and then i'll take it from there
oh it's the same profile the bleeding part
do you do any marrow readings uh there's such an interesting look into the minds of these things
yeah i do i read them earlier i'm gonna read them after this is iris stream uh i'll read them
marshmallows again and just do some yapping i mean have a sock yapping at all at this point
no i haven't um started streaming eight hours ago okay
um 12 hours would be 4 p.m yes actually yeah yeah we can just do it like that 4 p.m
oh no wait i have less than four hours with you
oh no
no
wait am i being pepega no i do i only have three and a half hours with you
oh that made me sad i wish i didn't look at that oh oh well like after iris done her a beautiful
doodles i i will look at marshmallows again and we'll yap a bit marshmallows okay only three
you've been streaming for roughly nine hours
i'm sorry reeflings i shouldn't have pointed it out i've upset us all
i've upset myself and upset you no one throw up though keep the sick in your mouth i swallow it
again okay don't don't throw up on yourself oh my god i no wait we should do bath time asmr
but this time the audio isn't blown out like i don't blow out the audio i'm fair she's leaving
us on 3.5 hours no no no just the nausea more just the nausea more don't don't be sick put it back
inside shawnee you silly give her even with us for eight hours already
can't stop won't stop um yeah i will most likely sleep after the stream and when i wake up
i'll do the sage collab and then i will record the missing audio for this month although actually
the script is very broken i might actually do the groom me properly one
it may for me mentally it may actually be a lot easier for me to quickly swap it to that one
then i'll do that one next month like as the next upload she's leaving us in an amount of time
greater than the average speech of her stream stop that's funny as anything as funny as anything
now i'm sad and nauseated no no they're just having fun Jesus okay it's not over we can still
enjoy the time we have left just prepare to head back into the trenches i mean technically if i stop
at 4 p.m i'll see you in 12 hours and we're playing the link as long as the emulator work
oh wait oh wait no it's fine i'm allowed to say emulator it's dead media anyway i'm allowed to
say it hey i just have to reapply her patches when she goes offline true 12 hours no well actually
no it won't be 12 hours because the pregnancy ASMR is going to go up at midnight which means
four hours before my usual stream time you're gonna see pregnant ASMR on my channel i said what i said
okay i said what i said yeah i'm pregnant ASMR well not me you're not getting me pregnant
they're pregnant you in my tongue and you can hear my heart you can actually hear my tongue
as same we're strong as offline is the same we get to digest i was gonna say do you not get
i don't know is my endurance not too much have you ever noticed that a tengu japanese demon
looks like a jew just saying smiley face where did that come from wonka wonka wonka wonka
processing processing thanks for the tip i'm not sure where that one came from
wait a minute i'm just checking the comment on my channel someone's like hard core because i
squeeze the microphone in between the ears
oh
you
why
oh he's getting hit by it that's so cute
that's so cute
is it bad that i actually already have eaten calamari
i actually have eaten calamari before and it's pretty delicious
it's yummy it's deep fried calamari oh then again it's deep fried and i'm Scottish so
that's probably why i like it do you know in Scotland we have deep fried pizza and it's delicious
okay calamari is yummy it's like what i said
she's gonna eat us oh i wanted to do the vor ASMR but i don't even know if you
have a love like vor anymore i was gonna swallow you and i was gonna get an artwork of you looking
like ah going into my mouth and i'm like
deep fried pizza um yeah calamari is good wait i'm calamari
it's vor bad it's over wait hold on let me check i'm gonna type on youtube
you're gonna type on youtube you come here youtube vor ASMR let's see what comes up
there's anything two months ago comes up
i need i need new to prove that it doesn't get taken down
oh there's a quite a few things i've been up for recently i guess it's not been completely
banned lady Demetrius eats you whole
will you be showing alt twitter any love yes um i unfortunately due to my dad visits have fallen
behind i basically lost two weeks and a couple of days progress on literally everything everywhere
and the girls are kind of waiting on me to do some stuff for them as well and
and then i had to issue with the script writer they embarrassed me and and it's kind of caused
a big backlog of issues and they are getting results they are getting results why is she drawing is
that cockroach is that is that pokemon no i can't be a pokemon i don't like him is it
um schlorp your giggle stick yeah basically um i do plan on using my alt twitter like
exponentially very soon like as i said for 20 000 subscribers i'm gonna stick a picture up on it
and all that oh my god my feature bird she's got skin okay i'm not very i'm not very uh i'm not
the friendliest them cuttlefish diets vary depending on where in the ocean they live but they commonly
feed on mollusks shellfish fish octopus worms and even other cuttlefish okay thank you their natural
predators include dolphins sharks large fish seals sharks i'm collabing with a shark the fuck
sharks eat me i'm collabing with a shark vtuber monkey is sharks eat me
oh no i'm gonna have to tell her go have to tell her that i'm gonna have to break the news sir
can't wait to see a new caller it's still not being shipped out yet it says it's in production
i will be i will be fair and say that it is like a moan paw like custom thing it's not like a mass
produced thing so you know i'll let them cook sharks can eat me gonna be the sub next we'll have
cuttlefish eat other cuttlefish you want to get eaten by me
uh
shoni's gonna leave us because she'll be eaten by a shark
what is that why is she drawing that looks crazy
are you squidding me right now this was her drawing my profile pic on youtube it's just
an animal android from an old live action japanese show called kikida kikida she's a
small echidna named tiny spiny hence the name oh you named after that
ah thank you cartoffel doom and tiny spiny brine said it right so committed to the
architect lifestyle she put herself on the menu oh my god you know how normally it's like eat sushi
off of the body of women i eat sushi off of the reef link and then i lick your tentacle just to
make you know that i might take a bite and then you go and you went and went i love that you're
smaller than me so you sit down you're so easy to play with and do what i want
mommy you're making me imagine i'm volunteers at the dessert table
look i like my hyper obscure live action
strongy i'm having a full body shut down after the comment about sushi are you scared am i making
your knees noble you can have no i'm it's my hyper fixation i will love it please eat me strongy
moment having a big belly fill of reeflings and she's done with four i'm 185 centimeters okay
and i'm a hundred and fucking sixty two or something i can't remember how long
am i six two or one five two and i'm still bigger than you lure wise okay get rekt
strongy uses her mouth to new or bad read no i wouldn't do that oh my god i need that time
no use to others being smaller than you no you're not allowed to be bigger than me that's a little
good
sharks are the trash cans that they will eat anything i didn't know that i thought goats were
like the indestructible thing that eats anything strongy six but no i'm definitely a six two juice
i'm like i'm pretty small i didn't realize how small i was until like everyone grew in high
school and i stayed the same height and i was like hmm something's not going on here what's happening
i don't know how little we're gonna get it and seagulls are ear trash
oh i like it so smooth buttery smooth
ah i keep doing that too early i want to get maybe i don't know how little we're gonna get it
and seagulls are ear trash she be posted her uh oh yeah i think all the girls got
access by management um so yeah
don't call a zero a trash oh yeah she's a goat oops but she's goddess or fertility kind of goat
strongy's the perfect size to sit on a big reefland's lap
i thought you're gonna say something else strongy's the perfect size to sit on our reeflands
we're at 12.7 thousand wanes to go
no reeflands is the perfect size for strongy to sit on too yeah see see see that's what i saw
she does like to eat though that's good i'm glad
a belly full of meat and a big sleep what more do you need in life
love me love me fertile goddess of fertility love me
love me oh wait hold on love me go love me
love me do do do love me rabbit love me
pull a bit and love me and ery shimpish that took me so long to come up with
that was like so hard to go through and my head was like being like a what
again reeflings are for a reason i i really wish i could somehow order order a custom
because if i could get one made in the image of you i would never fucking take that thing
sorry i wouldn't
let me go let me go fish at the eye table shimplash shimplash
i don't know if there's anything that does that maybe ate see i don't know
ate see had some unique things on it i also found a figure that looks like
what you would have technically and i really want to get it i really want to get it but
i'm going to have to wait until my doing is on like a good grill to get it but it looks like
your tentacle and i want it but i have to wait
and it's paralyzing as well like unironically
but i'd probably get like one green version and one paralyzing version
i don't know on your throne i don't know
i don't like using things like that i think it'd be funnier if it was like a doughnut on
go and be like because i called it the strongy figurine wink wink in the go what you've already
planned out your doughnut yes i planned it out months ago i've got a load of stuff to add to
it now that i can have your guys's inputs well
oh you've seen that to me zero
what happens if a shark tries to eat a veflin we literally gang up and perish the shark
you guys are not allowed to get eaten without my permission do you understand
you're not allowed to do anything without my permission not to breathe without my permission
well that's such a mess what did i talk about what
oh yeah
azuras is azuras is on the way i think shibis might have already been delivered in her updated model
uh thanks for me the only stomach will be in azuras oh do you accept your fate
i mean hers is so she didn't know at the time but hers is a veil so you can actually still see
that and it's the same on shibi as well you can actually still see it it's just less out there
remember us wreathlings have hypnosis powers to imagine a bunch of wreathless hypnosis
hypnosis strobing a shark probably give it a say yes you guys do have self-defense mechanisms so
you're not as easy access to others as you are to me
you protect us from the bully so you can bully your tentacle later exactly literally you nailed
it on the head that's exactly what i was saying just jump the shark like a jiu-jitsu kaisen episode
what hydration check wreathling i'm my i'm gonna be honest my throat's starting to feel it now and
i'm like oh that's not good that's not good that's not supposed to happen yet death by brain aneurysm
stony's model under recreate reactive condition could also cause flashbang
she wants her turtleneck all over the school okay i like that that's a good idea sorry but
actually it's a good idea to learn so see you need jumping
mercy really did a good job on those alternative designs i thought there was two
i
i love mercy's designs to associate the warrior
strony that wreathling is my victim wait with this lore does that mean a certain popular
vtuber with a shark theme would be the one you could dome strony no it's it's the doggie dog world
out there so we'd have to evade the shark to evade why is everything that comes out there
is master's tax it's her voice i don't know how she does it because it it does like when i do it
you don't listen to how like crackly my voice is when i do it i'm like but hers is so effortlessly
just the perfect like oh you know hi strony has a go round and we are your friend we're on 96 we're
about to go on 97 we've got 12k wines in the bank we're watching azura up here we're watching an azura
bod watching her monetization together and it's linked in chat if you want to watch along at the
same time that is a timestamp we're just reacting to our like doodling people's things because i never
got a chance to see it or we can trap the shark
boom yeah we're at 12.5 okay um if i've got another three hours we could get it down to
like 6k wines roughly i think that's good that's what three hours so we'll finish as there is
vaude and then i will ramble as i always do on marshmallow afterwards and we'll just ramble until
the end of stream but it was really nice being able to watch my gen mates like this was so chill but
like a good like the nice chill where it's like oh you know it's very nice survival of the fifth
you prefer shark or now when you don't do anything to the shark you chew bar
she's focusing i can see her thinking via her v to her model you can see in her we eyes that she's
thinking i'm her daughter was it cheese from us today's been so nice it's a very cozy day this is
like the kind of the introduction to the more endurance streams um as i said we've got legal
lord of the rings i'd show it but my obs might crash again yeah because i've got too many things
capturing too many things at once believe it or not um but i um
but what
uh oh no don't fall asleep now come on we're doing so well don't get tired now wake up it's the first
of the month don't don't get it now don't get it twisted now it's not the time to get tired right i'm
gonna i'm moving my legs up and down on the chair okay i'm like kicking my feet out in front of me
i'm not falling asleep okay i refuse i will grind until the last second of the stream
what what in the what in the book you want to do with it mama okay
i don't want to fall if you can't oh the mouse is in the cheese because i think crazy how she can
just do that from her head well if you want to see a mouse from me like the best you're getting is
wake up grab a brush put on a little bit makeup oh yeah today was awesome because i get to be in
the full livestream and i got my first car today and one gamble against two idiot pals jesus
i don't know what this week no i don't want to get epi i've had cola i'm having another cola i'm
having a water voice is getting a wee bit mmm it's getting a little bit mmm you know what i'm saying
the same voice is getting it's wavering
i love the noises that zara makes she's just on some other stuff
yum yum yum yum you have had water i'm gonna slip slip a sip more cola because it's got caffeine in it
which will trick my body into staying awake longer
literally me whenever someone goes no it's oh it's fine it's fine okay
it's getting a little hoarse call me a pony because my voice is getting a little hoarse
new speaking of pony i don't know what shit emi's cooking this stream i saw a glance of what her
thumbnail was for one of the streams uh uh hello hr i'd like to report a crime
i'm committed by my little sister and her friend don't think you're getting out of this one as well
she's in level two
chunky breath
uh oh what the sigma literally me every time it prompts me that i need to take a break
literally me uh what the sigma i just can't tell how long it's over the speaker
i guess it's the fact i'm a weasel and for you i'm gonna go to sleep rest well we flings
for anyone who needs to rest or get some work done or prepare themselves some food please don't
worry i'm still gonna be here i'm just bouncing myself on purpose up and down to keep myself awake
because i got a wave of tiredness and i'm like no no because i normally go for an afternoon nap
and i think my body's like afternoon nap and i'm like no uh not today um and then body's like
but normally afternoon nap but oh no not right now kind of busy kind of busy
but when the body uh what are you bouncing on like i'm bouncing on the chair
rockabye cut of fish on the tutor you don't mean put me asleep i'm i'm if i go off now
i still have another six hour stream to wrap up the rest of the wine i want to get at least like
i could potentially get six k wine which equals six uh three hours and then i'll finish off sonic
hero's chaos which will be like another hour possibly um and then little to the left dlc
i have no idea how long that's gonna be i assume if it's a dlc it's actually shorter than the base game
and the base game was like just two oh 97 popped 97 97 it just popped it just popped
congratulations congratulations it just popped it just popped yay we got 97 only tons more
eggs pizza go wow this isn't so crushing all it's about the same length as the base game
oh okay okay the that chair my name sounds like a great that so we're doing it we're doing it
we're doing it we're getting there we're getting there we're getting there pop pop pop pop pop
i will send it with these wines i will dump all of these on the grand exchange and they'll
sell instantly because i'm not the only person that's leveling up wine well what should i know
did the gloves work with the ipad oh they do they do they must be like
my pfp
pfp
congrats just two more look shit nori god damn we're addicted to this game
that's right i'm allowed to call you out on it
i'm sorry i never want to go offline but i want to look after yourself with what bed if you are easy
what i'm gonna do is this will be probably and i did kind of learn my lesson
before my dad came over i didn't realize how bad i was treating myself terms of health when it
came to the endurance streams and stuff because it made me realize that um like oh no i've not
been doing well so i don't think we're gonna do too many like mega 12 endurance streams except for
elden rings probably the next serious endurance stream we're gonna do and we're just going to
do it back to back until we're done so you know i mean just two more real just two more the first
thing that goes when you have sleep deprivation is the ability to tell the lack of sleep is affecting
i don't know i've got about five thousand left before maxing out oh my god reflect i'm jealous
can we swap accounts temporarily for like no particular reason because i think i would actually
make it if i had 5k to go
see i wish i could draw like how does she know to put like a little ridge in the bottom of the
shoe how does she know she's so smart she's so smart like how do you know these things
elden ring yes big big elden ring i'm sure all the reeflings have really completed the dlc
so they can carry me through it all now surely and i'll greet you next time with the skills
take care and cheer you on for the final stretch now you would cheer for the final stretch wouldn't
she pulled up their accounts and got the enlarged profile but did it not summon
did it no summon
can you be elden ring entirely uh yeah with the reeflings though what do you mean that is
cheesing if i bring people in every fight uh no uh but uh the developers didn't want the game to
be played this way uh then why did they put multiplayer in it where you can gang up with
two of your pals um oh but that's why they force invaders on you um i don't know maybe they should
realize that people just want to hang out and play a game together that's really well made
and elden ring fits that but they instead and jam in the fucking invader aspect
sorry you should actually see my face when i'm making these arguments like i literally put my
hand up like that and actually and all that like as soon as i get a 3d model it is over for you guys
to understand how much i'm moving about and like doing weird stuff on my hand so starting does at
least 150 damage before the boss exactly that bow and arrow that crossbow that i've not levelled up
yet that's right it's over for you as soon as the boss sees me holding the rapid fire crossbow
they know it's over even though we're getting absolutely shagged by the snake guy um we uh
actually using intended game mechanics is cheating real and true actually using the summons in the
game that the developers provided for the player is cheating what you ought to repeat that one for
the one for those of us in the back using game mechanics is cheating uh curious take
you might as well be a monkey because curious take george get it because there's a monkey called
curious george uh stroney is an elite gamer exactly legendary skyrim proof is on stream
streamed it a while ago oh we need to go back to scarring for full achievement actually i
didn't say how much gamer score i need to start playing xbox games for getting that gamer score more
if it's cheating i'd rather her curse you bail curse a curse upon your houses i even remember how
curse you bail goes curse you bail okay it's like two it's three minutes it's one minute long
oh no that's a parody hold on wait where's it hold on hold on
hold on a minute that's just a reef one hold on that one was just a reef
oh but you can't hear it because i'm fucking muted the desktop you absolute five head
oh hold on that's a sir hold on is there
oh there are incarnate life in me yet there is a life in me yet
i'll face upon your heart i love that so good actually so good
curse you bail
with a hail of harpoon
yeah see my voice is all scratched i can do the scratchy
that v went for it wonder what that mpc doing now i don't know don't ruin it i don't know yet
i don't know yet no tell me no spoilers because i'm not finished the dlc because you guys are
holding my hand to the dlc
what's she drawing now an angler fish i swear if that's the angler fish for jane two's suggestion
someone's getting their eyelashes farted on
ASMR reeflings are bailing your again
curse you reeflings a plague will both your houses
he's probably fine he had to get fine
i shall face upon your heart
what is he drawing which what's he drawn what's she drawn
e wait was that someone's profile page someone paid 15 dollars to get that drawn
she i'm doing a drawn stream tomorrow the fuck i'm buying i'm buying my figurine right now
she did you make 98 no no yeah i'm 97 i'm you're too quick for me you're too quick normally i'm
the quick one but i'm 97 and i have 12 000 left i will most likely be roughly 6000 left by the
endurance stream a plague of both your houses
are where are all the circling reeflings uh there's a reefling there and that's a reefling
there but there's not many today because it's um uh oh you know you don't have to be in game and so
yeah and it's not the last stream i have to do another stream to do it i'm a reefling yeah see
they're all reefling
did we count nori as a reefling see look we're head banging oh yeah i'm a
i logged out of runesgate so i could watch the watch along stream yeah who goes there identify yourself
stop someone was like you got uh i can't know i don't know where the the comment was but someone
who's like you were mentioned in a burping a vtuber thing and i'm like where i can't find it but i
think you know someone's been sharing my burps that one person is gonna go ape shit when i release
my burping ASMR that's all i'm gonna say they are gonna lose their mind when i release that
music makes you lose control music makes you lose control let's go
course you're reefling
of course you're reefling i will soon face upon your tentacle mark my words you too shall no passion
ah
like that's how i would do it kind of like that uh where the voice is like really broken and jagged
like that
please do feast upon them feast upon them
nice with them i'm gonna main break them chesker you're welcome
it's hot one that's the kind of like feralness you want when it comes to the r time
i feel like that would scare you if i was literally on top of you like
like would that not terrify you would that don't make you scared of me
oh
the brave reefling that's the point i would that please oh my god that's the kind of feral
i won oh my gosh this reefling fears nothing i can go feral
okay okay i'm learning i'm learning that's the point of having a scared bow and arrow
doesn't the blood go away if you're scared or is that not how it works
reeflings fear nothing from mommy so do your best take me take me
you're the first i'm gonna take out my rage on
oh
did you know that fear is the top shelf afro dzik oh mercy modest mentioned
do do do do do do do
oh my god mercies 60 subscribers away from 10k i'm going to cream my crackers
would anyone else like a custard cream for no particular reason mercies about to hit 10k
Mercy's about to hit 10k! Mercy's about to hit 10k! If you're not subscribed to the
Yandere, please consider dropping a cheeky subscription even if you can't
catch her streams. You can still have a giggle at her short. She has absolutely
fantastic stories in her shorts and she is so charming by default. It is lovely.
For a Yandere, she is very pawn and absolutely adored. So even if you can't
catch her streams live, you can always check out her shorts for a quick giggle
or re-watch a VOD if that tickles your pickle.
So yeah, don't be afraid to do it.
At the end of every week each one of us becomes free. Tonight the DJ makes us move.
Another sweat drops from the roof.
Anyway, that is... I love my Pongkai. Stop! I literally love that emote, that new one where
she's got like a star and it's like Pong! Pong!
For Bleeding Hearts, as there is a new emote came, but I think one of them is
actually needing an edit. The emote artist kind of let the ball slip, but I'm not
really in a position to go to anyone else at the moment.
I'm not... I'm happy that I got the work I asked for. I'm not exactly over the moon
at the price increase and then the kind of sloppiness of the second batch.
And I'm about to order a third batch because the girls have extra
slots.
But hopefully the third batch comes out a bit better because...
The pot emote is cool, dude.
Mercy's adorable. Yes, adorable yandere, that's the way...
That is definitely the way to describe it. Oh, she's doing a quick chee-bee.
Oh, she's doodling. She's doodling. Look at her go... Look at that speed!
It's about speed, it's about power. We stay humble, we devour, put in the work,
put in the hour, and take what's ours. Wait, do they do a price increase again?
So, originally the emotes were $10 per emote and I was like,
fuck me, that's some good quality. And then I come around for batch too
and it's now $25 per emote and I'm like, right, that's fine
because, you know, understandable economy's gone in the gutter because I
want official emote. And then that's fine and all, but then
we had quite a few issues like they gave.
It's just kind of silly stuff, like they sent back an emote they already made of
Emi, they randomly just made her an emote we never asked for,
but she actually already had that emote. So it was like, bro, if they drew the
wrong emote, can you at least draw one that she doesn't have? That would be great.
Like, because we could have got a free emote XZ.
Azura has the best laugh, Stroni has the best accent,
Mersi has the best laugh, Shibi has the best means,
AC has the best music, and Emi has the best comp option.
Yeah, her Azura is kind of... But anyway, I'm going to order their third batch now.
And just take it from there, because obviously unless the girls like have a
massive event that would increase their emote slots
significantly, I don't really think there's going to be too many new emotes
after this third batch. You know, unless like one of the...
I don't know, if an oiler really comes along then that's a bit different.
Are you still streaming? I worked a full shift, plus a bit of overtime.
Do you get paid extra for the overtime at least?
Remember to hydrate and enjoy your 30-minute post-work shit.
I'm so fucking happy we discussed that.
I done goofed, everyone point and laugh. I don't know much about this stuff,
but 10 bucks is the normal price for an emote.
It kind of goes a bit higher than that.
It's a bit different. Like one artist was like 50 per emote and I'm like
steady on. Let's not be around this.
We are now in the nine hour mark. Okay.
And the E. Oh, was the E a mistake? That's even funnier.
Sorry, that's the one brand for a zero. The E was a mistake.
The E was a mistake. Increase by 150, it turns out the two dollar
two-year emote being the gift is here with a secret genius.
You get 2.5 times as many gifted per dollar compared to the normal five
but one more slot.
Yeah, yeah, I completely planned that out.
Yeah, thought it through. Got the team to approve that.
Yep, that was completely planned and thank you everyone who has ever gifted
memberships to myself or any other girl.
I did not plan it like that. Technically we just passed the nine hour mark.
I'm trying to head truly.
Hydration check with water darlin. Oh, shit, fuck.
Okay, iPur, thank you for the 10 gifted memberships. Holy shit.
And congrats to those who cut it with your face. I can't really do the high
pitch right now because my voice is getting very strange.
What do you mean talking non-stop for nine hours is bad for your vocal cords?
What are you talking about? I'm serious.
Congrats to those who cut it and thank you iPur for
the gifted memberships. I appreciate it. I'm sure the girls all
appreciate it equally. Anyone who's ever gifted
has been a fantastic help and especially for those who are looking to move
out, Kohai and Azura I think are like if they could move out right now
their content creation would just like go in an upwards motion.
Still great. You're actually just so good at dodging. You're literally neon from
the matrix. I'm sorry but you are.
I love mummy yapping, yeah. A D1 yapper? What's a D1?
I'm getting nervous. What's a D1?
What's a D? I was not ready for Unleashed Mercy. She got you gifts.
I can't believe that the corruption arc is real. Division one, day one.
Oh my god, is that the hit game? Was it Tom Clark's Division One or something?
What was that game called? I think I'm a brains. My brain's short circuiting.
Oh no, this can't be. You can't believe it. Nine hours?
Thanks for the gift. Division one is the highest rank of college sports in
USA. Okay, I didn't even know you had
fucking divisions. You got like a fucking diamond rank as well.
Masters. Top 500 rank. Oh, big Tom Clancy.
Tom Clark. Look, look. Clark is a really good shoe shop, okay?
If you just want nice school shoes, just go there.
I have a really sad story about a shoe shop, that story.
I'll tell it another time. I didn't want to depress you though.
Did anyone want to bomb you there? Oh, is that A.C.?
Is that A.C.?
Is this supposed to be A.C. Call?
Is this supposed to be mommy A.C.? Truly.
I might have been prepared to go and it's just an anime girl that looks like A.C.
In Azura Stream.
You check if your count is a brand account.
Division one means you are at the top of the game at yapping.
How dare you. Professionally yapping you.
It's not a brand account check to be for you. You're just really good at dodging
then, I'm sorry, but you might as well sign up to play dodgeball because
you'd already be ranked one. Easy peasy one, squeezy.
The classic game, Tom Clark Splinter Cell. Stop, okay.
What was that game that was shooting with portals?
It was like a shooter game and you could make portals.
Split, portal? Split, portal? Split, something?
Split. It had a good premise. No, no, no. It's split gate. That's it. Split gate.
I had like you could kill people in it. Not, not portal. Split gate. Sorry, I was
talking about split gate. It was called with portals basically.
I wonder, did that game succeed? Is it still
successful? Is it still good? I played it when it
came out, but unfortunately because of the debuff of being a wham and I couldn't
wrap my head around the portals properly so I used to just focus on shooting
only and I was like, I might as well just sit and play college at you.
That's right because I'm not doing it properly. It didn't pop off like it needed
to. Oh that's such a shame. They're making a second one though.
I just feel like it's so much like, you need to use your mind so much.
But they're redoing it's art style curious. It was more like Halo's though.
Like 18.
There's uh Chance, I absolutely rune strong in a match. It's like great without
none. Um, what was...
My online handles are different everywhere for safety and I never
identify myself if I'm playing a game.
Um, like, I don't, it's just too much. Like my names are
scarred up. So many like different online game names.
And you would never know what it's mean, so...
Yeah, right. But there is a possibility that uh you got teabagged by me.
So yeah. I was good at the kills. I kept getting shot in the back at unexpected
portals and my brain just couldn't process the
sounds of the game either. Like I was really struggling to adjust.
Like I think I gave Valorant like a couple of days
and I really struggled to get used to the like the surround sound
of like here in an anime to the left. Like footsteps are so loud in Valorant.
Totally not strong as 69x0x0. When did you play Dead by Daylight?
Oh, I am an, I am a back in my day in Dead by Daylight.
Uh, you know, slugging was a thing. I don't think it's a thing anymore.
Um, you wouldn't have uh known
me but I, I, you play, I did play Overwatch. I don't play it anymore,
unfortunately. Tons of years in it. Apparently they're
bringing back 66 in Overwatch. I'm not sure how much I believe it.
I'll believe it when I see it.
Right pointing finger, left pointing finger. The jettier, the better.
Scottish say follow politics, let's go. I don't like Valorant if I want to play
Valorant and go for CS though. Wait, no! Valorant's not like CS though.
Slugging still happens. Overwatch killed it. They said they're in testing because
they're shifting the meta around or something.
Ugh, I don't know what's going on. Overwatch, my beloved. I don't know
what happened to you. Apparently there's a new healer though and I
have to admit I do like playing healers in video games.
I don't care if it's stereotypical. Strongly you're such a girl playing the
healer. I like playing the healer. I like the stress of
keeping everyone alive. Sorry, I do. I like that kind of stress of
being like, haha, I made you feel better in the game.
Okay, I don't care and I have to admit, the new character Juno has me
interested in potentially installing the game again.
But I wouldn't subject you guys to it on stream so don't worry before you're
like, hey, Overwatch stream, I will not subject you to it.
But I don't know if Juno's unlocked or if it's behind the battle pass because
I heard there was a big controversy
of like
she censored that, right?
I just saw that in the corner of my eye. She censored the fuck out of my eye.
They removed the healers at the battle pass in a while.
I only play tank. I like the mental damage.
Okay, I might unironically give Juno a shot. Apparently she's like an
all healer. She's like Ana where she can heal and
damage. You don't have to go between it. I'm not going to lie. Juno might drag me
in again a little bit, but you won't know.
And before I develop a new voiceline thanks to Overwatch too.
I better not. No more voiceline.
That was manual. I played a bit of Juno.
She's actually pretty fun.
E is a speed boost like Lucio and they're always an AOE that heals
increases or damage. Oh, I like that.
Oh, it's almost like an offensive healer. Like let's get in there, boys.
I like that. I like that. Stop it. You're gonna pull me in.
Don't pull me in at Overwatch again. I abandoned that baby when Papa Jeff
left. May he rip and piss even though he's still
alive and doing his thing, but may he rip?
Is Brig any good these days? I used to main him.
I'm afraid. It's a choke on my lord. Excuse me. Hold on a minute.
No, don't get nauseated. No, no, no, refling. Don't be sick because we're talking
about Overwatch too. No, don't be sick, don't be sick.
Papa Jeff Kaplan. Yeah, Jeff Kaplan left the development team when he learned
what was happening to Overwatch too.
As I'm fucking dying now apparently. I might need to pee. My bladder is getting
a bit full. I'm gonna be honest. I'm pretty full of liquid.
I don't know about you, but my bladder's pretty full of liquid right now.
A bit of liquid.
Are we allowed to do a very quick pee break? I'll keep the vod of
Azura going though. I won't pause it. Oh my god! Who's crying like that?
I just look over on the Azura Vod and it's like actually greeting out the wazoo.
Who's greeting like that? My little strawberry face.
Her baby.
I was a Moira main when she released. She was great. I love Moira too.
This is Emmy and her insurance fees. No, I don't know how she does it.
Like if I need to pee, I'm gonna go. Would you guys like to go with me?
Mommy is making a pee. Right, you know the rules. I will sit down and then you pee in
between my legs, okay? So then we both pee at the same time and our streams connect
and then I have taken a bit of your soul by doing this action because you know
there's no other crazier girl that would ever do something like that.
Maybe some of the Veiler girls might do something like that with you.
But in general, as a rule of thumb, most girls will not do that and I will steal
a part of your soul and you'll be forever mine briefly.
Okay, now that I'm aware how much we need to pee, I'm actually gonna go pee because I
really need to pee. I'll be right back, okay? The toilet's just there.
That's why I mute when I'm like, let's hear you pee. No.
Now go pee and stretch your legs.
You know, even after how much liquid I've drank, it's still not clear.
I think I'm permanently just always gonna have like yellow
pee. I must confess, it's killing me.
I'm done, but mommy's in back, get broke.
That's just, uh, yous are okay. I was only going for a little bit.
Did I wash my hands? The answer is no. Before anyone asks, you know.
If it's clear, you're over hydrating it? Okay. I mean, it wasn't neon, so I'll get,
I'll give myself credit. It wasn't neon.
What about 11,000? Right, as long as we're under like,
I'd say if we do get to 6,000 wines left, that's a three hour stream, which is kind
of perfect to wrap it up. Wrap it up, wrap it up. This stream should look pretty clear,
but when you look in the toilet after it should be a bit yellow. What? Oh, right, sorry. Okay,
I'm gonna see you. Okay, we're all good. Kind of like your hands clean for you.
I don't know, as long as you don't touch like any of the yellow snow or like the toilet paper
or anything like that. Wait, no, you touch the toilet paper to stop you from, the barrier.
As long as you don't leak like that, then you really have to wash your hands? I don't know.
Who knows? I'm not a germ expert, okay? I'm just a germ because I'm disgusting. Thank you,
I'll be here. That's not even a sentence. I think I'm starting to slowly get slightly delirious.
Gonna be honest, like I'm getting slightly delirious. I'm trying to drink some more water.
Yee-hee.
Okay, last few minutes you're all done. Aw, look at how many she managed to do, that's fantastic.
She's getting steam in? I think she did box shot relate after this actually.
Okay, box shot relate. Yay, predicted.
Been gone, been gone for nine hours, only slightly delirious, yeah.
I'm gonna get a big nap. This is definitely like, this is when I get into bed
and start falling asleep, so we're doing all right. We're doing all right.
We're doing all right, okay. You don't have to worry about me, so we're doing okay.
Oh, mercy, had the game crashed in here. That was a hard one.
Her game crashed and I was like, oh, okay.
Monk, Monk, Monk, Monk. We're actually in sleep.
Been gone for nine hours, only slightly delirious, she's getting E.P.
I'm gonna do marshmallows after the zero stream ends, so I'm starting to perish.
I'm starting to perish. I'm gonna make a,
I'm gonna make a, I'm gonna make a,
I'm trying to, like, drink to keep myself awake.
Amy fell asleep, now she's awake.
Probably could go to bed, I'll wait. I'll round it out and go at the top of the hour.
No, I'm gonna try to keep going because if I don't do it now,
the next stream is gonna take so much longer.
Wipes off face, your seat is ready, man. Stop it, Gira lurking outside on the ring cam, Bob.
It's that profile picture kills me every time I see it.
I just really like, oh, you hear like ding, ding, ding, and then oh, you hear it's
at your door and nothing else. Like, that's every time my brain plays that when I see your profile picture.
Thank you for like this to the chat.
It's literally Gira's ult. I hope you're doing okay then, darling.
Um, that was pretty smooth though.
But I'm warning you all now, I'm getting E.P., okay? And when I'm E.P., I'm not as hyper,
you've been warned. So don't expect hyper mumme. Mumme's getting tired, mumme's needing a lie down.
She's in E.P., E.P., but I can do it, okay? I can grind. If I get to like,
if I make it to four o'clock, what, how four, when's four o'clock? Did you know
o'clock means of the clock? I just thought you should know that. So when I say four o'clock,
I'm actually saying four of the clock. I just thought you should know because that's how it works
and dying. Mumme's gonna be a cuttlefish in bed with a recent stop. I cannot wait to get a freaking
mask off, like plushie. I'm gonna do so many things to that plushie. I'm gonna hump it. Sorry,
I shouldn't say that already. Oh, my inhibition. Oh, I'm not supposed to say that stuff.
Sorry. I'm gonna do ASMR with you, okay? I'm doing ASMR with you. Then I'm doing
what else am I doing with you? I'm gonna, I'm gonna put my feet on you. I'm gonna sit on you
with my butt and take photos. I'm gonna stick a tentacle on you and like edit it and be like,
damn, Reef was ready to go. Yeah, if Mumme goes to bed, I can go to bed, so it'd be fine
if you don't go to school all of a sudden. I just, I need, if I get it to 6,000 winds are left, I know
in my head that's three hours and I know for a fact I can yank for three hours unprompted.
So it's not gonna be a problem, but if I like chicken out now, there's a living so that's five
more hours and that's not terrible because I'm like, that's not really a bad for an endurance
stream type thing, but I've not got another five more hours, five more hours.
What about 8,000 for four hours?
Please don't leave me alone with the cats. No, Gimli Vigo won't go for you.
Do we need to keep that Reef limb plushie in some kind of predictive custody? No, it's mine.
It's mine, Reef. I get to do what I want them and he's gonna like it, isn't he?
He's gonna like it.
I guess he's, I'm straight, he's moving, but I'm very excited to get it and then I can
start my mascot ASMR series because I'm gonna get all the girls and I'm excited to do that and then
I could start doing it for other VTubers as well if they'd like to send me their mascot possibly.
Or maybe their plushie of their character, but I think it's rather cute to do it for the mascot
instead because it's like oh your name's this and you know your oh she started streaming and then
most notable streams were this and facts were this and like it's all positive. Every fling she can
grape for you lives. We need to keep strong and protective custody of it. No, she keeps the plushie
in a jar. No, what are we agreeing to? A lot of things. All at once. Right, we're just about to go
under 11,000. Oh my god, we're doing it. We are getting 99 and we're not really doing it on time,
but that's okay because we did the Nigerians and I had loads of fun doing the missions with you guys,
the quests in the first one. I think we will revisit RuneScape, but we'll 100% do questing
and I'll plan out the quests far in advance so everyone knows what's coming up.
Um, just, yeah, no.
What should we do? Is there a drawing time? Is she, is she post-yapping now? Or is she still going for it?
Yeah, mascot first so the girls get what they want, then the girls plushie next question.
Will any of the plushies be machine washable?
I saw someone cut open and put, uh, another thing before and I was like,
look, it's really degenerate but it's kind of horrible. I mean, he kind of cooked for that one
after me. Hi, Stony, how are you? I'm good, Rieflin, how are you? How big will the plushie
will be for this size, head size, torso? Um, uh, you put your hand straight. However long your hand
is is like kind of how big the plushie will be. Do you remember when I did the hand cam,
like, American Eatin' Sweets and I touched the plushies of Strawberry and Cinder? Yeah.
Well, why would they need to be machine? Now, why would they need to be a little silly like that?
Are there any other skills that require you to just sit in one place and click?
Eh! Wait, what's that in reference to? Cut is open. No, I wouldn't do it to you. I'm sticking
the tentacle on you. It's the girls, girls as a plushie, you'd cut open and stick an attachment
inside. Eight inches? I mean, yeah. Your hand eight inches long, what the fuck?
So I love the way Zero talks. I need more of that ASMR. Give me the goods. You know what we're
both here for. The mascots are getting prosthetic. Magic if you spam jewelry enchantment.
What we're doing, what, we're already picking the next one we're doing?
For a level and to get 99 and before we end up doing like a 99 account just for the hell of it.
You know what else is eight inches? Three of these.
Mm-hmm. Anyone know what that would be? What's eight divided by three?
Two point something. Oh yeah. Oh yeah, Mr. Krabs. I'm guessing Zero's the first one to get harassed
by Strony and then sent to HR. I don't know who the first girl harassed was.
I suppose technically it was Zero because during debut I went sexy. Oh no, I went
during debut but inside it was sexy, sexy. Reverse, thank you for letting me pop your cherry
for your super chat. It's mine now, yoink. Thank you.
Two point six six. Since we we flings are basically ahead with tentacles and you're
adding another tentacle to our heads, what are you trying to imply? No, it's four. It'll make
sense when I show the picture of what I have planned for you, okay? It's supposed to be like
your thing, okay? It'll make sense when I show it but it doesn't make any sense
verbally explaining what the photo is. Off collab with you guys is going to be wild stuff.
As I said before, all the girls were like down to come to Australia just because of me being an
anxious little mop bag that can't even eat with us. I'm like bro, are you trying to make me cry the
fuck? Like we actually only, I mean technically pre-debut but we didn't know each other that
well because we couldn't really, but it wasn't until after like we debuted and that we could get a
better feel of each other. Whoa, hold on a minute. I get Copa Fila, it's going to be the name of a
gen two. Hold on, just look down. Copa Fila, sorry. That's not even funny, shut up. Stop it. Stop it.
I mean trust the sign, it's you. I like to live. But yeah, all of them were like down to come to
Australia and I was like, oh I'd probably rent like an Airbnb for like however long they're staying
in higher computers and stuff and oh maybe not higher actually, I don't want to get sensitive
information. Is that kind of stuff? Yeah, yeah. The girls fighting over who wants to stream
because we can't do all the whole thing.
Personally I'd prefer a plushie of you over the refland but I would buy both. Oh we have to pick
one first. I thought mascots was nicer. Now I don't know if that's selfish of me to say that
mascots is more fun because obviously I want to do that series and I want a physical
thing of you that I can interact with when I make content. Like I'll be you know doing like
standing on you stuff, sitting on you, pinning you against the wall type stuff. Like I want that,
I want physical stuff that I can do with you. Ace and Martin would work since it would be one
at a time anyway. We all licking the same microphone.
Is she okay?
Oh did someone drop her? Fat. Super chat. Chad. Real.
Real.
I really understand why you want refland first. I still can't wait to color your
plushie. Thank you for your patience.
I think having plushies of girls would be cute to imagine as a bacon.
Yeah you need an airbnb, can't fit five more girls on your- stop! That's funny.
I would need to travel.
Oh.
Oh I'm so fucking cute. What the fuck?
You know you know you picked them good with me at the level.
I like the idea of a plushie view so I can have it sitting on my desk. I just stare at you and I'm
offline. You already know I'm listening in via the plushie. For the plushies there needs to be a
down payment for the production cost. It's not like one can be produced at a time. It's like all
the materials get ordered after the prototype's made and then a batch is made. 75 crafting I can
finally get my glory.
Uh starting plushie with Neil Lemonade dispensing!
The plushie even has a hole in the bottom to hide in the mic.
Mercy showed you how to wiretap the plushies didn't she?
Oh I like that.
Right in that A is my port for Mercy right now.
I'm stroney fumo with empty eyes staring into my soul. The plushies have cameras so Stroney can
watch us. They're dark in your- or wonk in your willy honestly.
Honestly? Literally when the reeflings don't send enough tributes, fine. I'll do it myself.
Releases a plushie line with hidden cameras.
That's terrible.
I'd be down. I mean who said that? Hold on a minute.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Wow.
No! How am I supposed to put that into an A? That's difficult. That's difficult.
Thank you tiny spain. I'm not sure how I'd manage that. It's so hard to do collabs so
we all have collabs in August but it is so hard to like have a flow and edit and all that stuff.
It's a bit of a nightmare. I'm gonna burp I'm so sorry.
I didn't realize it was gonna be that. I'm gonna like charge that up.
Um
But yeah we all got a little club to- oh I got a 10 out of 10. Nice base. Oh a 9 out of 10.
What was that? I burped it? That one came out deep. I put- I like tilted my head back to do that one.
I wonder if that's the secret. Oh I got an 11 out of 10.
Oh a 7 out of 10. 12 out of 10. Oh you need to clip it and ship it. I need to post like a
just a 60 second short of mean. It's just me burping. But it's all my best burps. Not the weak burps.
Oh don't. I'll make that one. And on don't. I'll make that. I'm not even kidding. You already
know I will go on a schizophrenia grant. You already know I will make it stop. Will I make it in
October? Because there's a missing one in October. Will I do it? Oh it's so good anonymous. What a
good suggestion. I don't know. I mean you will be logged out in 30 minutes. Make sure you move to
why? I'm not allowed to unhealthily play your game. How dare you. The anger you should get.
Actually another thing. I can't extend my voice too much as sore right now.
Ript your soul at home. 20 pounds your pro state while making you add.
Don't take a window.
Stony skits a ranting triggered by the name of a male body part. 10 hours of
We've done 10 hours have we? That's what I was trying to say. And all it came out was a beatbox.
You got a big. Let me search you. You got a honey, honey word. Yeah. It's your
You got a big. Let me search. Yeah.
Oh
That was terrible. I know we're reacting to a vote. That was terrible. You should be ashamed.
Ooh, even I do this.
We're almost at 10. What kind of beatbox is that? It was the Missy Elliott. You got a big. Let me
search it. Yeah. I gotta work it. It's your flipping the benign yet. And if you reverse it,
it says something I can't remember.
Are we sacred? Wait, she sacrifices bleeding hearts when they don't act. Well, that's hilarious.
Sorry, I didn't even know she did that. That's hilarious.
Stony. Oh, no, I missed it. No, I missed a message. I missed a message.
Wow, you guys are so generous. I'm so thankful for everyone being so nice to the girls. Seriously.
But that sacrifice is hilarious when they're bleeding hearts. Stony. Well, going on a run
in the ends of the refund saying that was great mommy, but I said no. Oh,
oh, just at the end of it. Wait, he said pro state. Oh, sorry, refund.
Stony karaoke went sadly. Karaoke is going to be delayed. My voice really isn't doing well
all of the moment. We need to sacrifice bleeding hearts to get showbiz through milk.
Here's your best people. I can't beat books.
I can't do it. Oh, no.
That's all I've got.
She's just the girl who thinks I am the one.
But the cat is not in gentle.
Me when I'm rejected like to design so far. Yeah, you get you shown up in gentle. Yeah,
here's the design. Give me my secret character I desire.
Bye bye. I need to go work. Thank you for hanging.
I would say see you after work. But unfortunately, I'll be off the lane
because we're actually coming up to the two hour mark.
What are you giggling at?
I don't know. I mean, I'm sure there's some sort of correlation with talking for 12 hours straight
and having a bit of a strange voice. I don't know what the correlation is. I've not figured it out
yet, but I'm sure there is some sort of let's see you. Sometimes I kind of feel bad for being a
bald, bleeding heart. Sometimes you can't catch anyone live. It's just how it is. It's just the
way the world is, honestly. It is what it is. You know, starting it's been 10 hours you get.
Yeah, we may be able to get 98 before a pop off.
Surely you just fly. Yes, of course.
The writer has ruined Giggle for me. Do you just really get flashbacks to Giggle stick without fail?
Muscle Mummy and Tomboy and Chintu, please. There is actually denied a Muscle Mummy,
but it's not because she was a Muscle Mummy. It's because there is a design element. I really,
actually, I can divulge this at this point in time. So there's both male advisors and there's
both female advisors in like in management. Okay. And if I showed the design to the girls,
not my gen mates. They've not seen this. If I showed it to the female advisors management,
they didn't like the design along with me. If I showed the design to the guys,
they liked it. And it's the first time I've seen a proper difference
that was very clearly like this is female gaze looking at this design
versus a male gaze looking at the design. Because I enjoyed the first rendition,
but then it got off. It got off track as it was developed further. And then I just got
straight up rejected. But I think we got to the fourth rendition and I was like, no,
we're just redirecting. We're not having it. If it's interest, no, it is. Of course,
we guys like it. No, no, no, I'd be very, I don't know if the concept artist is going to try and
remake her for possibly something else. But as it stands,
as it stands, she got rejected. There's a second character that got outright rejected. There was
no alterations. It was just like, no, this isn't at all one track. I'm afraid you're gonna have
to go back to the building board. Will you release the rejected ideas? I will release them if the
concept artist has no plans on selling them as adoptables.
Or doesn't want me to, because I don't want it to be disrespectful. And I mean,
you know, most of us have worked together before, so it's not really a disrespect thing. It's just
kind of like, obviously, it might not feel good if your design gets rejected. And it's like, well,
why are you rejecting it? And it's not like the design's objectively ugly. There's actually one
aspect in the design that got outright rejected that I really want to see used in another design.
So I'm not sure if we could show it if and when Gen 2 are confirmed and pop up. I'm not sure.
Obviously, I'll do my classic exposing the Allure's Gen 2.
Although the development notes aren't going to be as fun this time, because I never
got to name and put terrible names on the designs. Basically, you don't own the rights. Oh no,
I own the rights to it. I own the rights to whatever we've been produced by the concept artist.
But I'm not an asshole. I'm not going to turn around and be like, I'm going to embarrass you by
showing your rejected design. If they want to, you know, sell it as an adoptable or whatever,
that's fine with me. That's not a problem with me. Can't create some formal, so it's tricky.
I will say I have dropped the forbidden architect, archetype suggestion,
my desire to. Another L for a slime, bro, is blue. There's no slime that's been produced. I'm happy to
do that. As I said, it is not diverse.
But I will do the whole, like, exposing my Gen 2 type thing, and I'll do the fun behind the scene
stuff. And you'll see, like, the first version versus the next version, like, one design.
I absolutely adore, but I had to say, I was like, look, the chest, you need to cover it up more.
We can't have that. That's not going to fly. So we had to change the chest. And then we got
one of the designs. I was like, please pull down the shirt. We're not going to get away with that.
Pull down the shirt. Pull down the shirt. Pull it down. Like, that kind of stuff.
And there's only one slime I want. Is it mine?
Yeah, why I dropped the floor slime puzzle, which we'll never see. The hell you're dying on.
Underbib. It was just too much. And it was like, so obviously, Sheebie and Azura's kind of been a bit
of a wake up call to be like, okay, we do have to play by the rules. And they are getting,
hold on, Azura. I'm trying to ramble about Gen 2. Yeah, what was I saying?
Yes, Azura and Sheebie have kind of smacked me awake and being like, holy shit, I actually could
have jeopardized their income due to my kind of stupidity of the approach. And so definitely
like, pull this t-shirt down and cover up just slightly more. No underbobbles? No, you cannot get.
No, underbobbles are completely unallowed, actually, on Twitch. I assume YouTube is probably
going to adopt that. I wouldn't be surprised. I got out of the shower and Shawnee's still going,
hell yeah. When is the game coming out? Would you have Gen 2 in it? Every generation's going to
have their own spin-off game. The games are made on a parody of popular Vtuber games.
And that is such a generic umbrella term of games that have been popular with Vtuber, but
every gen gets their own game. And yeah, the Vtuber crackdown. I guess that's where
Outfit Towers was coming. Yeah, it made me a bit scared when Azura got rejected for monetization
because I thought at first it was just her design, but I was like watching her stuff and I'm like,
well, to be fair, when you stream, you're actually only shoulders up. I mean, heck, right now I'm
literally shoulders up. There's nothing more to me. It's not like this is the stream all day long
type things. This isn't the stream all day long. The stream is just your head and nothing more,
like there's not really much more to it,
but Sony played by the rules, you know what I mean?
I'm sorry. I just did that out of nowhere. Sorry if I jumped here to anyone with that.
I didn't mean it. I meant to. I did it manually. Is that a bit bigger?
I can't remember.
It's not an orc. Okay, we're about to go. We're about to go. I repeat, we're going to be out of the
10,000s, out of the 10,000s. I kind of like when you have very covered
clothing, you just take off more and more layers. Jumped here, I wouldn't mind that. That was just
the whole stream. What just happened? I was on a rambling point about how you don't really see
any of the design. Like, I'll literally, like, when have you seen this? You like saw it once
in the work of the stream. Like, when's the last time you saw it? Like, so I'm standing on the
reeflings in game. Stand, stand, stand. Stand, stand, stand. Standing on the bank teller and
stand, stand. Like, you don't really see the outrageousness past the point.
10 hour marks and don't forget to do ink wah wah. The thighs, though he, I don't really get to show
that often. We're free. Quick commit it to memory, real. Wah, co-opulation.
Um, yeah, and tell beller makes their own payment process. Certain streamants always be
fucking over for that. Who's that AO? You're done for. Someone accused me of being the AO poster,
how dare you. You see your, you see your accusations and raise your, who goes there, huh?
If anyone goes AO, it's Azura because she literally asked for me to give her an AO.
I'm like, God bless feet. Thank you, Spidey. Thank you, investor. Spidey for your, your
kind. Thank you for everyone for your investments and beller. Oh, what, what did I just, I did
that way too early. Didn't I? Yeah, I did. Okay. I'm getting too excited.
Can't wait for Halo, eh, eh. Okay. Combat evolved. Well, like I looked that up and it was like time
to complete the game. Ten hours and I was like, no, it's not. It's like an old game. Old games,
they didn't even have enough memory to make such a waltz, so I just, I just punched the muffin
case and if you heard that when women wear a hoodie and nothing else oh design
when right now baby I am a cut I am a cuttlefish and I stand stand stand stand
stand oh I don't know that right then congrats on strewn so long it's
appreciated the amazing model is great I'm glad you like it spent some smack
on this boy stroke of midnight and seat
Bing bong bing bong bong bing bing bong go to sleep America if you need go to
sleep don't forget to eat Europe if it's time to eat Aussies we're just
chilling at work. This is work a cock for Ozzy's. Shibuya's already start
outlining what to expect on him. She seems excited, I'm glad. Okay I'm fading,
almost sent a marrow. For you to Shibuya, I gotta go sleep. Oh, sleep tight, little
ofies man. As I said, once we finish, Azura's thing is about to be, her
vault's about to be finished, I'm just gonna ramble on Marshmallow for the rest of
the week. Azura, honestly? She cooked the stream, she absolutely cooked.
Mommy's the only substance I need. No, I need to sleep, I need to go. We're about to go
under 10K, that's what I want to see. So I want to see, and if I've got another two
hours, so what? That really will take us to 6K if I'm not too silly. Midday in
Western Australia right now, still going strong. From 4 a.m. to 4 p.p. under 4k
life, brah, you're legit gonna get the cape in front of us. I'm jealous, giving
your account right now. Password, email, and pin, go. Alright, I will watch the last
bit later, I've got work in a year. Rest well, sleep tight, rest well to those who
need to go as well. Please don't be afraid to go, pick your health over me, I promise
you it's the better choice. I am always streaming every single day, so I'll catch
you when I can catch you, okay? You don't have to worry. Yes, I'll give you my cape,
mommy. You don't have to worry, I'm on every day, okay? So please look after
yourself. If you need a hydra, you need to make your bed, you need to change the
sheets, you need to put a washing on, you need to do dishes, you need to prepare for
work, you need to lay out your outfit for tomorrow for work, you're allowed to go
do these little tasks, you brush your teeth, that kind of thing. Then you're
allowed to, okay? Marisa already ruined my sleep, so I'll show some just straight
up. I can't deal with being away from mommy, but I might miss you reading my
tomorrow. What is going on with Mrs. Irina? See, her mic does cut it. Oh, strong
as I'm gonna make this in five hours. I might need to try and sleep, so yes,
good night. See you next time, oh yeah. Little sis rain. I'm warm and cozy here,
I have a free day today. Aww. A free day and I've forced you to watch my gen mates wads
whilst I do wanes in Edgeville. Look at that, under 9k, isn't that gorgeous? That is absolutely
stunning. We started at 30,000 wanes to make and we're now at 9,000. Oh, that's stunning.
Not gonna lie, that made me leak a little bit realising that we actually did it. Like,
this is my first ever 99. Absolutely stunning. Absolutely stunning. Congrats on 18k, by the
way. Thank you so much! I don't know what the fuck is growing my channel so much. I genuinely,
like the meme videos are not being, you know, meme-ing anymore so I don't really know where
it's fucking coming from. It says- Oh, it says the hypnosis stream. I'm on to you subscribers.
I'm gonna be logged out in 10 minutes. Leave me alone, RuneScape. You're so stinky. Okay,
the hypnosis stream. No, it can't be. It says I gained 100 subscribers from hypnosis stream.
Where are you people coming from? I'm getting scared. I don't know, it's cause you're amazing
stuff. I don't know what's going on. It doesn't really tell you. Content audience? Did it say
audience? I guess it says new viewers. Like, is it that? It doesn't really tell you where
the traffic of subscribers comes from. That's bizarre. It says you're all American. That's
what it says. It says 46.7% of you are American. Doesn't show which other channel. They watch
Emmy, they watch Elias, I don't know. They watch Sheedy, they watch AC, they watch Mercy,
they watch Pillowdeer, they watch Smoothie, Druid, Groovey, Smart, Azura, Salky, Katz,
Kana, Yanagi from Pixel, Link, um, Fur, Faerie, Mayari. I've absolutely destroyed that name.
I'm so sorry. There's a lot of vowels in there. Nene from Kawaii. That's a lot of ASMR
videos. That's what it says. Your audience also watched. Your zoomer sister annoys you
with brain rot memes. My lips belong to you, Elias, I don't know. I bet you like kissing
your sister. Another Elias as well. Azura, Smoothie, Emmy. Is this Smoothie's clip? Another
Emmy? Okay, so Emmy is actually driving a lot of traffic to me, surprisingly. Emmy's
viewers, Emmy's, what your audience watches. So both Emmy and myself are getting watched
by Azura. What, the Smoothie clip is almost 150k? 150,000 people saw my fucking daughter's
chair. You degenerates. You filthy degenerates. Leave her alone. Okay, unless it's supporting
her, okay, that's different than Teehee. Didn't Emmy redirect into you from that stream? Trickle
Are you exposing us? I just might. Maybe you'll blackmail me and then you have to do favors
for me. I need curses. I need more members of the itty-bitty Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee Teehee
Teehee Teehee Teehee
It's a bridge
Grass, how dare you
Like I'm just MLG at this point
Just because
Just because you're a fake gamer boy
And you're being faced with a real gamer girl
That's right
You feel threatened
Oh that's right, the Scottish lass
Oh
She's threatening
Yeah, I don't know what the fuck I'm on about
I'm getting delirious
Hey Stroni, how are you feeling?
I just wanted to say thank you and also sorry
Oh, why are you saying sorry you good boy?
I was riefling her ass
Oh, wait
I knew that was gonna happen
Sorry
Sorry, I knew that
My bad, my apologies
Hold on, let me back in the servers real quick
She's a girl and she games
I got banned, I got banned
I can't believe it, I got banned
In real time
Not my wains for men and as if I didn't just get booted from this game
Bro
Let me in
Ooh, she left, I'm back already, I'm back
Don't worry, don't worry
12 over making wine or one minute, two seconds and then
What does that mean?
Okay
Hi Stroni, hi Meepling
I just wanted to say thank you and also sorry
I was riefling her ass
Why do you care about it?
I wasn't expecting it to go the way it did
Oh
Bro, I went on a fucking...
I went on a tangent
I think I sat on that for like a whole 30 minutes
I don't know how long I was sitting on that bad boy
But I wanted to thank you for the heartfelt response
I was fighting tears during it
I also wanted to thank you and the other wreathlings as well
I was reading chat and seeing how everyone engaged with the question
It made me realize how awesome this community is
I'm so proud to be a part of it
Thank you Stroni
Oh thank you wreathling
And also thank you fellow brothers in the wreath for being so amazing
Aw
That's what I'm saying
Like that's a thing
It's a little just being chilling
Okay, we're all a bunch of wreaths
But we are just
It's just
It's chill
There's no expectations
You know the lurkers be lurking
The bing chillings be bing chilling
And you know there's no pressure from me
Or any other wreathlings for that matter
Failure's strong together, real
I never finished the sentence, okay
I never finished the sentence
I had a frog in my throat
Stroni, this is the comic I was referring to
When someone said thirsty a little flower
I'm gonna open
No!
You've given me a puzzle
You need to give me the full link
You need to give me the HTTPS
Like comma thing
Stop giving me puzzles
Give me the full link
And then just do the dot
Stop hiding things behind the IQ puzzle
And before this doesn't work
Yeah, 404 not found
I literally can't open the file
Cause you took away something
And I can't do it
I got 404
Fail not found
Stop giving me logic puzzles
It's been 10 hours
Mummy, I've never done NNN before
But I wanna give you control
And I wanna be a good wreathling
If I had encouragement and orders
I think I could do it
Hold back for a month
I don't know, I'd need to plan it
Like proper plan it
I'm gonna
I'm gonna take a wild guess
And say the choosing beggar was
I know, absolutely not that girl
Wait, what?
No, no, it was absolutely not that girl
No, you won't be able to tell
No, it was not that girl
That girl's absolutely fantastic
She is
Nothing but sweet
She's pure kindness
And maybe you should have said
Please don't speculate
Because of this reason
If you get the wrong girl
You know, it's not very nice
No, it's absolutely not her
She is nothing but lovely
And juicy and gorgeous
And no, it is not her
Who here is a proud wreathling
Stop right now
We can't start typing that in chat
The clip earlier
These are the back clubs
Of clip tabs currently
Did you give me
See, there's no logic puzzle this time
I think you can only
I think you only need to do it on one show
Stop when it comes to
Hold on, hold on
Let me, let me cook
And before it says 404 again
Yeah, damn
You're clipping the fuck out of this
Okay, now
I'd show it on stream
But it might break Malbia
Johnny, I made the meme
You wanted a mercy at the all club
A bit of a
Wait, what did I ask for?
Bro, I'm so sorry
I hate to be like
Wait, what did I say?
But on it
I'm getting very tired
Oh my god
Right, okay
If this crashes my OBS
Don't worry, I'll come right back
But this is worth it to show
I remember the meme now
I remember the meme, hold on
I remember the meme
It's mercy at the all club
And it's all of us coming
De-de-de-deen
Literally
Look at all of our hairs as well
That's so good
That's such a good ad
Well done, Rufa
And that's so good
Let me show it to you
John ReefTard is my full name
Stop, we're gonna get in trouble
We're actually gonna get in trouble
Rufa
That's such a good meme
Well done, Rufa
And that's actually what I mean
Don't read this out loud
I'll try you like that far co-addon't you?
What little things did you do at your den meme?
I answered that.
Oh right but that's because you asked to make sure I don't forget.
I love Bomi so much.
If she has a thousand reflens then I'm one of them.
If she has a hundred then I'm one of them.
And if mommy only has one reflend then that reflend is me.
Hi I'm new here and I'm hooked.
Was it the ten hours of winemaking an Edgeville gameplay that just really spoke to your soul reflend?
It just over-empowered you that the duration the streamer might have.
Momente refleng.
I just want to let you know that I'm very blessed to have spawned in a family where emotions are fine and there's love all around.
Outsiders are surprised about how my flutons are very close and how we're very close with our cousins too.
One of the reasons I got attached to you is because of how genuine you are without being...
I'm getting nervous can I say this stuff out loud?
It's like I'm just interacting with one of the family members.
Please do not change but also take care of yourself physically and emotionally.
Are you kidding me right now?
All the loaded maros can leave at the top.
I love your videos and this live today.
You are awesome and I'm actually glad I'm here to watch you some more.
I'm really in love from reverse.
Oh my gosh thank you.
You might be eating those words tomorrow because I'm releasing pregnant with you ASMR in less than 24 hours.
Reverse.
Thank you for the super job.
I'm not kidding.
You genuinely might be eating those words because I made an ASMR where you're pregnant.
In my tummy and I don't regret it and I'm gonna play it and yeah.
It's worth the risk real.
Pregnant with me by me.
True.
I'm sure you know trust plays a massive factor in how enjoyable hypno content can be so while you may be inexperienced
in producing that kind of content just know your personality couldn't be more perfect for it.
Even when I want to push your buttons a little and I know it's wrong.
Even when I know it's bad and I shouldn't.
Thank you for the underwear update.
Now I really want to see them.
You're getting my underwear.
Oh no wait maybe.
Maybe I'll take a picture with underwear on and then take them off.
And then it's like a little photo shoot.
Not too many keys.
But I might not be able to catch stream today so here's a tribute.
That's my kind of reason.
You're all wet.
It's shocking to hear.
How much money from after three days?
Bro.
Okay.
I have a fish.
Fish, fish, fish.
Would it be alright if I sent a tentacle pic for your birthday?
As a gift?
Yes?
Oh my god wait.
Can I get like a mask like thing going on?
Oh no there's no way I can say that name.
Lex, riot.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Riot.
How do I say that?
Lex.
Lex or riot.
Yeah.
That's your name now.
There you go.
Nicknames all yours.
Close.
Lex right.
Oh they're really obvious.
That's actually really obvious now that you said that.
Bye.
Lex right.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Not the tentacle train.
We need to photoshop us with eight of them.
Oh I think that would actually be a bit scary.
Not gonna lie.
Um.
May we have a kiss please mummy?
You get me addicted each time you do them.
Um.
Do you say kiss or kiss?
Oh no.
Your language you used you said I kiss.
Which is singular.
That's right you're getting whipped to be an English language.
Um.
Congrats on 18k mumme.
Thank you Rhysling.
You ask where they come from but come on.
The way you keep an open mind to your shenanigans.
The way you accept us all.
And make streams comfy in second homes.
Go to love support.
Tin foil rambles.
And drain tentacles.
We adore and love you unironically.
Oh I love you too.
I'll never feel you don't deserve this.
I'm just like.
But why?
Speaking of pregnancy.
I just caught a mosquito trying to suck me.
I was going to say mosquito girl but then I said no.
Cause I don't like mosquitoes.
Um.
Apparently baby carried the DNA of the host.
I ain't paying the child support.
Real.
Okto pee pee jumpscare.
Won't know the idea again.
I'm that mosquito for real.
You would never need to cook.
For you have cake for us.
You mean bake.
You would never have to bake.
Because you have enough cake for us Rhysling.
Is that what you meant to say darling?
Be honest.
Sweetheart.
Is that what you meant to say?
They put you would never need to cook.
For you have enough cake for us Rhysling.
You mean I would never have to bake again.
Cause I have enough cake for you.
Is that what you mean QAPI?
I think that's what you meant.
What is that?
A disk of returning.
Return.
To sender.
Whee.
There's enough cake to go around here.
Hi mommy just letting you know you actually have 400 extra wines.
Aha.
Ok.
How did you do the math so quickly in between me farting around?
How do you do that?
Can we have more kisses please?
That's more like it.
Is that better?
See that multiple that time.
Let me get one of them.
To feed the French during the revolution.
Let them eat cake.
Did you know that Marie Antoinette never actually said eat them?
Oh ok right.
I was going to say a joke and I fucking started so badly through the damn thing.
I don't want to say it anymore.
In anger.
I don't want to say the freaking joke anymore.
I'm raging.
I literally fucking ruined it.
Anyway.
Made my day even brighter.
Mr. Blue Sky.
Why did you have to hide for so long?
Hello.
Ok.
I thought I didn't catch up.
But I have caught up because of the people in sharing their story with me.
But I don't want to read anything out loud because that's personal.
I thought I wasn't caught up.
I am caught up.
Mummy can we please have some cake?
We've been good rooflings.
20k and you get your cake deal.
There's a website that tells you I'm not that autistic.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Is this not finished yet?
Everyone gets a 20k.
I'll upload the pregnancy tomorrow.
I'll drop down to 15 so I've got some time to spawn.
I need to get my glist.
Don't!
That's funny but don't because it like fucking destroys channels.
Fucking people thought we were doing that at debut.
They were like oh my god they're button subscribers.
If there's a search of subscribers, you should like fucking scrub them all away.
You know.
We're trying our best.
You can look up your username and how much XP and plug it into a card.
Oh there's a website that tells you that.
You can see my XP live?
Stop I feel so exposed.
You can see my XP?
Mine?
The calling part 5 literally.
Your cooking XP remain in your walnut.
Who you calling a walnut?
Your big jobby.
Your peaking pie?
Eating bastard.
I didn't even know how I would insult you.
Disbelief over viewer's popularity shouldn't be so strong.
Viewer is the first member of the group.
There's a website where you can plug in the XP in the back.
I complained.
I'll force my friends and family to even the youngins.
Nope that's not how it works around these powers.
We Anakin Skywalker them fuck.
I don't know if you'll let's say that but yeah.
We don't own our brand for you.
I hate them.
What is the quote Anakin Skywalker?
It's a quote. Get the quote up right now.
Not just the men but the women and children too.
They're like animals.
So I slaughtered them like animals.
I hate them.
That's the...
Master Stroney there are too many of them.
Oh sorry that was the kid's voice.
What are we going to do?
You underestimate my power.
I hate women and children.
I hate them.
We are real unhappy with them.
That was perfect for the youngling.
I always stuck in my head.
Master Skywalker there are too many of them.
What are we going to do?
I don't know I just sounded British.
I assume it was a British child.
There's too many of them.
I just remember the accent of the wee chubby cheeks.
He's adorable.
He did a really good job.
Mummy please pin me against the wall and hold my tentacle hostage.
I want to be drained in milk of my ink.
But while you do a tinfoil rant do you want the tinfoil rant?
It would be a lot easier for me to do the tinfoil rant than the park bench if I'm being honest.
If you guys have the patience for me to instead do the park bench as the next one
and then I'll do tinfoil rant like now if that makes sense.
Like the one that's supposed to go up this month.
So just do a little swapsies.
And then someone will be like oh my god Stroney you're scamming me.
Where is this one audio you promised?
I'm like fucking relaxed.
Fucking relaxed.
The only thing you can come in the night.
You really like old school runes.
It's a goal.
It's a goal okay.
I want 100 notone.
I want level 99 and one runescape skill.
And I'm almost there okay.
I just have another 99,000 wines to go.
Wait no.
9,000 wines to go.
9,000 wines.
I far meant one.
I put it in the bank.
8,999 wines to go.
You know?
That's what I'm doing.
Stroney have you ever had horchat?
It's a Mexican drink made by soaking rice in water for 24 hours.
Then blending with milk sugar and cinnamon.
It's actually refreshing.
I've never done it.
I want to take in puppy Stroney for a walk Oreo.
I don't know how to write that.
You're still going aw yeah.
Never met a girl with such stamina before have you?
Stroney we need to cook.
What did Stroney just call me?
My first 99 was smithing.
I don't know why.
Yeah I picked cooking because I'm a woman.
That's literally it.
Out of everything I could have literally picked,
my brain was like well this one.
So there's no rhyme or reason on what your first 99 is.
Although someone said,
I think I have enough money to do fletching unironically
so I might just go for it.
Mummy jerks your pintas to extract all the corruption
that's thrown in the balls of tinfoil random.
She can stream for 12 hours but she's done after 2 minutes.
Do you mind?
Okay look, look.
You know what?
Sorry to the average jewel that needs to get punched in the face
and their leg caught in a bear trap.
Just to fucking come okay?
Excuse me for being a quick show.
Like why am I getting straight?
I never did anything.
Okay 2 minutes is plenty of time.
True though.
Like actually true though.
Like if death is like you've got 5 minutes
I'm like thanks mate.
I can probably bang out to appreciate that.
Stop!
Um...
We're not asking for a lot just for 4 extra minutes.
Is that how much extra time you need?
I'll be done in 2, you'll be done in 6.
Appreciate the amount of time.
Let's work for me and you get yours.
Ah ha!
Honestly!
I gotta make sure you keep the calories on you.
I can't have you working too hard now.
Come on.
Meanwhile you can tell Stony she's a good girl
and she'll have to play one hand
to see if she can grab her thighs
to knock herself out of it.
What?!
Orrrysy!
If you're getting 3...
You're getting 3 death of knocking of 5.
2 and 5 is enough.
Don't mind it.
You're dying in 5.
Ah just enough time honestly.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe my scottish
leaked shock of the movie.
Stony can I have some of the cake please?
Only because you asked nicely.
Here you go.
I don't know what you were expecting me to do.
I mean, unless you want to see my butt fangs
that's different there.
You can see the cake from the front.
There.
Ta-da!
That's why I can't show that like at all.
Mm-hmm.
All yours!
Holy yuck!
Yes, both with Mercy and I have that issue
so that's why we can't really do that.
But I'm going to get a cover up on Mercy's skirt.
I'm just going to get her completed
so she can toggle through if she's like...
um...
Yeah.
It's actually insane bro.
I got rigged out of the wazoo.
I got designed out of the wazoo.
I'm one happy cut off of this video.
It doesn't matter if you last two minutes.
I'll go as long as you want until you're really satisfied.
Well as I said I'm one and done
so you've got like two minutes of pumping
and then I'm like right what we are doing for take away.
What we...
Well can we watch an Elden Ring lore video
about the DLC once we complete it together
after rebinding.
I assume your dad named your first gen Pantyless.
Honestly, I'm very excited to see the short come out.
I need to edit it.
It's just...
It's one of the things where it's like,
you know what, it's on the back burner right now
because it's just like a small kind of hearty heart thing.
She's 2D?
It's Johnny, spin him around.
Okay, you win.
Hold on.
Hold on, I know how to do this.
I have to hold shift and then some other combination of a button.
I'm a real vtuber, don't worry.
What one is it?
Is it no shift?
Hold on, what's the one that makes me spin?
No.
Isn't there one that...
I did it!
I'm so smart.
Hit him with a 3D.
Hey, hey.
Hey.
Okay, that's making me motion sick.
Put me back down and put me straight.
Okay, there we go.
Also me.
Oh my gosh, why am I not maximising my wings before stream?
I was supposed to be like S, M, A, 6, K.
More mate, literally, I'm getting motion sick as well.
That's the wrong kind of spin.
We can't even see yours.
Oh, right.
Fally.
I didn't get rotate.
I got rotate so hard.
Oh yeah.
What, we are 8000?
How much time have we got?
An hour?
How much did that fresh moment take you back?
An hour!
Okay, we're done.
An hour.
She can't show back, so she made yesterday's.
I mean, it could be a hidden lore.
I really like backless pantyloons that cover up the clam.
But the starfish one is out.
It's almost over.
It's trying to get wonderful.
Well, thank you.
You're wonderful too.
We still go another hour.
I mean, I don't know how you guys aren't exhaustive to be honest.
You're like, fuck it.
I'll kind of listen to that accent for like one more second.
Like, I'm trying.
I'm holding it together.
I really am.
Be strong, Clarence.
Be strong for mother.
You have no idea how hot that's in.
Bootless chap?
What is bootless chap?
Bootless chap.
I don't know what this is.
Images.
Bootless chap.
Wait, what?
Is that what I think?
What?
Wait, that literally is just...
Wait, is that what you guys are going to be wearing on the farm?
I'll do it.
Is that literally what you guys are going to be wearing on the farm?
Accent makes the yapping even better.
Right, that's it.
We're going back to the lace role play.
I've already forgotten what I did in it.
I'm starting to lose it.
Be strong, roofling.
Be strong for mama.
Is Mercy on today?
I don't think she is.
Oh, Mercy.
UK, Manju...
Wait, you did come.
UK, Manju, UK, Manju, UK.
Mercy's 50 subscribers away from 10K.
I'm going to cr-
I'm going to custard.
No, Mercy.
I'm strong, but the question is, how long must I last?
You are the only non-member of the illusion team.
Man...
Shit, I'm terrible content if I'm the only one up.
Fuck.
I fucked it.
Oopsies, sorry.
My apologies.
I apologize.
I can't believe it.
I say aesthetics.
I'm so stupid.
I'm not tired of this grandpa.
Well, that's good.
That's darn dinkum good.
I don't know, something like that.
Can I play fair dinkum?
Can you guys stream snipe me in fair dinkum?
It's like this game about Australian farms.
Like, unironically, can you stream snipe in that game?
And I can get you guys to work and we go on adventures and stuff?
I have to play No Mercy for Mercy's Tinky.
What's No Mercy?
Is that a game I don't know about?
I told you, I'm actually a fake gamer girl.
Let me do it for attention.
Dinkum can be multiplayer, but I had a stream...
a stream snipe.
Is No Mercy a song?
No Mercy, song?
Songu desu?
No Mercy.
Oh, the song's called No Mercy?
I didn't even know it was called No Mercy.
Shoulda picked Mercy.
Shoulda picked any kind of support.
We ended up losing.
It's all your fault.
Oops, your tears are what I live for.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom...
Mom, would you do a full cover of Mercy?
Shoulda picked Mercy.
Shoulda picked any kind of support.
We ended up losing.
It's all your fault, your tears are what I live for.
Maybe I'll be bashed in.
I'm already back.
Actually, let's go on that part.
Maybe I'll be Tracer.
Maybe I'll be Tracer, I'm already Tracer, what about Winston, I'm already Winston, I'll be Genji.
Nervomafree, fuck, I've completely forgotten the entire song.
Yippee!
I love the Scottish cover, stop, you guys shouldn't hype up, it's so bad.
Not the cake drops!
Not the cake drops in-game, don't think I don't notice the cake drop.
Do a quick carrier game.
Wait, but you'd only hear me, you wouldn't hear the copyright of it.
So only two minutes and then food after, I'm fine with that as long as it makes you happy, mummy.
Yeah, but you need to ink too, it would be weird if I inked and then you didn't go.
You need to be inked too, you're an acapella, fuck it, why not, I'm delirious enough to take you on.
Right, okay, no, no, never say, carry okay.
I need the carry okay version or it's over.
Wait, oh god, this is terrible, I don't know the words.
Oh, why did I mean it, there's a few guys who can hear it.
This, the day I have ever played with him my life.
You see, you know what, you don't actually get me going.
When it says it's a lyric video and the lyrics don't pop up until it's on the fucking fence, I'm actually gonna have a go.
Right, just pop it up, just pop it up so I can read.
Pop it up, okay, let's try it this way.
I'm delirious enough that I'm malleable at this point.
This is the worst team I have ever played within my life.
When we finally get on the point, everyone dies.
I understand that every now and then the team doesn't click.
I don't think I can sympathise, should have picked Mercy.
Should have picked any kind of support, we ended up losing.
It's all your fault you should learn how this game works, should have been helping.
I feel like Mercy so much, why don't you just marry her?
I don't think you can try to lecture me when you're the most useless person we have on our team.
Anyone rage is just as hard as you.
Maybe you should go back to playing Team Fortress 2, not to be Mercy.
I'm not gonna be any kind of support, we ended up losing.
Should have picked Mercy, should have been Mercy.
It's all your fault you should learn how this game works, should have been helping.
Too early, too early.
I'm actually playing Team Fortress right now.
I think the game got revived because they fixed the servers or something.
Okay so it's the instrumental bit.
It's the instrumental bit.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Maybe I'll be Tracer, I'm already Tracer.
What about Widowmaker, I'm already Widowmaker.
I'll be Bastion, Nerf Bastion.
Right so Winston, I wanna be Winston.
I guess I'll be Genji, I'm already Genji.
Then I'll be McCree, I already chose McCree.
What's your idea?
You should be, I'm not gonna be Mercy.
Mercy, should have been only kind of support, losing.
Oh they're like singing in unison right now.
Four.
Okay that's the best I got, the bots got banned.
Okay no more, no more.
You're welcome.
That was really hard to do like in the enunciated accent
because it's so easy to get tripped up on words.
He's not McCree anymore, he's cold.
I remember when the name first happened,
if you got caught calling McCree, everyone was like,
that's so disrespectful and it was like bruv,
I've literally known him as McCree for three years,
like fucking relax, like give me a second to try and, you know,
just call McCree a little bit different.
Let's do that, let's do that.
10 out of 10, 5 out of 10, how do you rate me so low?
Riefling, sit on this man.
Everyone calls him McCree?
The name's McCree, I'm your Huckleberry.
Not to be confused with the hit poet writer Huckleberry Fin guy,
that was that answer and that one was where we shocked ourselves.
Well, I shocked him.
Hi, hi, hi.
I make a reefling stop, you're going to make me hungry for takeaway.
Oh my god, but what happens if I did deserve a takeaway though?
Happy to see you're still streaming.
We're doing it, we're going to be 98 by the time I pop my clothes off.
Hello.
Poor Matt Mercer is so sick of being asked to do the high noon quote though.
Yeah, I remember watching an interview with Frodo or Elijah,
Elijah, like Elijah Woods or Elijah Woods.
And Sean Aston who plays Samwise.
And I got the impression, they were asking him about different roles
that they had played and different things.
And then it got to Lord of the Rings and they left in a bit of a cut
which kind of implied that they were like kind of looking at each other
and rolling their eyes because they've done this interview
like a stupendous amount of times.
Like they've been asked the questions over and over.
There's nothing that could be asked that hasn't been said before.
So it was just, I think it is like, don't get me wrong,
I'm sure people appreciate even being associated for a thing,
but I'm sure like you were right as well.
Like he gets tired of being like, say high noon, sorry, other one.
Or like say this, say that.
But then at the same time, I'm sure they equally have.
I've been lurking since the start of stream.
I'm glad I was able to spend the day off and just be rambling in the background.
Well, as for anyone who, Sean, are you Irish?
It's a 50-50.
What's your final answer?
Am I Scottish or am I Irish?
Your answer, if you answer wrong, you'll be timed out for 10 seconds.
Brad didn't read the second half.
Brad didn't read the second half?
Wait, what?
Wait, did I miss?
I just timed someone out for saying Irish.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, are we not joking?
Do you pick the Irish pill or the Scottish pill?
Is this a trick question?
Clearly, I'm on slap on my haggis.
Brattie Reeflings needs time out.
She's Welsh, obviously.
I'm going to do a bit of coke and a Bacardi, I think.
I used to be able to do a scousa because I'm back in high school.
Never mind, I was making a joke.
Oh, right, okay.
See, that's the problem.
I'm so low IQ, you can't make jokes, okay?
That's how bad it is.
You'll never know how bad it is until it's too late, okay?
What?
She's English, obviously American.
Obviously, obviously Canadian with an accent like this.
What a Canadian.
Hey, Tabernac.
Oh, I'm sure I'm Canadian.
Taber, Taberdine, Aberdey.
Any fellow with Tabernacs?
I have my woman a bit smooth brain.
Yeah, you like the chicken breast brain?
I've got all the chicken breast for you, baby.
All up in this noggin.
I actually assure you.
Very clear Luxembourg.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you guys actually figured out I'm Dutch all along.
I actually live in, please,
brain name one district or location in the Netherlands.
I actually come from Belgium
and this place called...
Shit, I was gonna make a joke.
Hold on.
I've come from a place called Maskanche.
Is Ik Woon in Maskanche, Jongen?
I break the kunt.
Kruzzak.
Kruzman kruzzak.
One person is gonna get...
Rotterdam, yeah.
Ik woon in Rotterdam.
Ik ben in Nederlander this whole time.
Sorry, but if you didn't know Dutch people actually speak English.
Praaaat.
Qua?
Yeah, Maskanche.
One person got that reference.
Hee hee hee hee hee.
Qua desonne.
Desonne.
Neither Luxembourg or Belgium are in the Netherlands.
I know, I have to pick.
But in Belgium,
the Sprech Netherlands
and Engels and
French and German.
Anything but Dutch.
It's the only thing I know other than the French.
And all I can say is like,
you know,
do you want my ass?
Ah, m'a cool.
Montpell?
Sorry, my accent.
My voice is short.
I can't even string a sentence together in any other lingual.
I'm sorry, I have disappointed you.
I've truly let you down.
The best I can do is teach you Scots.
To say,
we should
do jumpin' jacks in bed.
You say,
or,
I need my hole.
Basically.
That is a sin. I'm sorry.
It's not very romantic.
Or you say,
you're getting pumped.
And I'd be like,
you're flirting with me.
Did you hear about the giant blackout in France?
Oh my god, I've not.
Wait, is that real?
You told me.
I literally do not have time to consume
any current world affairs, so I know nothing.
France blackout?
Real?
Paris is hit by a blackout.
A power blackout claims social media users
a day after the city was battered
by rain
and trance.
What?
It says rain and trance.
Paris blackout sparks chaos.
The Olympics
has under way major power out which is
okay, that's real.
We're learning about real world problems.
Wow.
The
Scottish language of women.
Exactly.
I thought they said,
can a hag use
your gifts?
You know what?
Don't say such silly things.
You frickin' frick.
I've been
I've not been slaving away, I'm literally
having fun. I've been slaving away for 11
hours here.
Can you get me?
You think I got a license in Dutch?
Nah, I used to.
So if you
play video games in Europe
you will most likely
make friends of a different language.
So that's where I picked up
random words and different phrases.
So obviously I
played video games.
So I could randomly go
left because the enemy
is left like left left left.
Or right.
I forget what right is.
But again in French
you wouldn't really go
more than chat but you know what I mean almost time to put into bed yeah right
is the link slaving away 11 hours making wine I'm getting this whole
server drunk and by bro Mexicans could see can I salsa your taco that's
actually really great can I salsa your tackle any salsa for this
taco seems like terminology is technology is filling us shot and
behave you're on your sling is Dutch a good mythical morning
mine I don't understand sorry it's not that need a deadly I've been meat slim
it's been storm Shawnee slaving away in the kitchen but not for but not for us
but for herself are you looking my chocolate start what's going on wait
why am I randomly getting a reward I've not done anything I'm just fucking shit
post then I'm starting to lose my ability to speak is this where Amy got
all the booze from real I provided her with the creamy Baileys or whatever it
was she was drinking I can't remember if it's something heavy someone said she
drank something really heavy so she's okay I got the salsa I just need someone
to give me their taco taco flavor keys it was Irish cream man she was so cool
50 50 3000 and go how dare you booze booze glorious booze how it gets me
steaming they're meant to do age I don't know how to rain Chardonnay maybe I
shouldn't rain dinny I'm sorry I am going slightly delirious but not to be
confused with something yes I'm trying to have that scotch cream you want us
scone you want to cream the scone I guess if I was like proper oh my god if I
hire an English chick in Gen 2 I'm gonna make her cat for a catch phrase do you
want to cream my scone I'm gonna make that her catch phrase I don't care what
her design is I don't care her what her lore is I will force that that lane on
her as she's English you want to cream my scone like in her wee voice and before
it's a scotch have you want to cream my scone yeah oh wait that's not what scotch
again fuck a scone all right you want to cream my scone Sunny Jane but you I am
losing the ability to think wow I went to sleep and use it and I'm still here
look when I said I grind on a skateboard when I grind on metal in the
workshop I don't only grind there okay I grind on runescape you you little was
it you little sissy's that do a 50 hour shift per week those are sissy numbers
okay you've never heard of grinding like this before I do more work in one day
than you do in one more month okay you just you just not even available your
mind is dust at the comprehension of it she does 50 hour shifts day exactly that's
what that's what I want to see you pretty you tell them you tell them this is
probably true Shawnee gets a lot of XP grinding with the refunds around you
wanna grind on me relax your mind take your time with me oh I just remembered
I had a song request for the take me to the candy shop so you hit the spot we're
not even at the 11 hour mark wait I have more than 4 4 p.m. how can I do work in
one month when I'm too busy what okay that's actually true yes Johnny what
says 30 minutes before vodka's mute oh no I've got 30 minutes I thought I had a
freaking hour I thought it was 1155 is it changed don't be so selfish YouTube
servers don't be so selfish don't be so selfish grinding like a champ exactly I
be moving I'm doing up down left left right AB AB on that tentacle that's the
type of grinding that I'm doing okay VOD limit is 1155 yes on that don't play
with fire and risk the water do you want to eat my starfish do you want to
taste the cake if you catch you in my sheets with a piece bone what is that a
song was that supposed to rhyme that or was that just a question my my life
is like a video game always collecting coins I don't actually know that song I
just know like the collecting coins for my 11th hour every minute of every hour
stop it I get nervous YouTube you make me nervous stop it
no I actually am though oh my god YouTube stop ruining the fun okay I'm
gonna message YouTube headquarters okay and I'm gonna ask them I'm gonna ask
them kindly to extend the VODs for me only so the reason they took the made of
VOD limit was because of that Fanny that has that low-side girl that that poor
girl just studies all day I've never seen her eat I've never seen her cat even
interact with her that's the reason why YouTube took it away to her okay so I'm
going to start harassment campaign against the low-fi girl that I don't I am
definitely losing it slightly just a wee bit this game ass play not oh my god
don't confuse me I've been streaming for 11 hours I want proper grammar I want
punctuation I want a capital letter I want commas and full stops I want I
need perfect punctuation to understand your communication to me to make myself
clear delirious air streamer never see I can read that no problem good morning
momy good morning why do they call it the oven when you have in the cold food
no stop stop stop all right see you to play music you she wants the tall
reasons terraria maincraft honestly it's not a request you know me a pop-up on
terraria right now I'm afraid I'm not that kind of streamer I ain't built like
that you know I'm a fake I'm not actually playing this game this is someone else's
gameplay I'm so sorry to break it let's all write gibberish me Frank and Sariana
never stop that oven meme hurts even the same brain same brain not same brain I
mean we do share a brain so it's fine
yeah I did it Shawnee's never beaten the pre-recorded allegations I honestly
don't think I can pre-recorded soon what level are we at now a billion a
supersonic quadrillion which is a real number and two seventy three nine
but wait no that's not what my level is my level is 97 sorry it's 97 not to be
confused with the bite of 87 what do you want to say what allegations is a
pre-recorded law law teacher fallacy incubation
what are you even what is that the baby the big band version of Friday are you
squid me or or or or or or or mama it's been 11 hours since you started yeah do
you have a water bottle don't forget to check your posture and stretch okay I'll
go I'm a go I'm a go get a bottle of water
I don't have any war hey oh yeah hold on I have a cup
wait
I forgot that water comes out of peps temporarily there, okay, might have a cup of water, so
use it. Yeah, I wish that a funny voice would tell me a straight, I'll stretch
through. What did he say? Okay. Holy cannoli, so strange. Your puny mind cannot
comprehend the endurance of the cuttlefish and that's okay. We are small adaptive creatures
in the water, okay, have a glass, listen to that adaptation. I don't have any, I got water
in the water, okay, sleeping can. The old water tastes nicer, I don't care what anyone says,
I don't know why it's just as easy to drink, I said it was it. The world's tiniest but endurance
is massive. I thought that for my doughnathon I would do like 24 hours but I think I would
actually finish. I think I'd rather just become cohesive for cohesive, that means to put something
together. Or that composite bond. Don't drink tap water unless you have to. I think it's
like Melbourne, actually Scotland and like Melbourne are the locations where tap water
is fine. Coherent, not possible. Water tier list, Fiji has got it. Oh my god. I saw if
you walk up Mount Fiji you can get stamps on a stick and I wanted to do that because
that was kind of cool. I was watching VTuber do 24 hours of karaoke, how is there even
a voice at the end? She's confusing, coherent, cohesive and covalent bond. Yeah, any covalent
bond. I'm doing it, okay we're in the 7000, this is what I wanted. I got the end. It's
like top 10 quality, damn straight it is. If you walk up Mount Fiji you find all the
bottles of water they sell. Wait isn't, okay that's a brand, 24 hour winemaking, no. I
definitely start losing like brain power at a certain point in stream and I've definitely
hit it right now and I can tell I've hit it and food wouldn't fix it, like I need to
sleep. Super tasty sleep, super spicy sleep. Carrot and coriander, super power, fruton,
fruton and a munchie bowl, something like that. You're going for 2s the billion, wait
wait, why would I go for 200 million XP? Is that the record or something? Why would anyone
do 200 million XP if it's like 13 million to get max? Imagine paying for bottled water.
Look, I'll take my hydration where I can get it, if it beats the neon pee allegations
I'll take it. Sleep, upload pregnant videos and have another stream of them waking up.
Honestly, we're playing blinks and I'm like oh my god, I couldn't even get past the second
level as a child. I am pa re aying, I know what I'm doing. If not, we're going to be
watching a tutorial live at each level and then copy what the person does. 200 millions
XP cap, well congrats to those who got 200 million, I ain't doin' 200 million.
Can ASMRs fall asleep to their own ASMR? I like sleep aid stuff, but I'm sure there
is people who do, but for me personally, I watch gameplay of games and stuff. Love the
Blinks Centre, and before blinks is what Gen 2's unconfirmed OSU is about. About unconfirmed,
I mean Gen 2's unconfirmed. I know, I'm shocking, but it's actually not confirmed.
We're at 7.9, literally this number is going down. What kind of game is blinks? Saw it on
Game Pass, but also, right, so one, you're a cat, and then you've got a hoover on ya,
and you can rewind time, but you have to pick up gems in order to access what you can do.
You can pause time, you can rewind it, you can make it go slow and stuff. It's really weird.
Also, the ASMR train you guys planned, the other day was too good. Oh, I'm so glad. I'm
gonna ask the girls if we can do it once a month. I think it went really well. I liked it.
Okay, I enjoyed. Well, good night. Rest well, those who need to sleep. I'll join you in sleep
land very shortly. I'll haunt you in your dreams. I'll be like, you didn't watch until
the end of my stream. Did you, ya bam? No, I'm not gonna do that. I promise I'm not hauntin'
I am just as tired as you. Stop clicking that. That's the third time I've done it.
Drop it. Wait, I remember the game. Because of the hidden decimal, it is recorded in the
game as to which is just under the data limit. Okay. A cat with a hoover on it seems like
a terrifying existence. Johnny's already invaded my dreams. Oh my god, I'm the invader in Elden
Reign. But instead, it's your dream. I wish you would haunt my dreams instead of the women
who's currently hauntin' them. Oh, are you like actually getting nightmares? It's been
fun. I truly enjoyed the stream. I'll see you again, Johnny. See you tomorrow. Rest well,
those who need to rest. We play in blanks. Yay. And there's gonna be Prego ASMR up this
time tomorrow. Yeah, you have forced to listen to my Prego belly. I'll be like, ooh, I'm
so full and pregnant. I don't, I'm sorry. I love gettin' groomed by my favourite shumer.
Thank you. You're more than welcome. It's been an absolute pleasure to fully groom you.
Oh, my fellow Americans. Hi, Momay. Hi, B-Sling. You can haunt my dreams any time.
It's funny seeing people say goodnight while I just woke up. It's about to be four, no,
it's three-sixteen for me in the afternoon. I go to sleep with your girls at ASMR, so
I already have your guys' voices in my head. And soon you'll get a Scottish accent. Soon
you'll get a Scottish accent. There's one riflin' that I corrupted in the workplace
and he went, I, or something. And everyone was like, huh? And he's like, oh, sorry, I've
got a Scottish accent. Okay. That was an odd combination. Please don't do that again,
body. I think my body just took a fucking screenshot. That was a sneeze. A hiccup and
a fucking burp all in one. What? It's been a while since I've popped by one of your
dreams. Hi, hi. Unfortunately, you've popped in on the most boring one of all. I'm currently
delirious after streaming 11 hours of RuneScape. My voice is sore because I've been talking
for 11 hours and the RuneScape gameplay is this. It's removing water and grapes from
my inventory, then putting it back in the bank to ferment for XP. Sorry. I look forward
to more scrawny streams. Oh, yeah. I stream every single day because I'm addicted. Oh, I
can make the collage soon of all my streams this month. I wonder, it's probably going to
look a little worse because I couldn't do as much membership streams this month. Sorry,
scrawny, step a little bit. You're allowed to sleep. I'm not going to be mad. You're
allowed to sleep. I'm doing good. We're going to, we have a bit of a VOD monkaS. It's coming,
but I can't see the actual time because my OBS broke and it says I've been streaming for
six hours on my end because my OBS farted one time and it shouldn't have farted. Like,
like OBS, honestly, I don't know why you thought that was appropriate to do that to me. Like,
I thought it was the shit, but it's not even the fart. Like, it's just, you still stream
every day, so it will be peak. I hope so. It's peak gameplay though. I'm totally not
biased with an unholy amount of, or Brian, totally not biased with an unholy amount of
hours in RS. I'm glad you like the, the peak gameplay arcane ghosts. I mean, it's just a
riveting. What more could you possibly ask for truly? What more could you need? What more could you need?
Thank you, Brian for adding to that as well. It helps me so much that I don't have to use my brain.
Thank you for the super care. Um, I don't know if we should do fletching for the heck of it at
all. What? I have like 51k winds. I just thought that in the corner of my eye. Great. We have five more
hours to go. Chatting stream with RuneScape in the back. Literally, it's just yapping. I just, I have a
yapped nonstop. Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep. Mods. Five more hours to go until I'm done.
Look at that. 51 jugs of wine. Just a wee bit. Hi. You're the reason I'm attracted to
Scottish accents now. Yay! Thank you. Oh my God. Thank you, Jay. You like it? Oh, I'm
scrawny. And my accent's getting you a boner right now. Yeah, you like that? Yeah. Absolutely
God. Are you just popping and locking in your seat right now? You are locked in. That guy, me,
serving up hot, stringy appachinos. Oh, that's so good. That guy, me. I'll get a good sleep. Yeah,
I'll get a good sleep after this. Hello, Momay. I just woke up. I'm going to look at
his body. He's still streaming. Yeah. It worked. It worked. It worked. We're at 7.6. We might
be able to get to 6. I'm not sure. I'm going to be honest. I'm not locked in. I'm locked out
if anything. My brain is now outside my skull at this point in time, in all honesty. She's
too powerful. Actually, I'm as well. I'll see if there's any more marshmallow. No, there's
no more marshmallows. You've exerted all questions. I'm too much of an open book that
there's no more questions to be asked. I'm your name's scrawny cuttles. I'll be giving
Lance a hard one because of my accent. Actually, your poor lassie seems hilarious. scrawny, the
same. Watch it. It's 3.21 PM, sir. Thank you. And I'm going to sleep. And I take my whiskey.
Just don't push yourself too much. She's playing in third person at me. I've seen people do
accounts of that when they're like, oh, when I'm in surgery, I see myself in third person.
I saw myself on the operating table. It's like a phenomenon that your brain needs to
imagine a third perspective in order to protect yourself from the danger it perceives. It can
inject that. You can see people working around you and your brain puts the rest together.
We're just actually a smart little thing trying to keep you alive, honestly. Some of this
stuff needs to be stand back and pure awe of just everything. You should make a reverse
comfort ASMR. Mimosa from Yume Plus did something like that. Oh wait, wait, reverse comfort isn't
you comfort me. I'm thinking of reverse ASMR where I randomly scream in the mic. I don't
really do that. You're still screaming. Good morning. Good morning. Good morning. Or good
morning. Nah, I guess that I'm both G's. I've got a guy on it. Good morning, Kavanya.
Wow. The power of I heard my name. That's a reverse. Do you think they simply see it
in third person or it's like an isometric view? I don't even know what isometric means.
I'm sorry. My brain doesn't have that pathway. What is isometric mean? Isometric. Isometric.
All the Europeans are wake up. Okay, now let's say good morning in all the European countries.
Okay, first things first. Bonjour. Petit de Genre. I don't know. Isometric is top down.
Like the tabletops in there. No, that's not what that means. I got to immediately coax
it up. Literally. Good morning. Bonjour. It's bonjour. It's just like aloe. I think it can
be used in morning context. Say good in French. You say bon. And then say morning. You say
morning. Forgotten. It's 6am. I'm going to have to call it. Rest well. Sleep tight. Go
and let the bed bugs. Bye. Not that any bed bugs are biting. If anything, I'm the little
bed bug. Oh my God. Remember in the B movie where the lawyers like, are you shagging this
B in the B movie? Is that you've got a little bed bug? Is that objection your honour? I shagged
this woman. Why was she wanting to shag the B? What's going on? Does that need to be concerned?
That ain't worry. What a perplexing movie. I just remember at the end of it, it goes,
here comes the sun. Here comes the sun. And I'll say, and then I can't remember the rest.
Still think it's ridiculous she left her husband for a B? Like, oh, and the husband's
crunk from Emperor's New Groove. It's so surreal. And after that lawyer was stung, he had a baby
assistant, assisting walker. Rest well. Sleep tight. Stronia's a bed bug isn't biting, but
she's definitely stuck it. Oh my God. I'll be making your toes curl. My job as a baby.
She was after that stinger. 30 more minutes until nuke. Okay, thank you for keeping me
right, because I am not going to... A bed bug for Gen 3. You think I'm going to have
an insect? You think the odds of me having an insect are that high? The only insect
I have is insect seeds, which kills them, which is actually not very nice. I don't know
if it's been asked, but do you sleep with pajamas? No, I can't wear anything. Which has
led to Gimli fucking biting my ass to wake me up when I keep sleeping in too long. She'll
ask for food via biting on my butt cheek, and it's really annoying. She hasn't stopped.
It's really weird. She purposely lifts the cover up with her face and then bites my cheek.
It's ridiculous. It's absolutely ridiculous. Oh my voice is cracking. Holy shit, can you
hear that voice crack? Oh my God. I have... Oh no, have I broke my voice? I hope not.
I need to record that fucking... Oh, I think I'm... Okay, I think we're back. I think we're
back. I think we're back. I think it's okay. I definitely need some ink supply. I'm just
telling you now, okay, refling, I need some ink to soothe my throat. I do. I do, I do,
I do. The voice has yapped enough, truly. We're getting there, we're getting there.
But we're made. I'll check Marshmallow in a minute just to make sure I've not missed
anything. You should probably stop once you go under 70. Oh, but if I keep pushing...
Ah, just pushing. Pushing real good. Ah, just pushing. Ink in the tea right now, do it.
Night night, rest well. Thank you for hanging. Bonne nuit. Bienvenue. Bon voyage.
S, seor.
30 minutes and then we're at the mark. We only have time to go under 60, but I'll just
I'm better to do more. Keep voice crack, I hope it recovers for all the other projects,
honestly. It'll be fine. I just shut up. Okay, I don't really talk, well, I mean, I spoke
to Sin the other day, if that counts as talking. I mean, yeah. That kind of has to put Sin.
I can't, but it's the more you've got.
You would like to know where our CASA is. Spanish lessons from a Scottish one. And to say
my house, my home is your home. You say, mi CASA, ay, t CASA. Yeah, you're a
Scottish Spanish teacher. Mami, please don't leave. Can we start a part two? I'm so sorry,
I would do it if I could. I don't feel very well. I'm a bit delirious. I'm sad. It's okay.
We'll do a finishing up stream and we'll finish all of this, I promise. Actually, is there
even anyone we can redirect him to? I don't think so. We may casually redirect him and
be like, yeah, I just did a 12-hour stream. But I love when the streamer's like, oh,
but yeah, that's it. And I'm like, oh, just 12 hours of room. Yeah, that's pretty good.
Yeah, no, I'm just chilling. We're just hanging out at the reef. I'm not going to
have a TV on. What the fuck is the bot in the corporation? Well, let's say, instead of
saying sayonara, haha, you're saying hi at the reef lane. Get up. I am so funny. Please
clap. Don't clap. That was awful. Mami, you have 50 minutes until the bad stuff starts
up. I can do it. I can do it. I can do it. I can do it. I can do it. I can do it. Yeah.
Okay, we're at 7.3. We're at 7.3. Come on, come on. You wish to trade with me. What do
you wish to offer me, dear reef lane? If it's a crusty sock, you're done for. If I accept
this trade and it's a crusty sock, you're done for. That was an outfit. Are you dressing
me up? You're dressing me up. I use it. Sanguishly, I mean, I mean, I do be cooking in the kitchen.
You want some? I do be cooking in the kitchen. I mean, shit, look at the drip. Look at the
drip. Look at them pixels. Look at them polygons. God damn, this game is stunning. Look at the
drip. Right, pop that stuff on. Thank you for pimping me out. Look at the drip in those
polygons. You can see literally every polygon is fantastic. Truly, you can admire every little
triangle that went into this game. It's gorgeous. Housewife strongy, is that what it's supposed
to be? Is that what it's supposed to be? That's actually what it's meant. Okay, let me take
Marshmallow. Sunny, I love you all the way to the moon and back. Did you know if you, I love you to
refling, did you know if you stretch out the DNA sequence, like if you did it like bit by
bit, it would reach the moon and back. That's what it should be like. Okay, the problem with getting
ink in the throat is you first have to ravage it before getting the treat. No, you need to be
nice to me. Don't be mean. I need medicine. You have to be nice to me if I need it for
medicinal purposes. Okay? That's, that's, yeah. Please continue your marination and get some
to this. Oh, my marination because I stank. Okay.
Oh wait, I don't think I have to read this one out loud.
Aw. I want to hear your reference opinion on it since I can't see. Oh, you want me to read
it out loud? Wait, hold on. I need to read this one. I actually need to use my brain
to listen. Hold on. Okay, I'm here. I want to hear your and the reason's opinion on this
since I can't see it. I don't know. Is it? Okay, hold on. Okay, okay. I'm sorry about
this post, right? Don't be. Don't be. You're just telling it how it is. But I feel like I
have no other place to see it. I want to send this now while I still have the courage. I am
scared of expressing myself, whether I have, it was met with ridiculing humiliation, whether
it be in real life or online. I was especially bad in secondary school when I was bullied
for factors I couldn't control such as my height or even just as my name. And it made
me super insecure. I have trouble communicating with people and it has unfortunately got more
astute to these experiences. And I have a dislike of talking to people. However, Vealer
has changed this. I've never seen a community so accepting of others regardless of their
interest. You've inspired me to express myself again. I want to hear your and the reason's
opinions on this since I can't see everything I want to see in one Mario. I want to send
some more. Is it wrong for me to do this? Because I want to send, no, you can see what
you want in my marshmallows. If you need to use it as an outlet, I honestly don't mind
at all. Get it out. It's better to see what's going on than to keep it inside. If you keep
that shit inside, that won't fuck you up. I'm being so serious. I literally had a meltdown
on a membership stream and then surprise, surprise, the next day I came online and everything
was fine. You're literally allowed to feel bad. You're literally allowed to feel your
emotions. You're literally allowed to have a bad, you don't have to pretend. This isn't
a workplace where it's like, how are you? And you go, yeah, I'm fine. And then deep down
inside, you're dying. No, that's not how it works here. And I'm sure all the reflins
agree with me. That's not how it works here. How are you? And then you tell us how you
actually are. That's how it is. You can be shy stuff. You can be just in the trenches.
If you want to use my marshmallows for that, you are more than welcome to go ahead and you
have full permission. You and any other refling for that matter, okay? And even for a lurker,
if you're like, shit, I ain't calling myself a reflin. Man, it's a cute name, okay? One,
it's a cute name. Two, fine. Everyone is allowed their opinions. If it's wrong, but...
Whoa, where am I going? Damn. I just really wanted to admire the drip, apparently. Oh,
you got lions on your back. I put myself in front of the bank. Oh, and I'm interacting
with the bank. You have to start somewhere. Ten minutes before noon. Oh, no, she can't
hear us. Okay, okay, okay. Someone says, boo. Oh, I'm scared. I'm baritized. Can we brush
our teeth together? Fuck, no. My toothbrush. It's in disarray. Mommy, what's your opinion
on facial hair? My opinion? It doesn't bother me. Have you been like a preference? I don't
really have preferences like that. I don't like preferences like, please be fat.
Nuke incoming. Dany ago? Wait, Dany to go? Duh, actually, I need to go. Is that going
to be the last thing I say before I go? Dany to go? Dany to go? Is it nuke time? Is it
nuke time? Don't force feed me. You need to stop. You have 15 minutes. You've got 20
minutes. Wait, why are you telling me to go? You're scaring me. I don't know if the
boat's popped or not. Yes, nuke town. It's been 1130. Okay. Okay, don't do that. You're
scaring me, really? Mom, why should I? Yeah, I don't really have an opinion, to be honest.
Strongie, the world of Pandora is so beautiful. The animals in the blue cat peep people. Also,
the wonder of the nature is perfect for the humans and RDA to harvest and exploit. Freaking
manatee, RDA, RDA. No, Strongie, I just want to say no, no, no, no. You're not getting any
Scottish age. I'm too tired to R wordy, okay? Mommy's too tired to R wordy. I'm not even
kidding today. I don't know why it didn't show up, but I was offering a Shanie and
Pokemon. Oh, thank you. I've not played New World's Pokemon. We know if you start
yapping again, you won't stop and then I'll be in yet. No, this cannot be. No, no, no,
no. Base refilling. You start stream about 10 minutes late today. I was 10 minutes late?
No brushing, she hates us. No, no, no, I'll do it to brush it. I can't do it. No, I don't
have time. I don't have time to go and get my two boys in the government. But I do it
before Ben. Imagine you just need to be fat and then end up, literally, literally. I thought
I thought that was what I was going to be. Okay, let's check the bank for how much water
and how much, oh my God, it's ruined. Wait, why are you, who's money dropping? Who's flexing
their fat stacks randomly? Just drop it. Brev, look at, look, go refilling. I'm going to take
this stack. I'm going to keep it a buck 50, okay? I'm going to yank real, like, I'm going
to keep it a buck 50. Stronning has terminally affing disease, honestly. Refilling tried to
rifle Stronning, but she's too tight. I literally am sorry, but I can't do it. I don't have the
anger in me to take it out on you. It just means we've got to brush what we see for it.
Oh, we just did that for me. That was just super easy. I'm just like, you keep my, my
key. I'm going to keep it a stack. Oh, I love terminology. I love that term. I'll keep it a
buck 50. What does that mean? What does I will keep it $1.50 mean? I'll keep it a buck
50. I'll keep it $1.50. What does that mean? What does that translate to? I'll keep it
$150. It means the money don't lie. It's a reference to Costco keeping their hot dog combo
at $1.50. No! I failed you. I failed in my American lore. Are you joking me? I normally
know all American lore. I don't. I lied. Are you kidding me right now? I want to give
my peace on that. I want to give my peace on that because I too am pretty lonely, but
you guys are my reefling brothers and Stronning brought us together and
I'm grateful. So you mean we're starting an army? Maybe a social uprising? Perhaps against
the high table. Thank you, Revive, for the super chat. I'm glad we can all keep each
other company. This world can get lonely if you don't reach out. But when you do
reach out, you'll notice that people all reach out with their hands too when
grab you. And you just got to sometimes do the... You gotta get through the awkward
bit where you gotta reach out. And yes, awkward but hey, that's human. Thank you,
Arcane Ghost. Now wait a minute. I've said your name today. How did you do that twice?
I don't know. Thank you for coming a member. Our brothers in the reef today,
Unity, would be lore-wise a wonderful bit. Who is the table? Why does everyone say
hi to them? Honestly, that's what I need the FBI agents to ask when they show up
at my door. The Cosco Fender threatened to perish the CEO if he raised the price
of the hotel combo. They're duplicating. Someone made an art about the Reefling Army
too. Wasn't that not the boat one of you guys in the background? Why did I not see
it? Can I not see it? Glory to Strony here. Glory to Villalor. Here, here.
Nastrovia. Clink. Oh wait, I have a cup that I can make a clink noise with. Glory to
Villalor. Nastrovia. Yay! Abranovich or something, I don't know. Okay, we almost made
it. The Cosco Hot Dog combo. I'ma keep it a buck, 50. Amen. Don't risk the vodka.
Is it time for me to go? Glory to Vsucki. Look, it was a good cost. The Suckibish
were running amok and they're contaminating the blood of other people. Look, it would
be a good cheesy anime, okay? Cool, but strong. A little over 60 minutes left, I
really hate pee. I'll fire 1000 CEOs before I let this company raise the price of a hot
dog. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Right, let me get to 6000, okay? Let me get to 6000. I'ma
keep it a Cosco Hot Dog and we'll do it when it gets to 6000 and then I will go to sleep.
Go to sleep. Go to sleep, my dear wee friend. Go to sleep. Go to sleep. I don't know what
I'm doing. I don't know what I'm doing. Freerooja ca, freerooja, dormee do. Oh, are you
having Scottish freerooja ca? Freerooja ca, freerooja ca, dormee do, dormee do. Sonny la
matina, sonny la matina, ding, ding, dong. That's absolutely purse. Stop it. Drop it.
Can you tuck his in? I don't know. Can you fuck me in? Like, I'm sorry. That was an
inside thought. That was for inside my head. I apologize, Riefen, for such vulgar obscenity.
Apologize. It was a slip of the tongue. I'll fire 1000 once before I let myself go over
but to stop. Okay. Do I need to go? I don't know when I need to go. Hitting on the back
streets. The blitzkrieg bop. Hey ho, let's go. Putting on the back line. Something else
they're all ripped off and ready to go. Okay, we might be able to get 6.8. Do you want me
to stop or do you want to make out what would you like to do? The choice is, I don't want
to be a fan. Speedrun, yeah. Are you trying to slip your tongue in the fucking? I'm the
I'm the one that tongues me, motherfucker.
Haha, okay.
Maybe one more inventory and then I go a bit.
Look at that, bub.
Under 69, that's the number, okay?
We are under 69.
I am going to go.
Will I use my ending screen?
Are you ready?
Okay, wait until the inventory is full and then we'll wait for the wine to pop,
okay? We just need the wine to pop.
We're about to pop, oh wait, I only have like 14 wine.
Okay, there's the wine to pop.
Okay, you ready?
What was I gonna do?
I've forgotten.
I don't know, I forgot.
Use the ending screen.
Oh, okay, yes, I will.
Okay, um, good night.
I love you.
I see you tomorrow and please, when you see the pregnant city,
go up, click on it and leave it in the background for the algorithm purposes.
And then wait a whole like 30 seconds before you like the video or something.
I don't know.
Good night, everything.
I love you.
I see you in the morning and we'll play Blinks,
which is a childhood game technically,
even though I got stuck on the second level.
Well, the second level.
Well, are you ready?
Look at that.
Honestly, look at them jibblies.
Streams ending.
Good night.
Reflings.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Good night.
Bye bye.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, kiss.
I will talk in the streamers chat for one second
and then I'll go a bit again and go a bit.